[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
s
for this cozy coastal town the holiday
season isn't over
in fact the most wonderful time of the
year has really just begun bear Kings on
the board in a handshake what a hold for
Wesley so just didn't give the world
champion a chance
once again vikon Zay starts the new year
as the center of the chess Universe this
year as host of the 85th Tata steel
chess tournament
a magnet for the best players in the
game some recognize the Masters field of
2023 as its strongest in recent memory
of course it helps when eight-time Tata
steel chess champion Magnus Carlson is
back Magnus is going baseball if Magnus
plays like this the rest of the way who
knows what can happen the world's number
one looks to further cement his legacy
in this event and the game's history
chasing Magnus will be amongst the best
in chess several have been crowned
Champion here before some have even
shocked the world in doing so
don't leave out those poised to capture
their first Tata title Anish Geary is
just I mean he beat both world number
one and world number two in the same
tournament
although winter Tata steel chess is also
known as the place new stars come to
bloom Magnus one here is a teenager this
year's event has its fair share of young
players on the rise each hoping to
follow in Carlson's footsteps motorbeck
keeps his lead with a solid
well-prepared draw against Gary the
Dutch referred to Tata steel as The
Wimbledon of chess for 85 years in
running this tournament continues to be
steeped in Prestige and Legacy and does
so again in this welcoming Little Dutch
town by the sea
mind Brendan it's the 85th edition of
the Tata steel chess tournament and it
starts right now
foreign
you to the playing Hall in Vikings a
today is the penultimate round of action
it is round 12 of 13 at the Tata steel
Chess Masters the 85th Edition we have a
great show in store for you four players
are within Striking Distance at the top
of leaderboard and I'm Grandmaster
Robert Hess alongside me is my good
friend Grant Master Dan laradiskey Tanya
your dearbeck Abdus atariq remains in
the lead but three players are right
behind him with the chance for first
place indeed they are happy Saturday
everybody what better way to spend the
weekend than watch the home stretch of
Tata steel when there are long
tournaments Robert there's always a fear
in Die Hard chess fans Minds that
somebody's gonna pull away there's gonna
be a breakaway performance Magnus
Carlson is going to be leading by Four
Points no such thing in 2023 Notre back
might be leading but he more than has
his work cut out for him
he certainly does this is the weekend
the final two games Saturday and
tomorrow's Sunday round is a bit earlier
but will be the final day a bit action a
bit earlier two hours earlier but that
we have to wait till tomorrow to talk
about because we're gonna first discuss
yesterday's action uh there were many
draws only one win that was by Parham
maksubu over Prague Nanda and that's
good news for nordier back abdusatara
the status quo works very well for him
Dania because he has had a half point
lead
yeah he is more than happy to exchange
straws and some incredible opening
preparation on display totally disarming
anushkiri playing a queen scan but
accepted drawing from a position of
strength and Magnus Carlson just was not
able to break down Wesley so prepare it
was a day of great opening preparation
with the black pieces and as you said in
order to break up this is more than
happy to Coast into the end of the
tournament withdraws as long as those
who are pursuing him in particular Anish
giri and Magnus Carlson also make draws
and yesterday he got what he asked for
he did he is in first place with seven
and a half points out of a possible 11.
Anish Gary sits behind with seven out of
11. that's a great score for him and
Magnus Carlson Wesley so they are tied
they were locked up in a heated battle
it was a hard-fought draw yesterday they
are a full point behind but within
Striking Distance so Donna it really is
about those four mathematically speaking
levonne Ronin 501 and Richard report
have a chance but they have to have
everything go their way so it is about
the top four at this late stage in the
tournament
it really is and as you say the cards
could fall in a crazy way we could see
Fabiano caruana atop the tournament
standings but the cards really have to
fall in a historic fashion for that to
happen but let's not forget that those
in the second half of the tournament
cross stable they always have the power
to disrupt the top of the tournament
standing that is really the magic of
these tournaments you could be in 12th
or 13th Place but with a well-timed win
you could change the completely the
landscape of the tournament going into
the final round and speaking of the
penultimate round let's review today's
pairings Robert just mouth-watering
matchups all around it's like this was
specifically designed to maximize the
hype
oh yes because Wesley so is one of the
four players we were noting on this
leaderboard and he takes on the leader
no dear Becca if you couldn't have
scripped this any better if you're
Wesley so they have never played each
other in classical chess they play each
other a lot online but let me ask you
Dania what does West need to do to take
down nordierbeck who has not lost a
single game well Notre back is double
blacked Wesley has to avoid the
narrative that we saw yesterday he needs
to avoid some sort of forcing
theoretical line he needs to try to get
noderbeck out of his preparation and get
the kind of position that Wesley excels
in quiet strategic he kind of needs to
play like Vincent kymer did uh who came
really the closest to defeating notrebek
of do Satora if you look at that you
think oh it was an easy draw no it
wasn't lost in a rook end game and
Vincent was able to squeeze him
throughout the game as we review a
couple of stats here at their first
crazy that it's their first classical
meeting Robert crazy in a good way
that's what we like to see
yes but there actually is many games
between these two Wesley so and Abdul
sitarov they duked it out in the speed
Chess Championship both in 2020 and in
2022 so that means they have a good
amount of experience trying to figure
out opening to take advantage of their
opponent's weaknesses and with that that
should be good news for Wesley so as the
more experienced veteran player you'd
like to have history you'd like to have
many games behind you and that way you
can use that to your advantage you can
try to figure out where do you go to
take down the staff who has been
unbeatable to this point he has indeed
but I think notrebrecht has to tell
himself he has to avoid catastrophizing
because if he loses this game to Wesley
his tournament does not end he still has
a chance for first place and he will
have the white pieces in the last round
and as we saw there there could be a
four-way tie for first place if in fact
Wesley so is able to deal Notre back his
first loss of the tournament that would
be an absolutely Wild final round oh my
goodness Robert how nervous would all
the players be if four of them had a
chance for first place not least of
which is the world champion was riding
an incredible comeback that he initiated
with three wins now in the second half
of the tournament
well the Uzbek teenager wants none of
that because the tournament can end here
and now if a few results go his way
including his own game against Wesley so
then abdusitar can secure the 2023 Tata
steel title if Jordan Von Forest beats
anushkiri and Prague Nanda does not lose
uh sorry if he defeats or draws Magnus
so yeah if he does not lose to Magnus
then abusitarov wins the 2023 toddler
steel Masters so Abdus tariff he has the
black pieces it's not easy to beat
Wesley that guy is as difficult to crack
as anybody on the planet but if he does
win and those other results go his way
he could end today as the tournament
winner
yeah of course all three of those things
happening at the same time is unlikely
Prague uh has to hold Magnus Carlson and
Jordan van Forrest has to defeat Anish
Gary that is our second Marquee matchup
of the day Anish giri has been Rock
Solid in this tournament as well and of
course Jordan benforest faced anishikeri
in the rapid tiebreaker of the 2021
taught us deal with Jordan van Forest
won so Anish Guri not only has a chip on
his shoulder Robert but your invent
Forest has struggled this tournament
he's had some bright spots he held
Magnus Carlson you know yesterday he
held dangly Ren from a position of
strength with the black pieces and he
actually leads their overall series
against Anish giri's uh one win and
three draws so he's been Rock Solid
against the niche but it feels like the
air is different this time
it is a different year a different event
a different Jordan van Forest Jordan has
dropped four Pawns in different games in
this tournament Anish giri has been the
complete opposite he has done nothing
wrong it seems and he is unbeaten he is
in second place he can LeapFrog the
tournament leader if Abu sitar were to
lose and he swore to win and in fact
with two rounds to go Anish can assure
himself at least a tie for first if he
wins both of his games and abusot does
not do the same so Anish giri he doesn't
completely control his own destiny but
with the black pieces against his
compatriot the pressure will be on him
and for Jordan Von Forest we've seen
some great opening surprises he has
worked with Magnus Carlson as a second
no uh no deer Beck in this case it is
Anish gear who needs to be very careful
when facing his compatriot and friend he
does indeed and in these situations each
player chooses the amount of risk that
they are comfortable with for Anish giri
I don't think he's comfortable with too
much risk he's playing one of the top
opening Specialists of our time I think
he's going to play the chess the solid
chest that we are accustomed to and the
cards will fall as they may and Robert
obviously a lot depends on the other
matchup so a lot is out of anishikiri
and Abdul satorab well out of distorts
control but Anish giri and Wesley sows
control
that's right and Magnus Carlsen does not
have control over his own fate he needs
to take down prognananda who is
struggling mightily in the back half of
the tournament prognanda has lost I
believe three out of his last four games
Magnus is on the rise he has won three
out of his last five so Magnus is in
good shape and just to run us through
the next four matchups they still are
going to be fun ones even if they don't
take a place in terms of who is going to
win the tournament five in a car wanna
with white against Vincent kymer the
youngster from Germany has played a
better second half he has not been able
to win positions where he's had huge
advantages gukesh on the other hand has
lost a bunch of games early but has won
a couple late and he takes on Lavon of
ronian who has been as solid as a rock
has not lost a game to this point with
one win in his record haramax Zulu won
yesterday he gets Arjun aragaisy today
Arjun three losses no wins the rest of
the games have been drawn so Parham
would like to make the most of his white
pieces and Richard port and dingley ren
it's a battle of a Wiley Richard report
against a solid dingly Wren
unfortunately for dingley Wren the world
champion Challenger has not had his best
event dropping below 2800 and we see
here a busy tariff starts the clock we
are off Dania Wesley so has not made his
first move what are you expecting no
he's just sort of taking his time and
chilling well first of all he has a lot
of time to chill we already know the
time control it's a hundred minutes uh
440 moves and then an additional 50
minutes for 20 moves and then 15 minutes
on move 60 and a 30 second increment
plenty of time to ponder his opening
Choice One D4 by Wesley so now the real
question Robert is going to be what
noterbeck plays because yesterday
against Anish gear we saw a Queen's
Gambit accepted which is more Uncommon
at the highest level than a queen's game
declined or a slav is he going to trust
his preparation and repeat the line or
is he going to deviate and play one of
the other red beautiful continuations as
he casts a bloodthirsty look up at his
opponent C4 not forced but Wesley plays
it well we won't get a London system
tonight somewhere in a deep dark corner
Eric Rosen just uh cringe just a little
bit and he does repeat the Queen's
Gambino
decision from the youngster because he
played this yesterday which means that
Wesley so was expecting it he looked at
it in his preparation and for Wesley
what he's doing right now I don't think
is oh I'm so surprised what do I do here
he has faced this many times before he
has played it with the black pieces as
well he is just trying to figure out
where he wants to take this game because
a booster tarp did not have to repeat
his opening they did yesterday so the
question is what does nordierbeck expect
from Wesley you were just pointing out
the move E2 to E4 that's a main choice
in this position but you don't have to
push that pawn all the way up you can
start with Knight C3 if you'd like you
can play Knight F3 to take away the
response that no dear brick played
yesterday with E7 to E5 so there are
different avenues that Wesley can go
down and I feel like he wants a more
solid game and he does not want
nordierbeck to rely on Preparation
that's the last thing you want when
you're playing somebody who is in the
lead and only needs a draw you do not
want him to go 25 moves deep Down A
variation he is prepared that's exactly
right I actually think Wesley he wants
to play a rare move sometime in the
first 10 moves take Notre back out of
his comfort zone get him to use his own
brain you mentioned e2e4 that was the
choice of Anish gear yesterday it led to
a very forcing line that Notre back was
very well acquainted with they quickly
got into an end game Anish giri never
really had serious winning chances
Wesley continues to ponder his next move
now when you mentioned Knight C3 Knight
F3 uh the recommendation of some recent
opening courses is the immediate E2 E3
it may seem nonsensical to block in the
dark squared Bishop but the benefit of
pushing the pawn more modestly one
square is that you are securing the pawn
on D4 in response black does have the
move E5 but that leads to a
fundamentally different type of position
compared to E4 and Wesley has made a
move and let's see what it is
yes the early stages of this game is
about the definition where this game
will go you push that e-pawn you would
like to play E4 but we saw not everyone
played E5 and he had it all worked out
against Anish giri so for Wesley and we
see they're making a couple moves we'll
make sure to get that on our boards in
just a few as a you see no deerback
responding instantly I mean he is going
to be in his preparation and he when he
is he's going to play instantly I feel
like he's the type of player that you
know when you have him out of book he
stops playing at the speed of light and
he doesn't play those psychological
games that are sometimes recommended
where you take you know three or four
minutes to try to fool your opponent
into a false sense of security oh I've
got my opponent out of prep notarek
isn't interested in that if he's well
prepared he is going to play in
instantly and conserve time and I like
that straightforwardness I'm going to be
honest with you Robert I'm actually a
bit surprised that he repeats the choice
from yesterday perhaps even Wesley is
surprised because we are so used to
players trying to dodge preparation at
all costs and playing different things
every round not effect doesn't want any
of that he believes in his analysis he
believes in his opening files and I like
that as well I think having faith in
what you analyzed before the tournament
is important now you do see a Pawn on E3
so Wesley has indeed opted for the more
conventional and the more modest
approach he's recaptured the pawn on C4
and notorbeck counter-strikes in the
center with C7 C5 Robert this is as old
as the Hills this theory has existed for
decades now
it is and we see that no dear Beck he is
unfazed he continues to make quick moves
and we can show the current position uh
because
um the position has changed at first you
take this Pawn on C4 now that pawn is
gone so let's just take a step back go
through it move by move because on
White's third turn I think it's already
important to show what Wesley did here
uh he made them Knight F3 it's one of
the ideas that I had mentioned because
in the game yesterday between
E4 right and after the E4 was played
Black played E5 so the move Knight F3
takes away this option and says we're
gonna go down a different path today
because if you play E5 the Knight simply
captures thank you for the Free Pawn so
I like what Wesley did but of course
Noir Beck was expecting this and that's
why he's playing so quickly and he
responded with Knight F6 and you don't
normally want to try to cling to the C4
Pawn you can do that but white normally
strikes at the pawn chain with A4 and
then wins the pawn back anyway with
interest and so you take the Tempe uh
that white takes to recapture the pawn
and get your own pieces out claim your
own share of the center which is exactly
what noterbeck does with C7 C5 and then
he follows up with the move A7 A6 the
point of this move is to cover the B5
score but also to prepare Queen side
expansion with B5 and this is another
major fork in the road for Wesley so
there is D take C5 transitioning the
game into a very complicated end game it
may seem totally symmetrical but do not
be fooled uh by the sort of pedestrian
appearance of that end game there are a
lot of Rich ideas for both sides but a
recent uh recommendation that I have
seen in some opening courses is actually
Knight B1 to D2 which may seem very very
odd but that closes down the line of
communication between the queens and and
the point is to meet C takes D4 with
Knight takes D4 and then potentially
bring the other Knight over to F3 I'm
not too familiar with the opening
intricacies here whereas you can also
play a2a4 and simply prevent black from
playing B6 in that case Robert you often
see blackfee and ketoing the bishop
anyway uh but doing it in more modest
fashion with B6
and A4 is a committal decision because
you're taking away the B5 push that
Dania was just mentioning but you give
up that B4 Square for the rest of the
game and else the B3 Square so if the
Knight jumps to C6 and over to A5 it
also go into B4 those dark squares over
on the queen side become blacks for the
taking and then there's some
vulnerabilities that white has to keep
an eye on so Wesley has had this
position before and as you are pointing
out there's D takes C5 offering the
queen Trade West Elite may have a slight
Edge there he may have some experience
but he may also think that doesn't
really give me enough chances to win and
I need to take down the person a full
point ahead so he doesn't take on C5 he
can play A4 as mentioned you can play
Knight bd2 he can play Bishop B3
pre-empting that his Bishop would have
been attacked uh with the move B5 so if
you Retreat your Bishop to start with
that means that after B5 you can strike
with A4 and go after uh the pawn that is
overextended so there are so many small
details that play a major role in how
this game takes shape and for Wesley he
has many options right now I'm very
curious if he prepared deeply in this or
if he's just going from memory and from
experience right now done yeah it's so
hard to predict in these types of
situations what players are thinking
about well you can say for a fact what
they're not thinking about he's not
thinking I'm seeing this position for
the first time let me try to figure out
you know what the main move is here he
knows this he's analyzed this and you
know he's probably analyzed this many
many years ago for the first time so
he's just probably trying to figure out
which direction he wants to take the
game in maybe he already has made that
decision before the game and he's just
making sure that he remembers everything
stealing himself for uh what will
indicate the type of position we're
gonna get because as you said this
decision is extremely committal choosing
whether to go into an end game is not a
decision that you want to take lightly
not at all and because I do think that
sometimes in many of our viewers
probably have this feeling themselves
that going into an end game means we're
going to make a draw or we're more
likely to make a draw but taking on C5
which is I believe what Wesley just did
um that doesn't mean that the game is
just suddenly going to Peter out it's
not an end game even it's a queenless
middle game where both sides have all
four minor pieces and both Rooks so if
we just make of the moves that are
happening uh yeah we just updated the
board here you see that black lost the
right to Castle and I think we should
show a white black did not trade on B1
but instead we took out C5 first because
I think that's an unfamiliar sight for
most people like why in the world would
you not take on do you want reserve your
right to Castle this is the end game so
often the king belongs on E7 anyway so
why give white that Tempo to go ahead
and get the Rook to D1 so if you think
about it
this could happen in the game with the
King already on E7 because if the Rook
comes to D1 the King goes up to E7 and
essentially saves black a Tempo so every
Tempo is of importance and in this end
game the king actually wants to stay in
the center not gets quote unquote safely
castled and Wesley's next move may also
cause some eyebrows to be raised Bishop
C4 to E2 what in the world is he doing
dropping his Bishop back from what seems
to be an active Square well first of all
C4 isn't too active of a square it's
just sort of biting on granite but this
move is actually prophylaxis prophylaxis
is the art of stopping or taking the
sting out of your opponent's threats and
ideas in this case we've mentioned the
idea of Queen side expansion with B7 B5
Wesley ensures that this move does not
come with Tempo and as a result of that
he has the time to CH to chip into
Black's Pawn chain with a very nasty
move A4 and if you can force black to
play P4 not only does black no longer
have access to that square but look at
how many weaknesses black now creates uh
black is now created on the queen side
there's C4 and A5 the Knight could
quickly drop into C4 and very often you
want to avoid this type of Pawn
structure so you might see Notre back
play B5 at a later stage when he is
ready to support that pawn or not push
that pawn two squares at all either push
it one square or find alternate
arrangements for his light squared
Bishop so Robert this is just the tip of
the iceberg but I think people can
already start to see how much nuance and
how much richness there is despite the
outward appearance of total symmetry in
this end game yeah Pawn pushes are ones
that you can't take back right that's
how chess Works once the pawn goes
forward it cannot Retreat so pushing the
pawn to B5 would be a decision that you
do not take lightly and here I think it
would be a mistake it's not an objective
mistake I don't believe I think it's all
right for black but I think from a
practical point of view it makes White's
task much easier and black task much
more difficult because if B5 is played
as you were noting you strike with A4
very quickly and if you ever take on A4
the pawn on A6 becomes a target white is
more developed let's just count how many
pieces are out white has three minor
pieces developed compared to just two
for black and the white king is Castle
now we were just talking about the king
in the end game is happy to be in the
center and that is true but in certain
positions if the board opens up then
that Kink could fall victim to say a
check on the A3 diet from A3 or
something like that so you just do need
to keep an eye on the king I like the
move Knight C 6 for black just
developing you can play Bishop D7
connecting your Rooks and I think that
black may be just a bit behind white but
the position remains quite solid so I
think that I would prefer if I were
playing this position to be more solid
rather than throwing my pieces forward
and I'll say two things and then perhaps
we should take a look at our bird's eye
view because we have some crazy
developments in our other Marquee
matchup between jbf and Anish Geary
first of all I love openings that have
withstood the test of time that have
been played for decades and decades
because then you really see the you know
the contribution of all the individual
chess players to our understanding of
that position we stand on the shoulders
of giants and this end game occurred for
the first time in 1939 actually Miguel
neidorf who is well known for a
different opening was just a third
player to opt for this end game with
white and to capture on C5 the first
person to play the move Bishop back to
E2 on move nine was zenko koshal a very
well-known Grandmaster from Croatian he
did that in 2001 so it took 60 years for
players to realize that moving the
bishop back is the most effective way to
take this thing out of B5 previously a
lot of players were automatically
pushing the a pawn up with white of
course as we've already talked about
creating a serious hole on B4 so Robert
we take these things for granted but it
took decades for even the strongest
players in the world to develop a kind
of nuanced understanding that we now
think everybody has
yes we rely on the shoulders of our
predecessors the Giants of the game that
came before this generation and this is
the type of position that will not be
solved with sheer preparation look at
your back abusotarov look at that camera
shaking I think that internally This
Heart might also be shaking because this
is such an important game he has won an
Olympiad gold medal for his country
Uzbekistan he's won a World rapid
Championship when he was just 17 years
old and now he has a chance to win this
classical individual tournament ahead of
Magnus Carlson Anish giri and the rest
of these stalwart competitors so it's a
big moment for him I think we should
leave him to think and why don't we head
right over to the game between Anish
giri and Jordan Von Forest because these
two friends and compatriots while they
know each other quite well by how
they've worked together they played
against one another today they are foes
and look at Anish he is thinking about
the position right now Jordan has shown
great preparation Time After Time In
This Very event he has worked with
Magnus Carlson as a second he has
trained Magnus Carlson for a World Chess
Championship matches and that experience
is invaluable it means that he is very
creative at the early stage and Dina
this is a clear illustration of that
there is a pawn out on H4 this looks
like a normal position but for some
reason White's eighth move was pushing
that pawn up two squares on the Rooks
flank and this epitomizes Jordan's
willingness to do two things the first
is of course to play moves that uh with
an untrained eye may seem outlandish or
bizarre and the second is that when you
turn the engine on at a low depth uh the
engine disapproves of some of Jordan's
opening choices yesterday was a great
case in point he had a king coming out
to E7 when you turn stockfish on at
first it gives white a huge Advantage
but when you leave it on for a long time
and these players they will leave a
computer on his position for days
they'll leave it on overnight they'll
have two different types of engines play
each other uh in a position so their
opening preparation is so much more
nuanced than just turning on the
computer and seeing the evaluation and
making a decision in five seconds and
here we have that again when you plug H4
into the engine Evo bar actually gives
black a slight Advantage but Robert in a
position this complex that is entirely
meaningless and I think it's safe to say
Jordan is aware that the engine might
disapprove of this move that actually is
what makes it so dangerous and so
unlikely that Anish giri is aware of its
existence so if we can rewind now just a
couple of moves we saw Magnus Carlson as
saying this very same regosan line uh
against kukesh that's Bishop F4 black
opting for the prescribed theoretical
method immediately sticking a knight on
e4 and then bringing the other night out
and the rationale behind H4 Robert is
that if you play the natural move E3 you
fall prey to a very nasty idea where
black simply pushes G5 and a tribe and
you might say well no problem at all
what you think I'm gonna let you trap my
Bishop no no no I'm gonna play H4 but
then black grabs the bishop on G3 and
white has to accept just the total
ruination of his kingside Pawn structure
E3 and G3 are horribly weak so H4 from
that perspective is a totally natural
move it just looks really really odd to
play that move on move 8 in a regozen
and done it if we go to the live
position it's an exchange sacrifice now
because there's a very forcing sequence
Knight takes Knight on C3 right now and
after Pawn takes C3 uh because white has
no choice but to take back Bishop A3
actually wins in exchange The Rook is
under attack directly if it goes to A1
the bishop slides into B2 hitting the
rook in the corner and the pawn on C3 to
boot that wins material for black but
this is Jordan's idea he is willing to
sacrifice materials and each Geary takes
off his Blazer a bishop A3 will be met
by the move Rook to B1 and the point is
clear after Bishop takes Rook
Queen takes Bishop
we will see that Queen on B1 stare at
the B7 pawn and if you want to keep that
pawn and push it up to B6 you lose the
game on the spot because white has a
light Square Bishop black does not
that's a pin the Knight jumps into E5
pretty much premovable and you are going
to win that night and win the game with
two minor pieces for a rook and just a
dominant position so this is what Jordan
has in mind here it's a risky choice
because you have given up material and
you're not getting it back anytime soon
but look at the play the free-flowing
nature of his pieces at some point that
Knight he's going to land on G5 you beat
me to a partner the bishop is coming out
the H7 Pawn is a target if white uh
excuse me black ever pushes a Pawn on
the king side that H4 Pawn will be used
as an attacking piece wow and that's
right is deep in thought right now he is
looking at his position he knows he can
net himself some material but is it
worth it especially because Jordan has
prepared this and it feels like Anish
has it this is absolutely fascinating
stuff and you can totally see why Anish
hasn't grabbed that exchange yet just
looking at this position with the
abundance of White's ideas on the king
side and on the queen side of course why
it has a very well protected Pawn on D4
there's that C4 Pawn lever that could be
used at a later point to get rid of
blacks only Central Pawn that's usually
the downside of positioning the Knight
on C6 you aren't able to play the move
C6 in order to support D5 so there's no
question that Jordan had this exact
position at home and that he has
analyzed the heck out of the resulting
ideas
Anish Guri those thoughts are
circulating through his mind he might be
telling himself I know for a fact that
Knight takes E3 and Bishop A3 is going
to be the computer recommendation but do
I want to go for a position that Jordan
has analyzed extensively and the answer
is yes Anish giri has grabbed the Knight
on C3 and I think it's safe to say
Robert that he will follow up with
Bishop A3 otherwise this move makes no
sense positionally I guess he could also
drop the bishop back to D6 but then I
feel like he's probably at least
slightly worse
yeah though the pawn on H4 is maybe not
the most useful move to include so if
you feel like you wasted a turn so to
speak I bring your Bishop to B4 and then
back to D6 white threw in the move H4
which actually may be more harmful than
helpful so if a niche gets worried or if
he just doesn't see how clear the
exchange sacrifice is uh Jordan has
taken back on C3 of course because
that's the only move here uh Bishop A3
it's a big decision and it's just
enough to visualize a couple moves it's
hard to assess and you know that Jordan
has looked at this with the Silicon
friend with the engines and that is a
scary proposition for anishkiri
it is indeed the idea that Jordan is not
only aware of the best moves but also uh
is aware of the ideas when you reach an
unconventional position a position in
which sort of the conventional wisdom
doesn't really apply this isn't a
typical structure that you get out of a
rogozin where white is down in exchange
and has a king side attack then the
player uh who has a more nuanced
understanding of the resulting ideas not
just of the resulting moves is the one
who stands uh to succeed so you're
absolutely right Bishop A3 I thought was
a given the more I look at it the more I
realize that Bishop B4 back to D6 might
actually be a prudent decision even if
black is nominally worse in the
resulting position but it does seem
quite a bit easier to play for black and
let me ask you an important question so
after B takes C3 just if we put the live
position uh up to date what would you do
if you're in each carry you're half
Point behind abusot you definitely don't
want to lose no matter what tournament
no matter what the standings are and
he's never wants to lose no chessler
does but do you think he says this is my
moment like I need to take a risk if I
want to win the Tata steel Masters for
the first time he's been a five-time
runner-up he is tired of second place
and well it might be the moment to say
Jordan I know you prepped this I am
going to call you out I'm gonna test how
strong this is for white let's go
I think Bishop A3 is the likeliest move
and I think what you just said right
there is exactly what Anish giri is
thinking also just concretely I think if
he drops his Bishop back to D6 and
Jordan grabs it and plays C3 C4 Black's
position just isn't fun to play there
just aren't that many winning chances
objectively and I I really think that
this is the time for Anish to take a
serious risk Jordan has displayed his
vulnerability in this tournament he is
beatable in this tournament and uh I
think the common expression having said
a you have to say B I really think it
applies in this position but obviously
Anisha is going to invest some thought
into this question and there he goes
Bishop A3 on the board I love it yes and
for Anish he may be on his own but he is
such a strong player he can find the
engine moves he can play very strong
chess uh the position is just starting
Jordan will play Rook B1 and you see him
and he already has very quickly
The Rook on B1 makes sense you win the
light Square Bishop for the cassia rook
and we know that Rooks are worth five
and Bishops are worth three or three in
a little bit uh but in a position that
doesn't have many open files the Rooks
can't show off their mic whereas a
bishop in this position look at the one
on F4 staring all the way into Black's
position the bishop coming from F1 to D3
along with the queen on B1 will stare
all the way towards the black king side
so I feel like the Bishops are very
strong and anise recognize that but I
also believe he's looking at this like
I'm skeptical I believe you have
compensation but he knows that black
can't possibly be worse he prepared this
variation up to a point and if this H4
and E3 line wasn't top recommendation he
knows that he is better and that's good
that's it feels good to know that you
should not be worse
and I think it's important not to
overstate the case it is likely that
Jordan spent maybe an hour or so on this
resulting position but obviously he had
no way to guarantee that Anish giri or
anyone in this tournament would go
specifically for this position let's not
forget that Bishop F5 and Knight to C6
the way uh Anish handled the bishop F4
variation is not the only way uh to
respond to this line so it's likely that
Jordan looked at this position but
unlikely that he knows it for another 20
or 30 moves with that being said this is
already an important decision for a
niche how is he going to defend the B7
Pawn you pointed out that B6 is out of
the question so Rook V8 is one
possibility but you could also decide
not to defend the pawn at all and
instead to prioritize other aspects of
the position such as your development
you could choose to Castle kingside but
then you have to reckon with the Knight
Sally to G5 followed by a quick H5 in
response to G6 I would already be
terrified Robert if I had this position
against Jordan Ben Forrest but there is
a very good reason that I'm here and
Anish giri is there but we are in for
some fireworks in this game
we certainly are look at Anish he is
left alone to his own devices and his
own thoughts it will not be simple for
him to figure out the way forward uh
it's a really complicated position and
Jordan could use the clock as a weapon
it's very early going we the round
really just got underway but you start
to feel that pressure when your opponent
has more time than he started with
that's the case for Jordan Vogue Forest
Jordan has won this tournament before he
won it in 2021 and he beat Anish giri to
do just that so I feel like a niche he
he knows how important this moment is
for his chess career he probably feels
some uh unfortunate history between the
two where it was supposed to be a
niche's title Jordan was he was supposed
to be at the top of the standings back
in 2021 but it but it was wrestled away
from him it was a topsy-turvy Armageddon
game that Jordan did in fact win so a
niche you look at him shaking his legs
this is critical time for him
he's just played a fantastic tournament
I keep repeating this every day Robert
it Bears repeating who has he beaten in
this tournament has he just beaten the
the players at the bottom of the
tournament standings no no no he
defeated dingley Ren who is
unfortunately in the second half of the
tournament cross table world number two
and he also played a sparkling game
against the world champion an
unforgettable display of opening
preparation and then end game prowess he
knocked Magnus Carlson out of the
ballpark and any tournament in which you
beat the world number two uh the world
number one and world number two is a
tournament that you are going to tell
your grandkids about and what a fitting
end it would be if Anish Gary managed to
surpass the tournament leader with a
clutch performance in the final two
rounds so he knows the gravity of the
moment and uh he grabs his hair with his
hands he's going to think about how and
whether he should defend the B7 pawn and
maybe that affords us a good opportunity
to have a look at some of the other
games what do you saying let's do it and
well one very important game is that of
the world champion Magnus Carlson he
takes on prognanda in the bottom right
hand side of our screen I just want to
note in the top left Wesley so against
Abdus atarov a few moves have been
played abusotage Bishop light Square
Bishop is out to B5 so it went via D7 so
he prioritized the bishop development
before the Knight and we're still in a
queenless middle game with plenty of
Life there but Donna what do you say
should we go to the Magnus game because
Magnus he's looking at those other
boards and he wants anishikiri to not
win his game and Wesley so needs to stop
Abdul sitar cannot keep winning if
Magnus hopes to retain any chances of
taking home this tournament title indeed
Let's Travel to Magnus land and of
course Magnus Carlson has double whities
white two games in a row that is
entirely normal for round Robin's
notabeck of course uh is the one who has
double black in rounds 11 and 12 and
funnily enough Magnus once again has an
isolated Queen on structure just like he
did yesterday against Wesley so you
might remember uh that he pushed that
pawn up to D5 at some point it led to
Central liquidation they traded a bunch
of pieces and Magnus who never really
got off the ground here you have a
fundamentally different type of position
because the pieces are developed to
different squares and uh yesterday of
course was a nimzo Indian here we see
Prague positioning a Pawn on E6 trying
to slow down the potential progress of
White's deep on but the downside Robert
is that that Bishop on C8 looks kind of
like a French Bishop
superficially I kind of like White's
position in the early going yeah a big
difference between yesterday's game and
today's is that the dark Square Bishop
is still on the board for black and
white has both Knights and that's really
useful especially with this isolated
Queen Pawn uh because you look at this
Pawn on D4 you may say it's a weakness
it can be targeted another Pawn can't
defend it but it actually is very useful
because if you look at the E5 and C5
squares those are under White's control
so that Knight A4 Knight C5 maneuver may
be in the future for white a rook would
like to come to the C file because
inherent to having an isolated Pawn
means that the adjacent files are open
for your Rook so the ENC files are
useful for Rooks to be placed on and I
just want to add Daniel that I think
it's tempting in a position like this to
try to break the pin as soon as possible
that Bishop on G5 is really frustrating
to deal with so let's just make the move
H6 for a second because I want to show a
change of Pawn structure Bishop takes C6
check I think will be played and the
reason why is if that Knight wasn't
pinned the bishop would be captured on
e4 so that's why you take on C6 the Pod
takes back and you look at the resulting
Pawn structure it's kind of ugly for
black A6 and C6 both isolated and very
importantly the bishop on C8 is kind of
blocked its path by its own pawns so
you'll have to spend more time making
moves like A5 Bishop A6 and in the
meantime white will Castle bring a rook
to C1 bring a rook to E1 then maybe even
a knight to E5 and go after those
eyesores on the queen side
I think there's a great description of
course first why we'll take care of
business on the king side and I would
imagine the Magnus will try to keep his
dark scored Bishop on the board and drop
it back to H4 G5 is nothing to worry
about in fact uh it like plays G5 then
he has to deal with weaknesses on the
king side as well so if we in fact get
this type of position both sides will
probably castle and not only do I think
that white is clearly better at this
point but his position and I think this
is what you're getting at is so much
easier to play the pieces are just
asking to be put on the best squares
Knight F3 to E5 you mentioned Knight C3
to A4 to C5 all of these Maneuvers are
just very standard fare for prognananda
he's gonna have far bigger fish to fry
here and harder decisions to make such
as how does he solve the problem of his
Bishop how does he make sure that he
doesn't lose the C6 Pawn so I'm with you
I actually think H6 is very unlikely I
don't think this position is appetizing
in the least and if we go back to the
live board well if you don't play H6
well then into you Castle do you allow
white to take on C6 and change the
structure or do you bring the bishop out
to D7 that may seem like an awkward move
and it is but on the other hand you take
the sting out of Bishop takes C6 these
are not easy decisions for prognananda
Robert and I think it's also safe to say
that he is out of his preparation this
was a symmetrical English and as we know
the symmetrical English is one of the
richest openings out there and that it
can lead to just a Litany of different
Pawn structures and there's a major
downside of Bishop D7 it blocks the
Queen's path in the D file which makes
the pawn push D4 to D5 all the more
appealing for white when you have an
isolated Pawn like this you often think
should I push it forward to trade it off
sometimes that results in Mass
liquidation like we saw yesterday
against Wesley so but with more pieces
on the board there are more threats for
white to execute on so I think that
prognada has to be very carefully and
this is a very quick variation that I
want to show let's just make the H6 move
again and just bear with me for some
second Bishop C6 check Pawn takes D6
Bishop takes Knight on F6 the bishop
takes back and Knight E5 if black takes
that Knight on E5 I think that Black's
already strategically lost you have a
terrible Bishop maybe you can hang in
for now but look at those juicy dark
squares F6 and D6 and if you trade
Queens just to finish the line or the
type of position I want to talk about
this is the worst possible end game you
could get white has all the fun zero
risk at all and those dark squares that
night's gonna be hopping into all of
them so that is what prognado wants to
avoid the reason he's calculating at the
moment is because he sees this future
and it's not one that he likes so it's a
big decision for prognanda right now and
just how the game is going to go
that's a great line and you're the Rook
can come to D6 the Knight can come to F6
or vice versa you take the stake I'll
take the lobster surf and turf that
Bishop on C8 even if it manages to come
out to A6 that diagonal A6 F1 that's not
not really where the action is at so
it's not only about just putting your
piece on a square where it seems to have
square control that piece also has to
stay relevant you know so ideally black
would put the bishop on B7 but here
nothing is possible because white has a
vice-like grip on all of the key dark
Square so as we go back to the live
board as prognananda Ponders uh his next
move already some very important
decisions to make for black and I think
this is exactly the kind of position
that Magnus wanted to get out of the
opening I'm not suggesting that he's
necessarily better objectively you can
see the eval bar feels pretty skeptical
but
correct me if I'm wrong Robert this is
what Magnus wants a rich position with
uh a lot of positional prospects and
definitely with all of the pieces on the
board there is a lot of room to outplay
your opponent
yeah at least for the near future it's
going to be more difficult for prognana
to make individual moves coming up with
a plan and we should take a look at the
head-to-head history between these two
because much has been said uh probably
not a beating Magnus in the Champions
chess tour he beat him quite a number of
times in the CCT but they've only played
Once In classical chess that was last
year in tata steel Magnus won that game
I feel like he has some extra motivation
to beat pragananda just because of all
the hype around those victories and of
course for this specific tournament
Dania if Magnus beats prognanda he may
in fact find himself in the tie for
first place if Wesley takes down
nodirbeck indeed so once again the cards
have to fall a certain way for Magnus
Carlsen to complete uh his incredible
tournament comeback lest we forget he
set at -1 what seemed to be just five
seconds ago and he has won three games
in the second half of this tournament as
Carlson there gets up from his chair
leaving us with a view of all those
Spectators crowded around uh behind the
barrier but there's also a generational
component Robert in terms of Magnus
having a chip onto his shoulder when he
plays talented Juniors like Prague like
Notre back he definitely wants to show
uh that the older generation that the
Old Guard still has a couple of miles
left in the tank but as I said earlier
always fascinating to see uh these types
of matchups just because they never get
a chance to play each other so we have
no idea how the game is going to go and
Prague he really needs to pull something
magical out of his hat because he has
been struggling in the last couple of
rounds losing three out of his last five
games
a tough stretch for him and no opponent
is easy no walkovers in this event and
your reward for losing a para maxulu
with the white pieces is to get black
against Magnus Carlson that frankly just
stinks but it's a good experience for
him he is not going to be winning this
tournament that's prognanda but he had a
great start and he would love nothing
more than to hold off magnets in this
game but it's a big moment I do think
we've talked about the options Bishop D7
Pawn H6 you can also move the Knight
away to E7 but why don't we move away
from this game because probably likely
we'll be taking this move very seriously
and he'll spend some time here so why
don't we zoom out to our bird's eye view
we instead of all seven games underway
just getting going for the most part
what's catching your eye Dania you know
man well we see that end game and Wesley
so Notre back developing handsomely
that's a funny little construction there
with the Knights on C4 and D4 and then
the bishop similarly adjacent on B5 and
C5 Wesley has brought his Knight to D4
and put pressure on motorbike's light
squared Bishop now we don't have to go
to that game I'll just point out that
taking the Knight on D4 gives White's
dark squared Bishop Prime real estate
with a potentially deadly check on A3 on
tap so I think it's safe to say we're
gonna see uh notorbeck maintain that
Central tension and perhaps take the
other night on C4 but we've got plenty
of other fascinating games I'm looking
at maxoulu Eric icy that's a very sharp
what seems to be a grunfeld uh with the
queen on B4 hitting the bishop hitting
the pawn on B7 and in karawana kymer
we've got a also very interesting open
Rue Lopez Vincent that's lower left of
your screen has just Advanced his Pawn
to C4 and opened up that C5 Square uh
probably for his dark Square Bishop so
I'm gonna narrow throw it down Robert to
karawana kymer and maksudlu aragaisi and
Report ding which is also a fascinating
Sicilian but between those first two
which one would you opt for I got this
covered for you partner let's go to the
game between five and a carwana and
Vincent kaima and the reason I'm gonna
take us there is a very fascinating
opening Choice by the young German
Superstar kymer he's a teenager he works
with Peter lecko we're used to Fabiano
caruana coming up with great opening
Novelties but if we just go back several
moves after 11 D4 uh this position may
look familiar to our more experienced
chess viewers this is as standards as it
gets in the Roy Lopez it's a closed
variation where oftentimes black just
puts the queen on C7 make sure the pawns
are defended before action heats up in
the center of all my lands look at what
Vincent played to my eyes I don't recall
seeing any game with the move D5 Connect
Four game has been one from B5 to E5 and
look at how explosive this is
I'm looking at this move and my brain is
just giving me a blue screen of death
the only thing I can say before we
actually delve into this move is that
right about 10 11 years ago and I've
played this line with black for many
many years so I feel like I'm pretty
familiar with most of the ideas I've
never seen D5 but in this type of
position I guess with the pawn on D4
rather than D3 black uh was playing D5
at a certain moment I think here with
the pawn sitting on D3 and guarding E4
D5 in this position just doesn't make
sense it drops the E5 Pawn but if we
play these moves on the board D5
actually makes a lot more sense here
Robert because the E4 Pawn is now Under
Fire so if white plays D take C5 which
carwana did the Knight takes on e4 and
the structure starts to resemble in open
relope this is why I thought that's what
it came from if white would have taken
the pawn on D5 then I think Vincent's
idea probably would have been to
recapture on D4
and then capture the pawn on D5 maybe
with a queen maybe with a knight but
this position to my you know totally
inexperienced eye just looks completely
fine for black that White's good Bishop
can support the knight from B7 and so
carwana decided to keep some more meat
on the bone he played Pawn takes E5 and
this looks like a full-fledged opening
idea by Vincent geimer
damn looks like it's worked to
Perfection based on the clock management
we had to cover up 30 minutes Risa
Fabiano being ahead in the clock with
his Stellar prep and as we continue this
game the Knight when the D2 the bishop
went to F5 and look at this there's this
tension on the E4 square and Vincent he
kind of ignores it and the reason why is
that if white tries to get greedy by
taking on e4 once black takes back and
the Queens are traded I need to take
with the bishop first on e4 because
and I'll explain why in a second but
once you uh get Bishop takes E4 on all
the swaps that you were just going for
uh then the problem is if you try to
take the E4 Pawn you're in trouble on
the first rank The Rook comes to D1 yes
the white Rook can drop back but once
you swap Brooks the E5 Pawn is lost
black is certainly no worse in fact
black is better with activity of the
minor pieces uh the pawns same amount
better activity for black I would prefer
that black even if the position is level
so just position that Vincent clearly
has studied deeply and he is temporarily
sacrificing upon Fabi knows better
instead of taking it he brings his
Knight back to F1 Donya I mean we could
look at uh some of the captures in the
center if you'd like though if I may I I
thought you just made a fantastic Point
Bishop takes E4 is a very important move
and these are the types of nuances that
you have to familiarize yourself with uh
if you in fact want to play one of these
rare lines and succeed if you play Pawn
Tech C4 it looks like it leads to the
same line but notice that the bishop on
F5 is a loose piece it's undefended so
here white could actually bring the
bishop out to F4 and taking the Knight
really is ineffective because you give
up the bishop pair and control over the
light squares in the center so you're
absolutely right Bishop takes E4 uh is a
very important detail here but as you're
saying instead Fabiano caruana shying
away from uh the mass Liquidation in the
center bringing his Knight back to F1 a
very common move in the open relopez the
Knight and then the Royal Lopez in
general the night thread threatening to
swing forward to E3 and put more
pressure on the D5 fund Vincent ignores
that as well he plays the move C4
opening up the C5 square and he's saying
that 93 just isn't dangerous because of
Bishop E6 and so Fabi changing his plans
just a little bit and instead brings his
Bishop out to E3 Robert I think he's
eyeing that juicy D4 Square which really
is White's greatest positional asset
Vincent he is still playing instantly
he's playing prophylactically and that
this is another very circumspect move
Knight D4 now gives up the E5 Pawn
well it's interesting so let's just go
back a half step there with Bishop
instead of Bishop G6 let's say black but
H6 the throwaway move I just want to
show that after Knight D4 and we swap
Knights on D4 because the bishop 105 is
under attack so you can't take the E5
pawn and after Bishop takes we cut the
board in half you know I love doing that
we have an extra Pawn for white on the
king side there are four to three and
white is gonna storm those pawns up the
board and go for an attack whereas
Black's Pawn the extra Pawn on the D
file is cemented in place firmly
blockaded and that's a huge Advantage
for white the pawn Mobility leads to an
edge so that's what Bishop G6 was played
but done yet it's not the end of the
story because after the game moved
Bishop G6
white can play Knight D4 anyway if you
take on E5 white has this move Pawn to
F4 and it looks like you're winning a
piece with at Pawn F5 I really wonder
what Vincent has drummed up here uh
because from the look of it if you could
get away with Knight D4 I'm starting to
appreciate White's position more but I
know that Vincent has deeply studied
this variation and he is not going to be
scared
no this is a great point I think Fabi
will play Knight D4 if he realizes that
the pawn on E5 is still Untouchable
maybe Vincent wants to trade on D4 and
then try to get his other Knight back
around to C5 and then again forward to
D3 we talk about White's biggest asset
on D4 well black has an equivalently
juicy outpost on D3 so as good as the
Knight on e4 may appear maybe you want
to find even greener pastures for it now
it is true that Black's Queen side pawns
are far less mobile than their
counterparts on the king side but there
is the possibility of chipping away at
White's Pawn chain with B5 before
obviously not immediately maybe first
after the exchange on D4 but there is
some meat on the bone on the queen side
but in general I agree that you would
not want to go for this position without
very deep preparation because from a
purely conceptual standpoint black has a
weakness on D5 why does the stronghold
on D4 and I think someone like
capablanca or a world champion in the
pre-computer era would definitely eval
evaluate this position in White's favor
let's see what kinds of concrete ideas
Vincent can bring to the table to
counterbalance that
and I'm being informed that this game
actually follows some correspondence
chess and this is not D5 was not a
novelty in fact it hasn't played before
and this bishop G6 move is a very good
choice and was used by Reiner young
against Carson Schmidt back in 2021 so
thanks to the team working hard behind
the scene to bring us that information
and in that game Knight D4 was played
and Black's response was Queen C8 so it
might just be a coincidence that this
was played in uh
by German players but either way it's
akimer knows what to do here so why
don't we leave Fabiano caruana to the
task we have some very important
matchups that are just heating up
including this game and when we return
from this break we'll dive right back in
to the likes of Wesley silver snow
Rebecca bustarov and Jordan Von Forest
against Anish Kyrie because that game is
particularly spicy we'll be right back
in just a few
interested in becoming a chess streamer
like your favorite creators such as
Hikaru Gotham chess and the bow tennis
sisters come on
chess.com is excited to announce the
community streamer program
whether you're just getting started with
streaming or already established and
looking to expand your audience you can
now connect your account to chess.com
and have your stream promoted on the
game's largest platform
simply link your account at chess.com
settings slash connected accounts set
your category to chess on Twitch and
start streaming you'll get an ad free
experience on chess.com you will pop up
on our list of live streamers your
trust.com profile will feature your
Twitch stream the and your stream will
be linked to your games on our play
server type command Community streamer
in chat and start growing your stream
today
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
back to the playing Hall in Vikings a
there is anishikiri with the black
pieces against Jordan van Forest this
matchup is a repeat of the 2021 tie
breaks the playoff between these two Was
Won by Jordan Von Forest it was an upset
it was a heroic effort for Jordan the
Dutch faithful was very proud to have a
champion from the Netherlands for the
first time since 1985 that was Jan teman
and Dania we know that Jordan Von Forest
the lower rated between these two
somehow has an eastery's number in
Vikings a one win for Jordan In
classical chess with three draws but no
losses and I'll just add that Jordan is
part of a chess playing family I'm
pretty sure his parents play chess but
more prominently his brother Lucas Von
Forrest is a Grandmaster and his sister
maxed out one Forest is a very solid
player as well I think she's over 2 000
and as a lot of prospect so your bed
Forest definitely grew up in an
environment that fostered uh the kind of
Mastery and the kind of commitment that
he has displayed throughout his chess
career and what preparation he has
displayed in this game he still has an
hour and 42 minutes that is more than he
started with we are now on move 19. this
is modern chess in a nutshell Robert but
more importantly we have a lot of
developments since anishagiri accepted
the exchange sacrifice so perhaps we
should start by rewinding a couple of
moves uh and showing what Anish giri
decided to do after benforest recaptured
the bishop on B1 first we had Rook B8
protecting the pawn on B7 the most
natural move and the first sort of big
decision Robert was Bishop A3 back to D6
anishkari sacrifices back a pawn in
order to get some pieces off the board
what do you make of this
well I think it makes a lot of sense
because the other choice was Bishop back
to E7 instead of Bishop of D6 but that
gets a bit passive and white is still
going to develop naturally with Bishop
coming out to D3 and will try to put
pressure on Black's King side so Bishop
D6 is a bit more forcing it gives back
some of the extra material to make his
difficulties feel a little bit less
troubling and queen takes D5 Bishop
takes F4 we're going to pause here for a
second because the Queens are staring at
each other if you trade Queens then
black is maybe just winning already the
end game will be terrible for white uh
without the queens of the board because
you are down a rook for just a bishop in
one Pawn that's five points for black
four points for white but more
importantly there are weaknesses left
behind in White's Camp so Queen E4 check
is an important move to
keep the queens of the board and after
Queen E7 once again the Queens are kept
by Queen takes a four but Dunya it looks
really risky for white because of what
Anish did in the game over here with
Queen to A3 going after the C3 pawn
queen C1 check is a big threat but
Jordan had this worked out he brings his
Queen all the way back he has studied
this variation and it's really wild
stuff with the Knight hopping around now
but Jordan
look at this one hour 42 minutes and 16
seconds on the clock he has more time
than he started with Dania for this
incredible really crazy position and
then after night E7 came out to D5 this
is an uh implicit draw for Jordan could
go back to E4 but no the the reason he
played uh this line is not just to uh
end Matters by forcing a draw he plays
another move that I would never play
without extensive reparation C3 C4
another move that creates weaknesses on
the queen side Anish could jump into B4
Jordan is ready to part ways with the A2
pawn and in some variations he might
have to bring his King out to E2 so what
a rich position this is and ichigiri is
down to an hour on the clock and he once
again has a vast choice of moves now the
fascinating thing here Robert is that
Anish could force the Queens off the
board he does have the move Queen C3
check but it's very important not to
make uh overly broad generalizations and
to say for example that anytime you're
down in exchange trading Queens is bad
after the Queens come off the board as I
understand it Jordan has first of all a
pawn for the exchange so the material
advantage itself has been diminished but
more importantly white preserves the
Integrity of his Pawn structure the
Knight on C3 might get in some trouble
and uh White's domination in the center
White's Superior Pawn structure in the
center may offer Jordan an excellent
practical compensation so Queen C3 is
one move night before has to be
calculated perhaps then the queen will
drop back to E4 forcing the king to f8
and there's other moves Queen A5 truck
Queen B4 Chuck I can identify at least
five viable candidate moves that Anish
Guri has to sort through in this
critical position
and I would be playing Queen C3 checks
so quickly here because after the after
the Queens get swapped on C3 just to put
this position on the board because I
think it's very instructive uh the
Knight gets to C3 and once the Knight is
there the A2 pawns under attack if you
save your A2 Pawn by pushing it up a
square black has this move Pawn to B5
let's bust open that file so The Rook on
V8 develops in place King D2 would be a
very useful move except for the fact it
might be one check or 94 check is good
but I was looking at Knight B1 Checkers
oh you could just win the A3 Pawn
directly the shoes are really good for
black so if we take a step back after
Queen C3 check and this is what Anish
giri and Jordan Von Forest have to do is
maybe Jordan's gonna play King to D1 a
ridiculous looking move but now if the
Queens get traded
the Knight can't jump into C3 and if it
goes to B4 the King goes up to the B3
Square Geez Louise
number two kicks the Knight back and
look at White's healthy Pawn structure
it is a pawn and a bishop for a rook and
white just has great control over the
center Mobility for his pieces you see
the eval bar saying that not only is
white not worse it might be even better
for white because the Rooks are not
connected and they don't have open files
to work with and that's the key point
the re you don't get an advantage just
because you have two Rooks and your
opponent has one the Rooks also have to
have prospects and they don't have any
prospects yes the D file is a semi-open
file you can put your Rook on d8
congratulations it's just staring at
this rock hard Pawn chain uh on you know
F2 E3 T4 and that pawn chain is as one
wise man said as strong as its base Pawn
how are you ever going to get to the F2
Pawn or even the E3 Pawn for that matter
so Jordan's idea definitely is to trade
on his own terms King D1 is a crucial
move and this may sound like a vast
exaggeration rubber but it really isn't
you have to be aware of the move King to
D1 when you sacrificed your exchange on
move 11. so this is the extent of
opening preparation that these players
display this is why chess has become
such a difficult game unbelievable
yeah and the line doesn't even end there
just to go through one little variation
in this position Queen C2 King C2 we
just showed the Knight before check it's
tempting to give that check but instead
the Knight should probably Retreat to F6
because from there it's going to hop
into E4 or into G-Force if Bishop D3 is
playing I think black will play Knight
to G4 to go after the F2 pawn and very
importantly is something we were
discussing that if the Rook goes to
defend it with Rook F1 black should
probably make of H5 and then Rook H6 the
Rooks need activity a rook lift is fun
for everybody and it still says the
position is balanced I don't know how to
assess it I don't know oh I think I
would prefer to have the black side of
this position because if you make an
inaccuracy when you're down material
sometimes things go from just completely
decent to out of hand with just one slip
so I feel like it's a very very
complicated position the Evo bar
hovering around the center and down to
the players well I would say they don't
know but Jordan does know he's in his
preparation anisha's trying to work this
out over the board and the ordin's now
built up a 45 minute advantage on the
clock it may seem insignificant now but
wait until a niche Gary drops down uh to
to 30 minutes the phrase that some lazy
chess commentators like to use in these
situations is dynamic equality I think
this is a good illustration of dynamic
equality the position could not possibly
be more asymmetrical both from a
material standpoint and from a pawn
structure standpoint nothing about this
position is even or symmetrical but both
players have their fair share of chances
black is up on Exchange and if black can
open up some files he might seize the
initiative white of course we've talked
about the compensatory factors that
white has a beautiful Pond Center very
well developed minor pieces so the
chances that both sides have are
different in nature but they kind of
balance each other out and if you're
more familiar with ideas than your
opponent in a position like this then
you've got a big practical advantage and
I think it's safe to say that Jordan's
H4 novelty has been successful even if
Anish giri manages to navigate his way
out of the chaos he's going to do so uh
while standing far behind on the clock
and who's to say that Jordan you know
that his opening file doesn't go another
five six moves that's pretty terrifying
prospect it's anishkiri puts his head
down in his hands to visualize the
position better and he is going to
continue pondering this very important
moment it's very frustrating to play
players who have studied an entire line
nearly 30 moves deep and you talk about
this player often he's your friend
someone you've worked with a Chess Sam
shankland he is renowned for his opening
preparation and when you feel like
you're just going up against the Silicon
beast but in human form it's no fun and
I actually had a game against Sam
what year was it 2011 so 12 years ago
now where we played this game he
finished the entire game with more time
than he started with and it I had white
and he made a draw without breaking a
sweat and maybe even two games he did
that and it's really you know not a fun
Prospect when you're sitting at the
board dealing with that but you also
have to tip your cap off to players who
really put in the work and you study the
lines and come up with ways to make the
game more interesting for Jordan right
here he is clearly within his
preparation based on his time
consumption or lack thereof so why don't
we leave Anish gear to the task we know
that he has several options with Queen
checks with nighth hops but we'll come
back to this game because the game
between our leader no dear Becca Abdul
sitarov and Wesley so is taking a turn
the game is changing in nature uh the
position may still be balanced but if we
can go to that game between abusitarov
and Wesley so a big decision was just
taken by the Uzbek teenager he captured
a knight on C4 so he gives white the
bishop hair it releases some of the
tension in the center but he does give
white his first long lasting positional
advantage of the game as you're noting
the last move was in fact Bishop B5
takes C4 and I did briefly mention why
taking the other Knight would be a
terrible idea you do not want to give
white a monopoly on the dark squares
this bishop is actually what stands
between black and a devastating attack
against the king the king is still in
the center and even though the Queens
are off the board white has plenty of
Firepower to orchestrate a decisive
attack on the king if the circumstances
are right so Notre pick takes the other
Knight how is he going to follow up
after Bishop takes C4 I assume B take C4
is not on the table but actually one
benefit of this awkward looking move is
that it gives the Knight a retreating
Square on B3 I keep mentioning the
prospect of white Stark Square Bishop
coming out to A3 well that is an idea
worth fighting for so I think BC
actually might be on the table and
Wesley is not recapturing immediately
but if he makes natural move Robert how
is notabeck going to continue
rearranging his pieces he's going to
bring a knight to E5 is he going to
double Rooks on C8 and one of the main
questions that neuterbeck has to wrestle
with throughout this entire end game is
he going to push the pawn down to B5 and
grab space on the queen side
well Bishop takes C4 I do think that's
the answer the pawn will go up to B5 so
from that vantage point I actually like
pawntix C4 it hurts White's Pawn
structure you'll have two isolated pawns
on the queen side but you open up the B
file for a rook that B7 Pawn can be a
bit tender so it actually just quickly
go B take C4 you can see the pawn on B7
is the end of the line for a rook to go
to and if you push that pawn up to B6
now because the bishop is still sitting
on E2 that Bishop can hop into F3 and
that's big trouble for Black Knight C6
check would be a fourth winning material
and you do not want to part with your
other Bishop that seems like a losing
proposition as well so I'm not something
that Notre back would like I think B
takes C4 is just more challenging
because Bishop takes C4 just to show how
black would continue so we see our
alternative B5 the bishop drops back to
E2 and I actually think that after
Bishop E2 black can maybe take this
Knight on D4 we don't really want to
give up the pair of Bishops but if you
take with the pawn you have an isolated
pawn and a black knight will just sit on
D5 that's really strong for black and if
you take with the bishop I think Black
Goes E5 to kick that Bishop out of D4
and there's Rook C2 to follow so black
gets very quick activity for the cost of
candy white the bishop pair actually
concretely the reason why he does not
lose a bishop as a result is that he's
got the intermediate check on A3 our old
friend makes an appearance this is
definitely one way Notre Beck could
respond to Bishop takes C4 another way
uh is is to play the move Rook to C7 as
I mentioned previously get the Rooks to
the C file and actually just prepare the
move B5 and the problem with White's
position is that he just doesn't really
have ways to make inroads in the center
that pawn on E6 is obviously an
important Cog in the machine because it
covers the F5 Square the a pawn covers
the B5 square that Knight on D4 is
sitting pretty or so it seems but it
doesn't really have jumping off points
it's just sitting in the center but a
piece isn't well placed just because
it's in the center it has to have
concrete Prospect so from the
perspective of mixing the game up and
actually creating some sort of imbalance
I really like the move B take C4 I
didn't notice at first that that move
opens up the B file but now I see its
appeal Wesley could just go after that
B7 Pawn one and to your second very
insightful Point by sitting on E2 with
the bishop you are opening up the
possibility of driving the bishop up to
F3 and putting even more pressure on
that pawn ultimately inducing V6 and
then the Knight actually will have a
very serious Prospect but after a
significant think Wesley decides to opt
for the natural recapture I'm a little
disappointed Robert I will admit he
takes C4 would have led to a very
interesting structure
I feel like for Wesley when he plays in
these events he's super solid very
difficult to beat him but he also draws
quite a lot so it's not like he'll you
can get to two points by winning two
games and losing two or you could draw
all four games I think he's just the
type of player who's more likely to draw
his games than to win them and it's
because he is very precise he doesn't
take speculative risks and if you're
going to win a tournament when you're
full point behind sometimes it is
necessary to just take a chance but I
understand his decision here he has no
risk right now he has a pair of Bishops
uh the position is relatively closed but
the bishop B2 has a full diagonal to
work with that Bishop can always drop
back to E2 the light Square Bishop over
to F3 you put your Rooks on D1 maybe
work on C1 and it's not like black can
attack anything in White's Camp so
that's the good news for Wesley but
keeping the pawn structure symmetrical
means that black also has less to worry
about I think that norderbeck has once
again played a very sturdy opening he
has been very impressive with the black
pieces
and his time management has been equally
impressive he leaves himself with plenty
of time to make important middle game
and end game decisions and that's a case
in point Rook C7 is already on the board
not about taking less than a minute to
make this move because he realizes that
at this point the margin of error is
pretty wide his position is so solid
that a move like Rook C7 is unlikely to
be a big mistake and not only isn't it a
big mistake I think uh it's the top
computer move in the position it
improves his position even further and
it tosses the ball right back into
Wesley's Court you've got the bishop
here congratulations but how are you
going to transform it into something
concrete I agree with you I think
notrebrecht has fully equalized and he
might be well on the way to making
another solid draw with the black pieces
and a draw would help him in the
tournament standings because atarov is
in the lead heading into this round in
fact he can end the tournament if he
wins this game today and a few other
results go his way so he is playing one
of the players chasing him and if he
beats Wesley so you're and Fun Forest
takes down any scary that game is very
sharp and if Magnus Carlson does not win
his game against prognanda then nerd
airbag wins the Tata steel Chess Masters
with a full round to spare so he's got
the stare he would like to win with a
round despair but right now Wesley so
has a very solid position it may not be
spectacular but with the pair of Bishops
with the stronghold over the center I
feel like Wesley is feeling just at home
there it can be a long grinded out
battle Wesley does not seem to mind that
but he doesn't have inroads just yet and
that's why I think Daniel I don't want
to speak on your behalf but we're
appreciating the solidity of
nordierbeck's opening choice and the
resulting position
I mean he's just such a mature player
and you know for his for his age the old
wisdom always went you know there's a
Russian expression Russian chess
expression that goes with young players
into the end game which says you know
even if you're playing a very talented
opponent uh go into the end game because
young players typically historically uh
aren't quite as able to handle
positional tension uh and complicated
end games as their more experienced
counterpart take that wisdom and throw
it into the trash can it's just not true
anymore if you look at the Young crop of
talent Notre back Ali Reza farouza who
is actually I think one of the greatest
end game players of his generation of
Our Generation already uh and and many
many others players are now well-rounded
and so you can't just artificially get a
certain type of physician uh and expect
a mistake that's just not going to
happen and I think we're seeing this
once again here but with that said
Robert I think we're in for a long haul
I don't think Wesley is just going to
acquiesce to a draw in the next five
moves he he is going to try to squeeze
this bishop pair into something concrete
and we're going to get I think many more
fascinating moments in this end game but
speaking of fascinating moments if we
could travel to the bird's eye view
really quickly we've got some crazy
action in the um well in many games in
maxulu Eric icy it appears that white
blunder tonight but in fact he did not
the Knight on F3 is Untouchable that's
right bottom of your screen uh to the
left of Carlson Prague because of the
move Rook to E3 the queen is trapped
typical standard Fair Robert from
parhamaksudu the ever creative
parhamaksudu
Wow Let's just show that variation very
quickly because I want to jump into the
Magnus Carlson game but because you
pointed out a cool tactic let's just you
know did Parham his do he won his game
yesterday so let's pull up this board
and we will show the tactic of why that
Knight on F3 is Untouchable for now the
last move G2 to G4 hits the queen on F5
and if Queen takes Knight enough three
as Donya pointed out the Rook slides up
to E3 and that Queen has no safe squares
it is trapped the best it can do is give
itself up for a rook but the resulting
Position will be winning for white the
queen uh for rook and Bishop now the
queen is better especially with the
Pawns in the situation they are so I
just wanted to point that out Parham
with more time than he started with he
is in great shape down the stretch of
this tournament he would love to add
another Victory unfortunately for him it
won't mean that he can compete for first
but getting an even score would be a big
accomplishment for the last second
replacement he replaced Johna who had to
withdraw and then all of a sudden the
call came in he's like there I go to the
Netherlands I will play against the
likes of Magnus Carlson dingley Wren
Arjuna geisi and the top players in the
world but Daniel I do want to take us to
the Magnus Carlson game because speaking
of top players in the world the world
champion in all three formats classical
chess rapid and Blitz he has himself a
really cool battle against pragnananda
and we have Parham the background behind
Magnus on screen the many onlookers
staring at the monitors that show these
games look at this position the last
move played from Prague NADA was Knight
E7 to D5 I know your instincts are
definitely the same as mine white should
be thinking about pushing that H Pawn
Harry up to H5
pushed Harry up to H5 induced serious
and permanent weaknesses on the king
side in particular after H5 G5 look at
that B1 H7 diagonal if black ever
castles to that side of the board and
hey you're not really castling Queen
side with the C file wide open like that
white could drop the bishop back to C2
and builds this is a very typical idea
in iqp positions bring the queen up to
D3 and threaten a Checkmate on H7 just
massive holes on the king side if in
fact Magnus pushes the pawn to H5 but
Robert that is not a move that comes
without a price tag because once Flex
Pawn appears on G5 the Knight on D5 does
get a stronghold on F4 and there is the
later possibility of black driving the
pawn down to G4 uh and creating
something resembling a king side attack
but just given how passive the bishop is
on C8 and how flimsy Black's
construction is overall I think H5 is
well worth the price
because black will have a difficult time
castling if you Castle after white opens
up those light squares notice that
Bishop on e4 it's very likely to slide
back on the diagonal at some point the
queen will step in front of it and
that's what we call a battery and it
often leads to a checkmating attack so
you can get that Queen on H7 if the
black king castles to the king side so
it's not an easy choice for prognan to
figure out where to move the King and I
just feel like White's play is quite
straightforward you can Castle bring a
rook to C1 bring the Rook to E1 and one
of the downsides of castling in the near
future is the H4 Pawn is actually a bit
loose notice the queen and Bishop for
black line up against that pawn so if
the Rook were gone maybe in some
variation black can take it so it's just
a big moment for Magnus here he can
Castle he can't throw an H5 I personally
like the look upon the H5 and I feel
like with that Bishop on C8 down yet you
called it first it is a bad piece so
whites-minded pieces more active he's
more developed has great control of the
center while H5 is a quite a committal
move I think it's a good one and the the
point about the bishop is the reason why
you avoid Knight takes D5 with a 10-foot
pole I think some people might look at
this and say hey let's give black an
isolated Queen Pawn of his own let's
Force Prague to join the party well
Knight takes D5 would be a terrible
positional decision because after the
recapture Black's Bishop has a beautiful
developing Square on G4 that is of
course one of the downsides of pushing
pawns that early you create weak squares
now as it stands the G4 square is simply
inaccessible to Black species you
certainly do not want to give the bishop
on C8 active prospects you might wonder
why Magnus is thinking why not just play
H5 as we discussed it's a pretty
committal move and I think there are
some compelling Alternatives I would
point out uh the move Knight F3 to E5
putting more pressure on Black's flimsy
kingside construction white could also
Castle Queen side if Magnus wants uh to
show a flare for the dramatic so
definitely a choice to be made here for
Carlson but these are the exactly the
types of positions that he excels in and
by that Robert I mean every single type
of position but when he's got that
slight advantage and that little
positional crunch he is just nasty nasty
about he is just demonic in these types
of structures there's a positional
Nuance that we should highlight that if
black is able to play H5 himself that
weakens his control of the dark squares
but only one side has a dark Square
bishop and it is pragananda so he's not
as worried about giving up the dark
squares as he is about giving up some of
these light squares especially with the
bishop on e4 so let's just show what the
position looks like after H5 black has
to deal with that move oh sorry I would
say White's age whites move H5 yeah but
but it shows what you know why black
would like to avoid it because you can't
take on H5 that would just be terrible
to get up the board yeah get me out of
here
unacceptable even to mention it and so
if the pawn goes up to G5 to keep the
position more close then white can
castle and the downside for white of
pushing the pawn to H5 is it can become
a Target after Knight F4 but black
doesn't have all the time in the world
if you spend two moves to bring your
knight to the rim white will just play
in the center there's a king still
sitting on E8 maybe Rook a to D1 and try
to push that pawn to D5 if you take on
H5 so you can't just do nothing and
dilly dally and keep your King on E8 the
position will be blasted open and it's
going to be black who pays the price
yeah and a corner upon on H5 just isn't
the most important element of the
position do all of this and the payoff
uh is is is pretty meager so that's out
of the question for Prague and as we
indicated at the start if black just
sort of nonchalantly castles King side
well Bishop C2 comes really really fast
and another important element of this
position Robert this is a slightly more
subtle Point let's let's make a random
move for black after Queen to D3 uh the
the typical way to defend against this
Checkmate when you can't play G6 is to
slide The Rook over to E8 and oftentimes
Queen H7 just isn't that big of a
problem because the King has the direct
pathway through the tunnel to E7 but not
here after Queen H7 King f8 The Pawn on
H6 is hanging and that well maybe white
doesn't even have to take the pawn but
this definitely is a simple way to get a
huge Advantage G5 falls on the next move
white also has uh more tactical ideas
like Bishop G6 so because Lex kingside
is so weak a check on H7 is likely to be
devastating and so black must think
twice before castle and King side maybe
it's worth bringing the bishop back from
F6 so that you could block the battery
with F7 F5 or drop the Knight back to F6
but none of this Robert looks in in the
least bit reassuring
no because you're what you're doing is
defending against the checkmating attack
and you're getting a bit passive and
that Bishop on C8 it needs to get out
into the open it's far away from doing
that and the Knight will be the only
defender of the black king so just
instead of B6 just to put the position
that you were talking about is let's say
Bishop drops back to G7 a queen to D3 go
up there then black can even make with
F5 if you want that looks very weakening
so I wouldn't go for that uh but you can
play Knight F6 as well although that's
kind of a flimsy defensive construction
because at some moment Knight E4 removes
the defender of H7 Knight E5 as well
it's just a good forward hop I love the
look of this position from Magnus
Carlson it is clear that he is in the
driver's seat he just has eight look at
this an initiative and he plays H5 he is
not showing any fear he's not
restraining himself he is going forward
because he knows objectively is a good
position
yeah he's not going to pass up the
opportunity to induce permanent
weaknesses on the king side and Magnus
just has an ideal position after move
15. it's non-theoretical he's gotten
Prague out of his preparation uh the
Indian Junior has already spent almost
an hour and the toughest tasks the
adversity is is really still ahead for
Prague you know this was the easy part
now he has a worse position against
Carlson with not that much time on his
clock
it is very very dangerous situation here
for a struggling Prague who lost
yesterday's game with the white pieces
Department as you've been pointing out
as a reward you're facing a bloodthirsty
Magnus Carlson with the black pieces and
already major major difficulties for
Prague
this is not a fun position for him
Magnus has been taken down by prognanda
in the Champions chess store on many
different occasions I mean programa
shows great resilience but in classical
chess
Magnus won his only game against
prognanda a year ago in Vikings a he
wants to make it two for two beat him
while they're young in chess that's what
the Mantra goes because then they become
2800 and it's hard to beat them when
they get that strong so I think the
megas Carlson in a good position he has
one full point behind Noir Becca so
Abdus does not beat Wesley so Magnus
gets very close to that leader and then
it makes round 13 all the more exciting
it does indeed and as Prague quickly
carries out the move G5 there simply was
no alternative presumably Magnus is
going to take some time to decide what
he wants to prioritize there's 95 he can
Castle kingside he can preemptively drop
the bishop back to C2 that simply
prevents black from castling King sides
so an important choice now for the world
champion and he has plenty of time to
make it and we then have plenty of time
to go back to our Birds to have you
Robert because the other games are not
stopping for even a second then for his
Geary continues to heat up and he's
shying away from the queen trade and now
trying to open up the B file with his
last move wherever you turn you've got
amazing action Vincent kymer lower left
he's pushing his beep on up the board as
well to B4 and trying to chip away at
White's Queen side structure I'm
speechless this is an amazing round
honestly already
the games are really exciting in the
middle on the bottom there levana runs
Rook is on A6 there was a bishop trade
there that's how the Rook went up there
because otherwise it makes no sense but
that game also is interesting and the
queenless middle game between Richard
report and dingley Wren the Knight H2
move right expect report to find cool
ideas and prognanda yeah of course his
game is Magnus Carlson has his work cut
out but I think we should go yesterday's
game against Max Zulu feature of the
blue Knight H2 and it has a very similar
idea this time to get it around to E3
sorry to cut you off there no you're all
good I thought you were saying probably
not like he did something so I had to
look at his board over there uh but the
game between nishikiri and Jordan Von
Forest that one has changed a bit it's a
moment that Anish is able to strike with
his Pawn trying to open up his Rook so
why don't we see the latest updates on
that one
let's do it let's take a closer look at
the game now let's rewind two moves
because last we saw was Jordan's 19th
move C3 C4 uh implicitly inviting a
queen trade and each Gary says no I want
to keep the Queens on the board because
I don't trust your king in the center I
want to go after that King instead he
plays Knight to C3 oh nerves of Steel
for Anish Gary that Knight of course
could get entangled in the web of
White's Center Pond speaking of Center
ponds Jordan pushes C5 opening up the C4
Square for his light squared Bishop now
taking on A2 seems a little bit too
Brazen it walks into Bishop C4 with
Tempo and then there's that uh check on
e4 that could come at an inopportune
time and Anish the last move of the game
was B7 B6 and finally finally Jordan
benforest is starting to take his time
he still has an hour and 36 minutes that
is a very unwelcome sight for Anish and
Robert before I pass that on to you I
think I want to make one important point
which is that castling kingside does not
solve Black's King problems because then
you walk right into the Open Arms of
Knight F3 to G5 an idea we mentioned
previously and after G6 H5 the king
could actually be a lot less safe on the
king side ironically than it is in the
center
yeah just because you run away doesn't
mean that your king is safe the queen on
C2 is well positioned to launch an
attack with Knight G5 on tap so B6 is a
good good move in the sense that it's
trying to open up that Rook black has an
extra Rook for a bishop in one Pawn
let's make use of that rook and white
does not want to make the move Pawn C5
to C6 that would actually be a very bad
decision because it closes down the
queen side in a favorable way for black
the A2 Pawn I think can be captured and
as you're highlighting this is the most
consequential point that if Knight takes
A2 is played Queen E4 check
without the queen being able to retreat
to E7 black could be in trouble but the
queen just slides all the way back you
cannot afford a queen trade if you're
white and now the Black Knight escapes
back to B4 and your head that material
your king is finding some shelter so if
we go to the live position
this move B6 it challenges the setup and
I'm wondering is the black king fully
safe in the center if the move Bishop C4
is played for example uh it's starting
to look very spicy
Bishop C4 is definitely the best move
here for white of course the point isn't
really to defend the A2 that's just a
positive byproduct of the move the point
is to escape the center as quickly as
possible because White's King is
definitely not safe in the center in the
event of B take C5 but Jordan he escapes
just in time and this is a very
unenviable situation for black he's kind
of stuck in uh stuck in molasses on the
queen said that night on C3 has really
lost its luster now the queen is tied
down to its defense and if you just
blindly continue playing on the queen
side all you're going to do is get
yourself checkmated immediately after
Queen F5 castles Knight G5 you can throw
in the towel that's it I mean look at
Black's pieces totally stuck on an
irrelevant side of the board so instead
of the uh incredibly Reckless Rook B2
probably Anish should take this time to
Castle but in this position apart from
the obvious Knight G5 white could
actually start by pushing the pawn up to
up to H5 and this is just a little bit
of pro prophylaxis you're preventing the
move G6 because let's not forget the
very important idea of HG HG and what
queen takes G6 check my voice cracked
again I'm losing my I'm losing my
abilities and the pawn on F7 is pin
Robert this is getting incredibly
dangerous I think Anish might already
start regretting not trading Queens if
you're an invent Forest develops his
Bishop to C4
but
well I agree with all that I will add
that in the live position the eval Bar
says anisha's play is fully Justified
it's saying that he is playing this
quite well and there are two ways to
look at it Jordan for the first time all
game is actually thinking so for a niche
there's there are two options either
Jordan is out of his preparation because
this is as far as he went there's way
too many lines in chess to look at you
can't memorize them all or anise just
made a mistake and Jordan didn't analyze
it because it's like the fourth best
move according to the engines I don't
think it was a big mistake it looks like
quite a natural move if I were sitting
in a niche's seat where he currently has
vacated to walk around and stretch his
legs I would have thought about the move
B6 as well because there's not a check
that white can give the king the Knight
on C3 covers both B5 and E4 so no checks
available to White's pieces and you're
trying to activate the Rook so I think
that he made a very natural move and I
feel like for the first time all game it
can breathe a little bit easier knowing
that Jordan doesn't have the entirety of
the continuation mapped out indeed
Jordan is finally using his brain and no
matter what the evaluation is that is
definitely a relief I also think the
Anish Gary in round one or round two in
the early going of the tournament might
have given more serious consideration to
Queen C3 check but in this tournament
situation he needs to take risks I mean
he doesn't want to be the runner-up for
the sixth time in his career and
realistically a draw in this game
doesn't entirely eliminate his chances
if the cards fall favorably but a win
with the black pieces uh would would
give him a huge huge boost because let's
be real Wesley so is very unlikely uh to
lose that end game with the white pieces
so I definitely think his decision was
influenced by the tournament situation
and I'm on the same page I don't think
you know Queen A3 and Knight C3 is a
serious mistake I just think it's a wild
chaotic position in the player who can
maintain their nerves the player who can
manage their time better and the better
calculator is going to win in this
position
Jordan Von Forrest nothing really to
lose at this point he is using the role
of spoiler to his Advantage because it
gets in each Geary and each really wants
to win take his first taught to steal
title that would mean the world to him
he is an ambassador for the event he
does many things for it helps the
organizers out he does promo and he is
from the Netherlands as is Jordan Forest
so I will leave his work to him he's no
longer seated in ishikiri Jordan Von
Forest leaning over the board trying to
figure it out and as we look all seven
games are still in session very exciting
games I might add we'll take a look at
some of the games we have yet to get to
when we return from break but before we
do we want to make mention of a very
special event coming your way because
chess kid is hosting the second chess
kid bullet Championship on February 25th
the tournament is open to players
worldwide as completely free to play it
top players receive chest in Gold
memberships and gift cards to the chess
kit store funmaster Mike will be
covering all the action at twitch.tv
chess kid at chess.com TV if you're
someone you know has what it takes make
sure to join the official chested Club
over at chesskid.com use the command
bullet Champs in chat for more Daniel
nerdinski and I will be right back this
is the Tata seal Chess Masters 2023 it
is the penultimate round so much action
left to dissect we'll be right back
do you wish playing a chess game with a
friend was as easy as sending them a
text well good news now it is but
chess.com's new iMessage app you can
start and play a game directly in
iMessage your friend doesn't even need a
chess.com account it's just tap and play
head over to go.just.com iMessage or use
the command iMessage in chat to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
January and Vicon Zay the Netherlands
for this cozy coastal town the holiday
season isn't over
in fact the most wonderful time of the
year has really just begun bear Kings
on a handshake what a hold for Wesley so
just didn't give the world champion a
chance
once again vikon Zay starts the new year
as the center of the chess Universe this
year as host of the 85th Tata steel
chess tournament
a magnet for the best players in the
game some recognize the Masters field of
2023 as its strongest in recent memory
of course it helps when eight-time Tata
steel chess champion Magnus Carlson is
back
Magnus is going baseball if Magnus plays
like this the rest of the way who knows
what can happen
the world's number one looks to further
cement his legacy in this event and the
game's history
chasing Magnus will be amongst the best
in chess several have been crowned
Champion here before some have even
shocked the world in doing so
and don't leave out those poised to
capture their first Tata title Anish
Gary is just I mean he beat both world
number one and world number two in the
same tournament
although winter Tata steel chess is also
known as the place new stars come to
bloom
Magnus one here is a teenager this
year's event has its fair share of young
players on the rise each hoping to
follow in Carlson's footsteps motorbeck
keeps his lead with a solid
well-prepared draw against Gary the
Dutch referred to Tata steel as The
Wimbledon of chess for 85 years in
running this tournament continues to be
steep in Prestige and Legacy and does so
again in this welcoming Little Dutch
town by the sea
mine brynden it's the 85th edition of
the Tata steel chess tournament let's
make chess history together
you can't talk about the history of the
Tata steel chess tournament without
mentioning the man you see on the screen
in front of you Lovato rhodium is a
four-time champion at vikon Zay he has
an illustrious chess career although he
did have a down year in 2022 losing many
rating points he's having a good event
thus far Dania he has plus one he has
gained some ready points and he's a
chance to take down gookesh in this one
and give himself an outside shot at this
year's title
indeed no he's doing great and this
tournament has been a major confidence
boost after a major struggle at the last
U.S Championship where I actually think
he didn't win a single game as we look
at the top half of the tournament cross
table of one sitting pretty on plus one
with six points out of 11. I don't
believe he's lost a game in the issue
status still or has he
Livonia has not lost it's not lost a
game and that is a major achievement yes
he's made a lot of draws but as you
indicated he's dropped a lot of rating
in the last year and what you want after
an off-year is a tournament where you
prove to yourself that you can compete
with the best of him and from round one
where levonne held Magnus Carlsen with
black cue this round he's barely been
worse in any of his games but can he
deliver in at least one of the final two
games to end strong well he's got black
against kukesh in a rugos in the
position has changed a lot uh Robert The
Rook moved away from A6 but more
importantly the pawn structure has
changed you've got the hanging Pawns in
the center which can be both the
strength and a weakness essentially at
the same time
yeah this position is one where will
Black's pawns be vulnerable or are they
actually strong for instance not in this
particular moment but if black pushes
that pawn to A4 maybe his one Pawn takes
care of two of White's pawns because
that B Pawn isn't pushing anytime soon
now in the current position I'm looking
at this night tray that's being offered
black has more space and to me that
means you just keep more pieces on the
board I like the look of the retreating
move Knight E4 to F6 that way the Knight
on D2 still sits in The Bishop's path
the bishop on E1 it's a long range piece
but it can't jump over pieces and the
Knight is in front of it so I think the
Knight should in fact Retreat for now
but then Knight on D2 done it it made
land on B3 hitting both A5 and C5 so
they're pros and cons of keeping more
material on the board
yeah Knight F6 should be associated with
direct calculation I think there's Queen
E6 to B6 very important resource
guarding uh both of the liabilities on
the queen side at the same time as an
alternative I like your idea of playing
A4 you could do it immediately you're
not you know too afraid of Knight takes
C4 the queen could recapture and
centralize itself but in that case you
have to reckon with uh the idea of
doubling Brooks on C1 I'll tell you one
thing that black does not want to do
unless the circumstances change is play
the move C4 this could be very tempting
because you create a pawn chain and yes
after C4 your pawns are safe but your
squares are not and white will
immediately reroute his Knight to that
very juicy outpost on D4 so when you've
got the hanging Pawn structure you
normally want to refrain from pushing
your Pawn either to C4 or to D4 unless
you absolutely have to
very very true and for Luana Rodin he is
the oldest player in the field uh he is
extremely experienced he was the number
two rated player in the world at certain
points in his career he has won in
Vikings day four different times so he
knows when to push those pawns probably
pushing C4 as Dania was indicating is it
hand white the dark squares and guess
what only white has a dark Square Bishop
so you don't want to give it a complete
scope across the board and so that's why
Lavon he says I'm going to take on D2 I
don't want to see that Knight hop around
the B3 and hit my pawns so he trades and
now after the bishop takes back on D2 he
can't play A5 to A4 and clamp down on
the queen side this game is not going to
be decided in the next few moves it's
all about the maneuvering that's going
to take place will the bishop be
dominant over the night or will that
Knight be able to go to a better Square
maybe a light Square where the bishop
can't challenge it a very interesting
positional Affair indeed both kings are
safe and so the battle is going to
continue revolving squarely around the
queen side can white make something of
his pressure on the C5 Pawn I think it's
safe to say that we will see the Rooks
doubling on the C file maybe
blackstrokes will double as well but I
agree LeBron's going to play A4 he's
going to Deep Freeze White's Queen side
pawns and gukesh is going to continue
trying to massage the C5 pawn and trying
to induce the move C4 and then gaining
control of the dark squares in the
center well as uh the Indian Junior
decides with which piece to recapture on
D2 Queen takes D2 also a viable move
let's perhaps go back to our bird's eye
view and take a look at the developments
in some of the other games I always say
this Robert but just the amount of
different openings and types of
positions that we have uh has really
really impressed me you know we've had
tournaments where half of the games are
a Berlin end game you know everything
kind of Peter's out at the start we have
not had any of that in this year's
taught us deal almost every round has
featured just a panoply of different
openings and different types of
structures so we've got something for
everyone
we do indeed and one game that has been
interesting from the start is the one
between Fabiano caruana and Vincent
kymer I think we should dive into that
one it's second from the left on the
bottom row because Fabiano caruana
entered this round in a tie with levanov
Ronin with six points out of 11 games
and he has a chance to win this
tournament if all the other results go
his way that means if a niche struggles
and Nordic abusitarov only scores a half
point but the game itself is really
fascinating so if we can pull that game
up down here just to go back to move 18
for white just because it's not the
first time in this game we've talked
about temporary peace sacrifice Knight
takes E4 uh was played here and after
Pawn takes E4 most of us mere mortals
would just move our Knight out the way
because it's under attack but Fabiano
says your night on C6 is attacking my
Pawn E5 and it's also not defended so
let's play Bishop A4 what a clever move
because if the Knight is captured in F3
then on C6 is captured and The Rook on 8
is targeted and the bishop will then win
that pawn so white would be up material
and that means that black is going to
deal with this threat and it just always
fun to see these clever uh in-between
moves that players make and Bishop A4 is
a really nice resource it is and you
know the disaster of playing Knight D4
it wasn't only that it gives up the pawn
I'll just point out that F4 the old
resource no longer works because black
can take on Busan but just look at that
D3 Square black is itching to sink his
teeth into that square after Bishop A4
Vincent decides to Kick the Can down the
road he takes on C3 now Bishop takes C6
just looks Unthinkable to give black
these connected passers on the second
rank he doesn't want anything to do with
that he takes back on C3 and once again
Vincent needs to decide how he is going
to defend the night he has Queen C7 he
can play Rook C8
the Knight isn't really in trouble but
he has to weigh the pros and cons of the
different types of moves available to
him obviously he can also grab the queen
on D1 first but I don't know if he wants
to give white control of uh the the open
D file
no he doesn't and the big thing about
this position is the bishop on G6 is
actually not a very good piece so if you
play Queen C7 which was my first
instinct as a way to protect the Knight
so if we can bring up an analysis board
and show some moves here that Bishop
takes C6 Queen takes C6 the Knight
Ventures into D4 after the swap of
Bishop for Knight and the bishop on G6
is kind of a bystander it's staring into
its own pawn and the Knight on D4 is
entrenched there a white has control of
the dark squares and two different minor
pieces that can play on those squares
and the White Queen will venture out to
A4 at some moment the C4 Pawn is a bit
loose I just like how free-flowing the
position seems for white not that black
is in trouble objectively the position
is fine but if you ask me to pick a side
that I'd rather play from it's
definitely White
I agree that White's position is easier
to play with that in mind concretely I
think after Queen D5 black is probably
closer to equalizing than white is to a
serious Advantage there is first of all
uh the threat of Queen takes the five
second of all the bishop for me seven
could come into C5 and just try to chop
that Knight off of D4 now the Knight
will be very ably replaced by a bishop
on D4 that will nicely defend all of
White's uh isolated Pawns in the center
and on the queen side but we know that
opposite colored Bishops often yield the
game uh give the game a drawish
character but with Queens on the board
there is still plenty of meat on the
bone I like the way Fabi has handled
this middle game and I like the fact
that he's now forcing Vincent to make
several committal decisions in a row the
first of which is how is he going to
defend the Knight on C6 Vincent leads
back in his chair there he's got plenty
of time to make the decision and that is
one of the bonuses of extensive opening
preparation you just give yourself more
time once the the game inevitably goes
into a middle game that you haven't
studied you've got that extra 15-20
minutes to make that extra precise
decision and that could be the
difference between a win and a loss at
this level
really instructive points by you that
was a really good line with a queen
coming up to D5 and then opposite
colored Bishops may be seen so uh for
Vincent it looks like he's doing a great
job out of the gates here the game will
continue though just because you have
great preparation doesn't mean you
suddenly hold or win and in this
particular game it feels like Fabi will
try to squeeze a little Advantage here
or there not that he has one but it
might be a moment where it's difficult
for Vincent to find the most accurate
continuations and then that's how you
turn a neutral position into a slight
plus and then eventually a slight plus
into a potential win so I think that
there's a lot of work cut out for these
players Vincent is deep in thought so
let's zoom out from this one and maybe
take a look at one game we haven't
looked at at all and it's the game
between Richard report and dingley ren
in the bottom left I see the move F7 F5
played Dania it looks like the action is
now heating up yeah I was going to say
it's a perfect opportunity to take a
look at that game because uh you would
be forgiven for thinking that things are
moving in a rather mundane Direction the
Queens got off the board but now dingley
Wren has spiced things up again with F7
F5 now this was uh What uh is referred
to as the check over variation if we
rewind all the way back to the start uh
I'll run you through uh the course of
the game very very quickly uh it would
seem to be an open Sicilian love that
Ding still trying to score some wins at
the end of the tournament he doesn't
just want a quick Berlin draw no he
wants to win report taking on 24 with
the queen this line has actually gotten
very very popular in the last couple of
years and after Knight F6 the knights
are developed the bishop comes out to B5
pinning the Knight on C6 that's how
black got the bishop pair and that's
very very common in this variation now
Richard report Castle in Queen side he
wants a tactical game but dingly Wren he
manages to get the Queens off the board
pretty quickly an idea that is actually
popular in the advanced Karo Khan the
queen drops back to A6 making an offer
that white really can't refuse the queen
on D3 doesn't have too many good squares
to go to and so Vincent says okay all
trade Queens especially because I'm
leaving you with uh a crippled queenside
Pawn structure then he brings the Rook
into the center and E5 a committal
decision by ding weakening these two
light squares but he believes that he's
got the Firepower to keep them under
lock and key and after Knight H2 picking
a page out of prague's book both nights
maneuvering their way back but the idea
of Black's maneuver was to open up a
pathway for the F Pawn so why is F5 uh
such a nasty movable because it
threatens to cut into White's control of
the center you definitely don't want to
play e takes up five I would imagine uh
and give up the G2 Pawn but if you play
the move F3 perhaps ding is seriously
contemplating the move F4 leaving
White's Knight locked on F1 you always
like pointing this out when a pawn and a
knight are on the same file and there
are two squares between them the pawn
greatly limits the knight's Mobility
very very good uh explanation of what's
Happening Here so the big decision that
dingly Ren has just made is to prevent
that knight from going to E3 and up to
D5 that's a maneuver that prognanda try
to essay yesterday against paramaksudu
that's where the Knight went back to H2
in the first place so I think that white
can take the pawn F5 it looks like a
decision that might cause some problems
but the thing about it is after Pawn
takes a five if black says give me your
G2 Pawn afterwards
after Rook G1 G7 is hanging at the end
of the G file and if you say I I need to
move my Bishop somewhere but I don't
want to lose a pawn let me take your
knight on F1 after Rook e takes F1 you
can't castle kingside that's a really
important note because Bishop takes H6
the pawn will be pinned
that's a very important point and well
spotted by you Bishop takes H and if you
can't Castle kingside you can play a
move like King F7 but I stand corrected
Robert I was too influenced by the ugly
appearance of the kingside pawns and I
don't think I lent sufficient weight to
the fact that White's night now has
direct access to D5 there's the prospect
of playing F4 and opening the king side
up the more I look at this position the
more it occurs to me that white probably
has the advantage in an end game like
this
you're usually the first person to
mention that pawn structure is overrated
so I'm I've learned from you and you
know it is a very instructive point to
keep mentioning but one thing that is
important about the pawn structure is
that if the pieces get traded off if we
just go to the live board for uh or we
can look at it underneath the cameras
there but here we see that if the pieces
get trayed off black is in a pretty much
losing King and pawn end game because of
the doubled a pawns they're isolated
over there that's really bad news and a
lot of Rook end games without the minor
pieces will be very bad for black so
black needs to keep more pieces on the
board to create counter threats
otherwise his pawns will be vulnerable
so daily Wren I mean he strikes with F5
but if Richard report says that doesn't
look too scary let me open up the
position by taking you on F5 maybe he
has some chances to punish ding in this
position
he does and to tie up our discussion of
Pawn structure I always like to say in
addition to pawn structures are
overrated the significance of Pawn
structures is generally inversely
proportional to the amount of pieces
left on the board so the fewer pieces
are left on the board the more important
and the more weighty uh the pawn
structure becomes obviously if there are
no pieces on the board and just pawns
Pawn end games are literally just about
Pawn Stars like that is the only
important thing alongside King activity
of course so your point is is very well
taken uh right now black may not be
worried about his doubled apons but with
every piece that disappears from the
board uh the butterflies uh start
entering Black's stomach and Richard has
decided against taking on F5 I think
that was a very good move I'm now a you
know completely devoted Advocate if he
takes that fight but instead he goes for
the more uh traditional the more natural
approach and pushes the pawn up to F3 he
believes that after F4 he will be able
to find suitable living arrangements for
his Knight on F1
yeah whether that's by pushing the pawn
to G3 or running the Knight back to H2
and up to G4 at some point I think G3 is
quite likely or pushing the pawn to H5
the Knight H2 Knight G4 but either way
the Knight will not stay on F1 forever
uh but it's going to be up to daily rent
to decide whether or not he plays F4
right now so while dangly run the world
champion Challenger figures that out
let's go back to our bird's eye view
because we have some top games that may
decide who the champion is at the end of
the event and none is more important
than the top left let's go right there
because Donya I think that game may be
over relatively soon we just saw a
bishop on B2 take a knight on C3 it's a
Wesley so versus No Deal game and it
looks like we're getting an opposite
called Bishop ending wow well it looks
to me like zero winning chances for
white and if not any red can hold this
and looks like he's going to he is
really in good position to win the Tata
steel Masters this is beyond impressive
and Notre back is doing essentially what
Wesley so did against Magnus Carlson
yesterday excellent opening preparation
shows that he understands the resulting
position and now drawing not grobling in
a slightly worse end game somewhere if
anything I would prefer black now
I think black's Advantage is purely
symbol I don't even think you can talk
about an advantage but I think black is
the one with a slight pull here Wesley
has just captured a knight on C3
essentially giving away all of his
winning chances after Rook takes E3
you're gonna have opposite colored
Bishops and with a structure as
symmetrical as it is I think there's a
high likelihood Robert that uh we're
gonna get a mass trade of Rooks and uh a
draw agreement pretty soon but how
impressive is it that notorbeck just
seems to be holding from a position of
strength with the black pieces two games
in a row now against players uh who are
just well known for their ability to
create problems with the white pieces
but frustrating game for Wesley so and I
would just add that I think analysts in
retrospect are going to blame Wesley for
going for this end game variation I
don't think that you can say it's a bad
decision that end game we had in this
game is incredibly Rich it's not a bad
try it's just that Notre back seems to
know everything
I don't think Wesley took a risk that's
the biggest problem because if we look
at how this game developed after the
bishop took on C4 we'll bring uh up an
analysis board and we will show that at
this moment here Bishop takes C4 let's
just go through what happened in the
game and then we'll backtrack and see
what could have happened uh look at how
seamlessly no dear back
coordinators pieces and just played on
the Queen's side like every single move
had a purpose like Bishop B4 to get
control the C3 squared also to induce a
weakness with Pawn to A3 you have been
talking about Bishop A3 check at some
point but if your Pawn is on A3 you're
never getting a bishop to that square
and you're also creating uh some
problems for your B3 Pawn in the future
as well so he just kicks the bishop out
after uh moving his Knight into E4
Knight D2 check is a threat so that's
why the Knight came back to F3 and then
be fine he's like let's trade everything
I am better I am more active I'll put my
knight into C3 and you have to take me
otherwise you're in trouble I just feel
like the plan became very
straightforward for nodirbeck he didn't
have to make any difficult decisions he
still had to calculate but look at the
position we have in the game zero
problems for Abdus Atari so if we go
back to that moment where the capture on
C4 happened Donya
I feel like an ambitious tribe was B
take C4 maybe I'm looking at this uh
with rose-colored glasses oh just we'll
play for a win no problems there are
problems the night can come to B6 and
maybe the A4 the C4 Pawn is isolated
maybe an eventual Target uh so black has
some pluses of his own with a knight on
D7 getting up to the A4 Square uh all
that being said it does make a
double-edged position where white will
have chances to win the game and if you
want to win the tournament he wasn't so
had to win this game and I think you
were very prescient I think you made
this point yesterday that Wesley he can
struggle in situations where he
essentially needs to win on demand
because he doesn't always like to make
long-term weaknesses in his position yet
that is often what you have to do
especially against someone uh who's in
as good a form as notrec is he's not
going to shoot himself in the foot if
the position is overly simple and after
Bishop takes C4 black had zero problems
coordinating his pieces and now forcing
a mass trade down the scene file of
course you could argue retrospectively
that Wesley could have chosen uh a
queen's gamut accepted line with more
meat on the bone something like what
Gary played yesterday but can you really
blame him after noderbeck displayed
extensive preparation for going for
alignment he feels comfortable with I
don't think you can and I totally agree
that I think B takes C4 was the biggest
individual chance to introduce some sort
of imbalance and Intrigue into the
position as it stands as we fast forward
back to our live board King E2 has just
been played
I think we might get a draw for by one
of the players here we might get a
couple more moves but the result of the
game is is really not in question at
this point yeah I want to give credit to
abhishtarov and not assign blame to
Wesley so it was great preparation and
he had a tough decision to make does he
take that risk on and if we think about
the Fuller picture while Wesley so may
not win this tournament he gains rating
points and he has stated that he wants
to have a good classical chess year he
won the chess.com Global championship in
2022 that was rapid chess he had some
amazing events throughout the year but
classical chess it didn't always go his
way so to have this kind of performance
he has two wins and all the rest of his
games have been drawn it means he'll end
the tournament even I believe if he
loses the final game with some gained
rating points so for Wesley
um that's Wesley so on screen here uh
not Jordan Forest but Wesley he gets
prognanda with the black pieces in the
final game and that's it's going to be a
tough matchup but one that he probably
believes he can handle after all he did
just draw Magnus Carlson with the black
pieces
it's definitely a winnable game and we
know how much Prague has been struggling
in the second half of the tournament his
struggles are continuing today as he
faces the world champion of the black
pieces but definitely a solid
performance by Wesley two wins there in
a row in the middle of the tournament a
very impressive end game squeeze against
Vincent kymer a few rounds ago but in
this game it just wasn't meant to be for
the American Grandmaster I think Notre
Beck can continue putting a little bit
of pressure by trying to get this Knight
around to D5 he is not done with the C3
square if a knight appears on C3 well
there will be hell to pay I think Wesley
has to figure out a way to get this Rook
off the board ASAP and to solve the
problem of the C3 score before he
actually ends up in a worse position
but Notre back he is just a beast that's
a good call by you I think I sort of
took my eye off the game because I just
assumed it's going to be a drop is it
called not quite yet you're 100 right
with the presence of knights you can't
just claim madroth right as you're
looking at this if the knights get
traded oh then we shake hands for sure
because there's nowhere to go to but if
that Knight goes Knight F6 Knight D5 The
Rook moves out the way in Knight C3 or
the bishop moves and that goes to B4 the
A2 Pawn is a target so Black's position
is actually quite sturdy White's
position can be vulnerable so Wesley
does need to be careful here I think he
feels confident in his ability to draw
this game it is opposite colored Bishops
even if he loses a pawn somewhere if he
could trade those Knights he should be
able to hold and if you look at Wesley's
uh body language his posture here I mean
he doesn't look like he's the most
excited about the position and no
dearbeck on the other side he's looking
like a person who's determined to see if
he can win this game he wants to win
this tournament outright he can actually
actually win the event in this round if
he takes down Wesley so
anise Geary loses to Jordan Von forest
and then Magnus Carlsen is unable to
beat pragananda the tournament is done
there will still be the final game but
no direct abdusitarov will be the
champion so you see it on the screen in
front of you when I laid out no Rebecca
Abdul sitarov can win the tournament if
he today if he beats Wesley so and
Jordan run Forrest takes down a niche
and Magnus does not win well norterbeck
partially holds his Destiny in his hands
he's taking care of business on his side
let's see if Jordan venforest is taking
care of business on his because Jordan
and Anish giri have had an incredibly
exciting game
really from the very opening a
scintillating exchange Sacrifice by
Jordan uh as he tries to take down Anish
giri's regosan he now has an extra hour
on the clock and the game continues to
percolate it continues to heat up we see
that Anish Guri has managed to take his
King out of the center as has Jordan the
last move of the game is Queen A3 2b4
attacking the bishop on C4 I'll pass it
back to you Robert but before I do I'll
just point out that Jordan van Forest
has indeed pushed his spawn up to H5 and
he's not so much trying to go H6 as he
is trying to prevent the possibility of
G6 and Knight G5 that is the enemy at
Anish giri's door
wow and the the position is way very
scary
yeah Knight G5 well we'll have to go G6
only let's bring up an analysis board
yeah we need to look right at this line
because G6 is the only option you can't
push the app on the bishop pins it Queen
takes H7 check is mate so G6 Pawn takes
G6 you can't take back on G6 that's the
big problem
and if you take on G6 you can't take
back with a palm but you go Queen takes
C4 that's a very important uh move to
include because if G takes F7 check the
Rook takes on F7 defending H7
immediately and if Knight takes Rook as
you're pointing out 92 check will scoop
up the White Queen and black would win
the game
so that's what a niche Gary had in mind
when he played the move Queen before but
as many of you in the chat are pointing
out and I see some great analysis being
shared Jordan benforest is under no
obligation nor he is he in a hurry to
play H takes G6 all he has to do is
solve the problem of his Bishop now how
do you do that well you don't do it by
bringing the bishop back to B3 because
then C4 shuts that Bishop down that's
you know the benefit of having that pawn
on C5 but I think that the simple Queen
to D3 permanently solves the problem of
the bishop and faces black with
insurmountable problems not just on the
king side Robert this is what Anish Gary
may have missed but also on the queen
side the Knight on C3 is incredibly
vulnerable now white obviously now
threatens the devastating H takes G6 the
problem is in the black can't defend
against that he can and he can do that
in several ways let's say black brings
the king up to G7 solving the problem of
the pin along uh the a2j8 diagonal white
will bring the Rook over to C1 hitting
the Knight the Knight has to move back
to A4 and now white has untied his hands
for action on the queen side that now
The Queen Is Now free to roam about the
cabin because the Rook has been
delegated the assignment of guarding the
bishop the queen can swing over to E4
and just look at the assortment of white
pieces staring right at the black king
this position is just totally one-sided
it's not even close to Robert the Eva
bar is showing plus 10 and that's not an
exaggeration the king is just toast here
King is wide open and all of White's
pieces are staring in that direction uh
that's scary that's really really scary
that attack happens in the blink of an
eye and maybe that night that you just
moved a second ago there from C3 can I
go back to B5 instead is that any better
than I trying to aim towards the D6
square and help out in the defense it
doesn't look very pleasant but maybe the
Knight will help out the king to allow
black to survive
yeah there's definitely more resilient
options than what I just uh showed but
still I think Queen E4 is devastating
and just as an illustrative line if you
play a move like rookie 8 you'd be
forgiven for thinking that things are
things look complicated but white has
the devastating idea of H6 check I spoke
a little bit too soon when I said that
that wasn't Jordan's idea it wasn't his
original idea but it wins the game now
it can't take the pawn because of Queen
H for check and if the king drops back
to ga I mean Bishop takes F7 is one of
many ways to win the game you could also
just play Queen F4 and queen F6 with an
Unstoppable Lobster pincer made and the
underlying problem that undergirds this
entire attack is just that nishkiri has
tied his pieces up on the queen side
they're stuck there and they're actually
blocked by his own pawns so if I rewind
a little bit back uh we are testing out
the defensive move King G7 I think a
more resilient option might be to bring
the Rook up to B6 so that the move H6
does not come with check but all of the
points I made uh in reference to King G7
I think they hold I still think Rook C1
should be winning for white I would
caution against assuming that the game
is over and that the attack plays itself
it doesn't and Jordan will have to be
precise but he is definitely winning
from an objective standpoint this has
been phenomenal opening preparation by
Jordan and now he's got a chance to
deliver in a big way
and he's already played it yeah go can
you go back into that line you were
talking about so King G7 yep um Rook C1
this all seems relatively forcing the
Knight has to move otherwise you'll lose
the piece knight back to B5
Queen E4 Knight D6 I like bringing the
Knight back to help defend the king
and I'm assuming Queen E5 check is your
plan because F6 is not an option with
the Knight coming E6 with checking the
queen got going up to E7 it likely meets
the mate so after Queen E5 check I'm
wondering what happens if the king
slides back to Jeep because it looks
like Pawn H6 for white leads to made on
G7 but miraculously that Knight on D6
can hop out so that's not the move the
Knight goes to F5 so uh we have the Evo
bar that helps us know that white is
winning but H6 almost looks winning but
when the Knight comes to F5 it also
attacks that pawn and tries to remove it
so what actually would be the winning
option here because F7 is extra well
defended and if you pick play a careless
move like Pawn takes C5 the bishop run
C4 is actually under attack thanks to
the Knight on D6 hitting it as well as a
queen attacking it as well so I feel
like there I mean I know based on the
evaluation there is a win but this
doesn't seem very easy your point is
well taken and it Bears repeating your
demand Forest doesn't know for a fact
that his attack is winning he might
sense it intuitively but when you don't
know the evaluation it's so much harder
to find the right move if someone Taps
you on the shoulder and says hey it's
plus nine you're going to look for a
decisive move and you have a better
chance of finding the correct move which
is actually the calm Queen E5 to F6 the
point is to put additional pressure on
the F7 Pawn if the Knight leaves D6 then
H6 is Unstoppable Checkmate and black
simply actually has no defense against
the move H6 he has to give his Queen up
on C4 because after H6 Knight F5 black
grabs the pawn on F7 with Checkmate but
another illustration of your point
Robert if we rewind to this position H6
check is an incredibly tempting move
which does win if the king drops back to
G8 but it doesn't in this case black
actually takes on H6 and white loses his
entire Advantage because Queen H4 check
it seems like forced mate but it is in
the king is an incredibly slippery piece
when it's on under attack it doesn't go
down quickly after Queen H7 King F6
white is subtly at a dead end the King
has access uh as an escape shoot to the
center it can dip back to the king side
in the event of Queen H4 and this is
just another false positive that Jordan
Bend Forest has to avoid he's got a lot
of work to do but the reason I think
he's got the win in the bag has to do
with the time on his clock because of
his great crazy preparation he has over
an hour to figure out these subtleties
and for a player of his caliber rubber I
think it's safe to say that these tasks
are more than manageable
okay so I want to ask another defensive
question so this line I get it Black's
King is in big trouble so instead of
King G7
um in the live position can black Rook
B6 is that a way to defend along the
sixth rank the whole threat for white
was H6 G6 H6 g66 Queen takes G6 to the
F7 Pawn is pinned so The Rook provides
another Defender towards the king side
that pawn on G6 now is protected and
before you answer the question and I
will let you answer it I was just going
to say that this is clearly a more
Jordan Von Forest type of position than
nishikiri type position a niche does not
like it when his King is under attack no
player really enjoys it uh I guess
homoph you know from that's a name to
throw out there wow
yeah one of the best defenders in chess
history but Anish Geary is not going to
be enjoying himself trying to save his
King I have a funny story about Houma
for a little comic relief but first let
me take a stab at your question Jordan
Forest to to quote Mikhail tall has
succeeded in taking his opponent into a
forest where two plus two equals five
and there's only enough uh the path is
narrow enough only for one person to
return who will that person be well
after Rook C1 I think it's very likely
to be white but I agree the game is
actually far from over I assume you're
intending Knight B5 or is Knight A4 more
sensible with the Rook already on
because Knight B5 I could actually
potentially take on C5 uh and you can't
take back because of the discovery
against the queen yeah I like Knight A4
because it also allows for Knight B2
with a fork against Queen and Bishop I
just I mean there's clearly something
great for white what it just doesn't
seem readily apparent and your move
Queen E4 simple strong bring your queen
up into the attack Bishop takes F7
Knight takes episode of the queen E8
check all sorts of threats are there I
get it and maybe it is that simple The
Rook on B6 can go over to f six to try
to defend but with Queen E7 on the
docket maybe it's just too little too
late I mean Black's position is falling
apart and oh one more oh sorry go ahead
one more note though about uh homoph he
was known as the central Defender right
because he was such a tenacious
resourceful uh player at fending off big
attacks
yeah and and the I I will have to rewind
to the starting position to tell that
story but I promise it'll only take me a
couple of seconds but before I do that
in this specific position which is quite
likely to arise I think it's important
to indicate that after C takes D4 you
don't want to take on F7 with the bishop
because after Rook takes F7 queeniehx
the queen comes back to the rescue we
actually saw a similar line like this
much earlier when black still was on
Castle that Queen on before is a better
Defender than it looks but the problem
is Knight takes F7 uh setting up a
devastating Discovery and after Rook F7
Queen E8 Check Yes the queen comes back
to f8 but in this case it doesn't help
and what's the game-winning move it is
H5 H6 and how symbolic is that Robert
that the move which might win the game
uh is Possible only because of that
novelty which Jordan van Forrest
demonstrated on all the way back on move
eight h2h4 in the opening and the H Pawn
is an Irreplaceable contributor to this
decisive attack Anish Gary is down to 20
minutes and with every ticking second I
think his chances are getting closer and
closer to zero
I think that anishkira is tournament
Ambassador wants to ban Jordan van
forest from this tournament because he
would have a
tougher Jordan run for us in 2021 taking
him down in a Time scramble in
Armageddon uh here in 2023 Anish giri if
he had been able to win this game he
would tie or become close to no deerback
Abdul sitarov but right now he's just
getting blown off the board thanks to
Stellar preparation from Von Forest but
for Fun Forest he is a previous winner
he won in 2021 as we talked about
numerous times but he can play the
ultimate spoiler in the next two games
against Denise Geary we see what's
happening he has a winning advantage and
he gets black against no dearbec abduce
Atara so look at the start he lost in
round three to Fabiano he lost around
five to Parham and round seven to
probably now with the black pieces
Three L's then he beat Arjun he looks
like he's well on his way to victory
over in his giri and with the opening
preparation that we've seen from him and
we know what he's capable of he's won
this super tournament before
no Derby has to be very careful you
can't take this opponent for granted
just because he struggled in the first
11 games
indeed Jordan man Forest he plays for a
win with both colors in this game if he
can in fact complete this attack will
give him a massive confidence boost
going into that all-important final
round against Notre back abdusitor if I
may share my story really quickly before
we go back to the birds of you I know
people are really excited about the
Magnus game which is seeing some major
Transformations my coach left sakis uh
told me this story from one of the
Soviet championships in the 1980s ratmir
holmoff had a very long night uh where
he was doing undisclosed things I'll let
people fill in the blanks and when he
came to the board on the following day
he played the moves D4 his opponent was
White rap mirror was black he plays F5
normal Dutch defense Knight to C3
Wallace and then he plays E6 not the
best move in the position but a second
raid option white plays E4 opening up
the center olmoff confidently takes on
e4 then he plays the move Knight B8 to
C6 and after Knight F3 he executes the
move H6 at this point I think it might
have been I don't remember who it was I
think it was tall who comes over to the
board I guess within a gassed expression
of his right mirror he tops him on the
shoulder what on Earth are you doing
what do you mean what I'm doing mahil
Nick image I'm playing the night roof of
course that's how he played the night
off but reflected about uh the e-file
and uh well you can guess what he was
doing on the night before to Warrant
this line needless to say he lost the
game unevently
seems very eventful given the nature of
that position and I was clear what he
was doing he was creating Novelties for
the Chess World to uh talk about many
years later but that's a thing of the
past homeop was known as the central
Defender he was resilient as they come
uh but I think that in each Geary it's
beyond that at the moment his King side
is just he's being hunted and he doesn't
have sufficient defense and you see the
look on his face it does kind of say it
all so we'll leave a niche to this
defensive task he'll need Jordan to slip
up to have a chance here but somebody
who had as an outside chance at fighting
for first place is the world champion
Magnus Carlson so Magnus he needs no
deerback to lose at some point and he
needs to win his final two games and we
have seen a
um determined Magnus in the last five
rounds he's won three games and in this
game against pragnanda he also looks
determined to keep up that streak and
prognanda on the other side he's looking
to end his losing streak he's lost three
of the last four games and it's not been
a fun last Bunch for him and we see Rook
E3 the last one from Magnus two nights
against two Bishops but Donna this isn't
the open board that Bishops thrive in
and Magnus Carlson has made a decision a
couple moves ago that I deemed very
unlikely he did indeed take on T5 and
not only did he take on D5 he actually
took with the bishop in our analysis the
bishop was perhaps the most important
Cog in White's attacking machine because
it stood behind the uh battery that
white could have constructed with the
queen and Bishop but Magnus Carlson has
such a deep feel for the position and
one of the Hallmarks of the greatest
players in the world is that they are
able to make unconventional decisions
they violate the rules and they know
when to do it and they just see past the
sort of superficial drawbacks of the
move and I actually think magnus's
decision to take on D5 is fully
Justified now you might ask why and I'll
point out two important factors first of
all is that night on E5 just a splinter
a bone in Black's throat if you take
that Knight then you give up your
fiancated bishop and your king starts
complaining if you play F6 the Knight
dives into G6 and even nastier square
and the bishop on E6 loses its support
the second Factor sure Robert is
something we've talked about for a while
the presence of this Pawn on G5 that
pawn it sticks out like a sore thumb and
why can't use this Pawn to fuel the fire
of a king side attack with F2 F4 white
Rook is perfectly positioned to help
that out and if you move the pawn remove
the pawn from G5 the other Rook could
lift itself over to G3 and before you
know it in the blink of an eye that
could turn into a mating attack so I
think Magnus is still better
um I think you know the the rumors of
Magnus losing his Advantage have been
greatly exaggerated and I very much
still think that uh ragnananda is is in
Dire Straits here
and the problems for product are left
right and center and on the clock he has
20 moves to make and he has under 30
minutes so he is essentially in that
territory of a minute per move in this
position you mentioned F4 is a threat
white would love to open up the black
king but if you play Queen F6 for
prognanda uh we don't even need to show
it exactly but the knight from C3 that's
the one piece not doing its maximum
potential it can go to A4 and then
infiltrate on the dark squares on the
queen side so not only is there a
potential attack but strategically black
is in big trouble because the knights
have uh routes to maneuver and those
Bishops they're just staring into the
own Pawn in the case of the bishop and
E6 and the white knight in the case of
the bishop on G7 and if you ever take
that Knight on E5 your king side is in
trouble and the dark squares are
permanently whites for the taking and it
looks like he made the move Bishop F5 so
Donna he's inviting the pawn push to F4
what do you see as his follow-up I see
the move F6 I think he's moved the
bishop away from what would turn into
the most vulnerable Square on the board
if he plays F6 so I think Magnus has to
calculate F4 after F4 F6 if we could
bring up an analysis board and I think
Magnus does have a very appealing
positional alternative if he doesn't
want to calculate but after F4 F6 the
critical move here is Knight E5 to G6
and the additional benefit of putting
the bishop on F5 is that you can now
snap that Knight off the board and
perhaps you could follow up with the
move F6 F5 reopening your fiancato
Bishop this is kind of what Prague wants
he wants a sharp position he wants to
generate some chances here because right
now it's a one-sided position or white
is having all the fun so this is the
likely outcome if Magnus plays F4 uh
before I pass it back to you I think a
very Magnus style move would be Queen D2
back to D1 why on Earth would you play
that move well because the drawback of
Bishop F5 is that it weakens the central
Square on D5 and the queen has exciting
prospects now on both sides of the board
Queen D1 is a non-committal move that
accentuates the pressure threatens B7
and D5 and just makes the situation even
nastier for black I had to make a
prediction I think Magnus might play
Queen D1 pretty quickly here
I'm not gonna lie Queen D1 is one of my
favorite moves that you've ever
suggested in commentary and it's a
really really deep point because making
me turn red here Robert good thing we're
off camera for the moment but the D5
Pawn is a Target and also if the move F6
is played just to continue that line
then Knight G6 will be played and in
this variation it's that much better for
white because the bishop has to take on
G6 and after H6 G6 because the pawn is
on F2 after F5 the white Rook can just
slide on over to E1 there's no Pawn
hanging on F4 there's no tension uh in
the position and the queen jumping over
to B3 The Rook landing on E7 is your
point or E6 the problems for black are
all over the place and so Queen D1 is
just one of those moves it's not passing
the turn exactly but it's creating new
threats you always take into account
while your opponent's last move did the
bishop on F5 opened up F6 but it also
weakened blast control of the D5 Pawn I
love Queen D1 I think it's a very Magnus
type of move and with the lead on the
clock and the advantage that I see him
having on the board I think prognanda is
going to struggle to try to maintain any
sort of balance I mean it is worse for
him objectively and I think practically
speaking just much harder to play
it is I mean you could see the evil bar
plus point a plus one that's a pretty
big Advantage as it is but practically
the situation is even tougher Queen D1
is also approved of by our silicon fiend
or friend depending on where you sit
Magnus is in full control he's in full
control on the clock and if he uncorks
Queen D1 I just feel like prague's
position is so so hard to defend
well friend and fiend are one letter
apart and it's going to be a tough
defensive task for Prague Nanda and well
Magnus Carlson it's clear that he's
still energetic he is still playing for
victories and after such a long
tournament here uh it's not always easy
to do but the Meetup caught up with
Magnus to see how he's feeling about the
rest of the tournament and his energy
levels coming into these last couple
rounds
that's how are you feeling well I mean
we've had two free days in the the last
uh you know five days so
um it should be it should be fun
um you know offices uh it's um it's a
long-term but um
yeah you've got to keep on um fighting
and you know uh I don't feel worse now
that I did at the start so that's all
right
Magnus Carl is saying he doesn't feel
worse than he did at the start but his
start was really not good a win against
visit kymer in round two a game hopes
for a fantastic tournament but rounds
four and five he met roadblocks in Anish
giri and no dearbec Abdul sitarov not so
coincidentally the two players who were
leading entering this round 12. so Donya
with two rounds to go look at all the
W's from rounds seven through ten Magnus
seems to be finding his form perhaps a
little bit too late but sometimes better
late than never and I've said this
before I'll say it again every time the
Chess World starts to shovel dirt on the
world champion he just finds it in
himself to turn the narrative around
this of course is one of the key
Hallmarks of all-time greats in any
sport it's just their ability to take a
tournament that with another loss or two
could turn into the worst performance of
their life and make it into a
performance that definitely wouldn't be
called the best performance of magnus's
life if he even wins the tournament but
it definitely would be one of the
greatest comebacks of his career if he
can finish strong in the last two rounds
obviously he doesn't control his Destiny
entirely he needs some help from some of
the players he needs some help from
Wesley so he didn't get any he'll need
some help from Jordan van forest in the
last round
sometimes you need a little bit of help
from your friends or from fiends and
Jordan Von Forest happens to be both
Jordan has a great position against
Anish Geary and that's exactly what
Magus Carlson needs so that's the friend
but the fiend in Jordan van Forest is a
guy with crazy preparation who once
again has been a friend to Madness for
the world championship matches he has
been a second on Magnus Carlson's team
and so for Magnus himself you look at
this position he has great chances he
needs to focus squarely solely on this
position and queen D1 I love that move
the more I think about it the more I
like it because I'm actually not sure
what prognana should play as a response
to it as Queen B3 threatens two pawns at
the same time and I just don't know how
Prague is going to deal with those dual
threats
there are other moves that on the docket
that Magnus would consider you could
play Rook F1 to E1 but I don't love that
move because it relinquishes not
entirely but somewhat the possibility of
pushing the pawn to F4 and the best
moves are those that keep all of the
options open while increasing the
pressure Queen D1 checks all of the
boxes in that regard 48 minutes on the
clock to make 20 moves for the world
champion he definitely doesn't have to
rush he can really take his time enjoy
this position I'm sure he's having a
good time thinking of all the ways in
which he could cause further problems to
his young incredibly talented but
struggling opponent and there it is yeah
he's definitely put Queen D1 of course
he did was there ever any doubt Robert
that he would play this move brilliant
suggestion by you and Brilliant move
from Magnus Carlsen I mean one of the
key things about the lines we've been
discussing is that if black plays F6 a
much needed move to kick that pesky
Knight out of E5 the light squares
become vulnerable and then Magnus will
dominate them how do you dominate them
with your queen on the light squares and
go into B3 and in the event of a trade
on G6 going over into G4 so Rook E8
played quite quickly from prognanda I
think that for Magnus Rook F to E1 makes
sense but now I'm sort of spying some
tactics is there a knight takes F7 here
because the f-file is a problem for
black whoa talking of brilliant
suggestions it definitely has to be
considered shall we delve into the the
complications Knight takes F7 I think we
have to look
all right let's bring up our analysis
board Knight takes that well I feel like
I have to take and Rook after you have a
rook F3 even better than Queen F3
oh no the game is over here you can't
take back because after Queen to D7
there's Queen D3 but there's also the
straightforward G4 isn't there
yeah both moves look just great for
white uh G4 has a little bit more wrist
because the king is open we see the
evaluation stay Sky High for white and
after you take on F5 down goes D5 as
well this is just a is this netting a
pawn from Magnus after Knight takes F7
is what can prognanda do
he has to move his Queen the queen is
hanging if he moves it to C7 he releases
his control over the D5 Pawn that makes
things even worse that evil bar shoots
up even further Knight comes back to E5
and the same ideas for assist except you
don't have the F Pawn anymore you're
absolutely right Knight F7 is an amazing
tactic and I love moments when
positional pressure is transformed into
an attack or into a tactic this is has
just been a textbook display by Magnus
where does the Queen have to go Robert
to minimize the damage I guess to D7
but then the Knight comes back to E5
with tempo oh my goodness
and after Bishop E5 I think it's
important to indicate that well maybe D
takes oh D takes C5 Works yes because
the the fd4 there is Knight E4 perhaps
oh
gosh can anything go right here for
Prague
Knight comes to have six
F4 is coming this is totally lost
and D4 is loose yeah this is just really
bad I mean Knight takes F7
isn't that just winning a pawn and I
don't know how prognanda can defend
himself do you think because he played
the move rookie quickly he missed it I
think he missed it but I'm like maybe
he's just looked at this tactic and
found some kind of resource but I'm not
seeing a resource at all I think Knight
takes of seven is going to shock him and
Magnus I mean he is looking up that
board Rook fte1 is a simple move that
should keep white slightly better but
Knight takes F7 is the type of move that
helps you win a tournament and Magnus he
should not miss that especially after
finding Queen D1 which is such a nice
move and I wouldn't excoriate the world
champion if he plays Rook fe1 quickly
but Magnus has been in such sharp form
the second half of the tournament and
Knight takes episode just be consistent
with the way that he plays these
positions Magnus is one of the greatest
positional players of all time but I
think Knight takes F7 is a move he would
be likely to find in a Blitz game
foreign
huge moment and I believe he sees it but
he's calculating it because you don't
want to make some kind of mistake where
not you it's not that you throw your
advantage away but it might make Black's
defensive task easy in some ways not in
this position uh taking on F7 following
it up with Rook F3 to pin that Bishop on
F5 that Rook on f8 it looked like it was
passive but it was doing an important
duty it was covering the F7 pawn and
Knight takes F7 is a huge opportunity
for the world champion he's lucky he's
got it Robert yeah you could tell
glare yeah he he knows it's there he's
looking at Knight takes F7 and the
follow-up and if he finds that move
what'd he just do
he moved I believe he reached over
somewhere to Black side of the board and
that can only mean one thing I think
has he taken an F7 he might not have
um
I don't board should update I think he
did
I think he
because I don't see the I know there's a
rook on E1 though he went Rook fd1 oh
man a missed opportunity but he keeps as
I said let's not go crazy here he keeps
a big Advantage but man he takes F7 was
just a golden opportunity to end this
game real fast you could make it in time
for lunch
I mean there must have been some kind of
Defense there for black because the Eva
bar was up quite High uh but if we go
back that half move before work after E1
it wasn't like completely winning was it
the evaluation bar wasn't through the
roof it was just uh an advantage for
white but uh Knight takes F7 there that
looked like a real opportunity for the
world champion but as I look at his
position it still looks great so it's
not like a good plan I'll tell you what
I I don't like spitting out you know
engine lines but just to establish
Clarity on this situation I would guess
that Magnus might have missed Knight
takes F7 but the actual computer line is
as follows Queen to D7 Knight to E5 and
now apparently the only move to avoid a
lost totally lost fish is Rook takes E5
with the obvious idea that de is met
with D4 that is not an easy move to see
white therefore has to take back with
the rook and after the capture on E5 and
this is starting to make more sense this
position is all not all that easy to
evaluate Robert because this Pawn is
very very menacing yes white has won a
pawn yes Black's King is weak but
when you look at the eval bar and you
see plus 1.5 uh the the menacing nature
of the D4 Pawn is diminished again we
can't forget that the players do not
know the evaluation so it would make
sense that Magnus calculated to this
position and decided that he wants to
keep the tension and wants to keep the
status quo so to speak uh and continue
squeezing yeah thank you for putting
this position on the board because as I
look at this position I can't quite make
out the number of the evaluations uh you
know hard for my eyes I have four of
them and I still can't see it but this
looks like a promising defensive chance
for black the king is open sure but that
deep Pawn keeps White's pieces a bit
stuck tied down locating that pawn the
bishop 105 the queen D7 Rook date all
doing uh work here to help that pawn go
forward so maybe Magnus saw this and
Rook takes E5 what a tactical shot that
would have been from prognanda it does
look good for white I agree uh with the
chat there but it's a position that may
maybe black would have chance to hold at
least it you feel some open space for
your pieces whereas if your move is
Bishop E6 you're rich you're retreating
back and forth white can continue with
the other plan Knight A4 now all of
white pieces are pretty optimal squares
with the exception being this Knight on
C3 so Knight A4 then the Knight goes
into C5 and white is just completely
dominating many of the important squares
in the position yeah I don't think that
we should make a mountain out of a
molehill I think something similar
happened in magnus's game against
Fabiano caruana which of course he
wanted the black pieces in convincing
fashion once uh Magnus carried out the
game-winning idea he had several ways to
win the game faster but instead he chose
to liquidate into a winning end game he
still won that game pretty fast he was
still dominating from wire to wire so I
think this is an example of that Magnus
should still win this game if he
continues playing with the same level of
energy the same level of positional
Acumen that he has displayed in the
first 20 moves of this game
I I'm with you I think uh 1967 was there
and perhaps you just didn't see it all
together sometimes it escapes your radar
it is much easier to commentate because
you throw out ideas and you see the eval
bar off the side saying that white is
much better that helps you when the eval
are changes right at first it was pretty
steadily at around 0.7 it seemed but
then it went up that indicates there's a
tactic there and that's what allowed me
to look at Knight takes F7 to focus in
on it but after Bishop E6 I do think
that Magnus has an advantage he can play
Knight A4 breathe the Knight into C5 and
I think that he'll be happy so while
Magnus and prognanda they're gonna
jockey for some position why don't we
zoom out for a second and look at our
bird's eye view
because this is not the only important
game in session we have the game between
abusa tariff and Wesley so still looking
better for yeah in the top left but
Wesley is holding on with a knight on B1
covering the C3 square but over the
other side Dania it looks like Jordan
Von Forest even though he still has an
attack maybe anishikiri is back in the
game
a huge development in that game Anita
security is down to only 12 minutes in
Yard Man Forest did not take a lot of
time in the critical moment and came up
with what seems to be a serious mistake
at least according to the engine rather
than shifting his Rook from F1 to C1 and
let's just go to that game and you know
there are some other fascinating
positions in muksudu Eric I see we've
got all sorts of pandemonium uh report
ding heating up as well but this of
course is the tournament that has the
most impact uh the game that has the
most impact on the tournament standings
D takes C5 was Jordan van Forest Choice
Anish giri calmly holy Cooley shifts his
Rook from B6 over to C6 and as a
consequence of that capture the D file
has opened the position has changed a
little bit and Robert I'm having a hard
time just adjusting my eyes to this new
set of circumstances but why is it that
dc5 loses oh my gosh perhaps a Lion's
Share of White's Advantage there's a
crazy tactic here I think if I'm not
wrong Jordan was relying on Knight takes
F7 here because if the Rook takes F7 if
we can show this line
um Knight F7 Rook F7 Bishop takes check
King takes Queen E7 check it looks like
you're just winning right Queen D7 wins
The Rook on C6 but if we move the king
back to f8 or to G8 somewhere there and
you take the Rook you get checkmated
because a knight E2 and then after the
King goes the H file Queen H4 is check
lands
Anastasia's mate Anastasia's mate it
makes an appearance and for Jordan Von
Forest it was so far down the line it's
incredibly difficult to see that the
white king might get checkmated and he
goes to this line believing that he's
gonna win material but it is not there
for him because the Knight on C3 is
going to hop to the E2 Square deliver
the first check and the queen will Land
The Knockout blow that is a crazy
variation
Anish Gary he never dies these top
players they always seem to find a way
to make things complicated and you're
absolutely right Knight takes F7 would
end the game on this spot if it weren't
for the 92 resource now Jordan has to
find an alternative now I should also
point out that Rook C1 uh the old friend
the move that should have won him the
game almost on the spot now runs into a
formidable foe in Rook takes C5 and that
is why D takes C5 helps black not only
does it open up the center but it also
enables The Rook to join into the
defensive effort it attacks the Knight
on G5 and guess what if I plays Rook
takes C3 after Rook takes G5 black is
simply winning he fully consolidates his
King side and we shouldn't forget that
black is up in exchange so Jordan's
attack it has to succeed or he's
actually going to be worse Roxy one is
impossible uh Knight takes F7 is
ineffective there is Bishop takes F7
check but it might fail for exactly the
same reason that Knight takes F7 fail
else this is a stunning development
Robert and this is why we can never
say anything for certain positions
change really quickly we're talking
about humans here and this might have
just been a significant a huge
turnaround as Jordan just probably
didn't take quite enough time on D take
C5
he has nearly an hour on the clock and
you see Jordan there he kind of held his
head in his hands he is calculating in
Anish giri he's perked up because that
variation we're looking at it could lead
to a force draw perhaps but not more
than that for white so he has to be
careful not to lose this game and Anish
Geary he might have chances to play for
first all of a sudden out of nowhere
that is just a really sharp variation
and it's one that Jordan is going to
regret but we'll leave Jordan to it he's
going to spend some time thinking here
and before we head to break we want to
make mention of a very special event
coming up starting soon it is the pro
chess League it is back with elite
players like Magnus and Hikaru
headlining this season and a prize pool
of 150 000 the 2023 season will be one
for the history books qualifiers begin
February 1st and the main event starts
on February 14th use the command PCL and
chat for all the details for now on
behalf of myself and Daniel neraditski
we're gonna head to break and when we
return it's more from round 12 at the
Tanta still Masters we'll see you soon
[Music]
hey everybody it's Danny here and as you
may know chess.com and chessable are now
one and I'm here to show you how you can
makeyourchess.com and chessable one in
just a few clicks to start let's log in
and connect our chess.com account I just
scroll right here above the browser and
click log in scroll down and click
continue with chess.com now if you're
already logged into chess.com it's just
gonna ask you if you want to approve
that connection I'm going to say yes sir
but after approving it'll bring you
right back to the chessable home page
now the puzzle connect feature can be
found under Tools and you click puzzle
Connect Now what that does after you
type in your username is it's going to
pool positions from the games you've
played on chess.com create your very own
personalized chessable course and then
quiz you with the positions where you
may have missed the best move and the
more you play on chess.com the more
games it will have to quiz you as long
as your account stays connected it's
pretty sweet and it's going to help you
get better learning from the mistake in
your games yes this is a pro feature
accessible but if you go to
chessable.com link you can get 30 days
of pro for free
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
given a second lease of life in this
position against his compatriot and
friend Jordan Vaughn Forest the number
one player from the Netherlands Manish
Geary taking on the number two Dutch
player Jordan Von forest and while
anishikiri is the higher rated player
and is doing better in this tournament
in vikon Zay Jordan actually leads the
series with one win and three draws so
Donya something about the vikon Zay
water brings out the best in Jordan but
also the best in a niche historically
he has indeed played very well against
the Supreme Patriot has a yard and Van
Forest but he struggled in this
tournament and it seemed like the
narrative would continue with a Surefire
win but now we have a stunning
development Jordan bed forest refrains
from Rook C1 which would have given him
a decisive attack commits a tactical
oversight and now essentially has to win
the game from scratch I think we should
clarify uh that white is still better
white continues to attack anishkiri's
position is still very much unenviable
his time situation is still disturbing
13 minutes for 13 moves and I think
Jordan has done a good job of slowing
himself down calming himself down one of
the hardest things to do is to recover
from a tactical oversight of this
magnitude but if he calmly drops his
Knight back to F3 the presence of the
bishop on C4 coupled uh with obviously
Black's long-term King weakness I think
still gives white excellent tactical
chances and excellent chances uh to to
win this game so that's not exactly
graduate the situation Gordon is still
in charge but he has to put what has
just happened completely behind him and
focus on the task at hand I feel like
it's going to be difficult we've all
been there games where we're like I'm
gonna win this one it's gonna be a swift
end to it I'm gonna check my opponent
and now the white king is actually in a
bit of danger as well because at some
Moment The Black Queen can slide back to
say B7 and go for checkmate and wow we
see Jordan
F4 and then Rook G7 quickly played by a
nation that might be a mistake we see
the eval bar going up and up Donya so
what is the problem with this Rook G7
move well before I answer that question
the reason Jordan has played F4 I think
it's a very natural move because he
wants to keep his Knight on G5 and it's
worth paying the relatively small price
of uh his King weakness to keep that
Knight on G5 in addition uh you've you
now have the idea of lifting The Rook up
to F3 so Rook F3 immediately is
attempting move you could first start by
taking on F7 and eliminating uh one of
the key pawns that gives Black's King
shelter and then you could follow up
with Rook F3 so something about Rook G7
the engine does not like it might have
to do with Knight takes F7 it might have
to do with Rook F3 but another move that
I think has its appeal is just a common
move like King H2 just get the King off
of the first rank take the sting out of
a potential Queen B1 which would
otherwise come with check and prepare a
rook lift to H3 am I missing something
or is that uh right about the reason
Rook G7 might be a mistake well King H2
makes a lot of sense just Rook F3 can be
met by Queen B1 check as Dania has
mentioned you want to get those Queens
off the board the black king will feel
much safer you see the eval bar drop
completely so we do not want to trade
Queens if we're thinking whether it's
from Jordan's perspective and so let's
go kingage too but black might have the
resource Queen to B2 here that Knight is
now Frozen in place if you ever want to
play Knight takes F7 and go for tactics
uh it's going to be tactically terrible
for you because Queen takes G2 is where
does that queen go
you've been doing your puzzle Rush
solving this one yeah that means that if
just a moment ago Pawn H6 becomes a
really big threat as the Knight can't
move so all of a sudden there are many
things that Jordan has to figure out
apparently this is even because of
course all chess play uh Physicians are
just uh equal no matter what how in the
world this is equal oh my god do you
want to hear why that's an amazing
reason it's checked Queen F5 just
another day in the UPS just give up the
night Bishop takes up seven get out only
move otherwise you lose and whichever
Rook takes a pathway is opened up for
White's Queen White's Queen
single-handedly delivers Perpetual Rook
F7 Queen C8 and no matter with which
Rook you block how you block the queen
is always just gonna have one more check
and white does just enough here to make
the drive the King goes to the H file uh
in any situation you or are only asking
for trouble due to Rook H3 that just
illustrates the tremendous attacking
potential even if white loses all of his
pieces he still has enough Firepower to
secure the drop
that is an unbelievable sequence so it
is there are going to be some ideas for
Jordan to get rid of that F7 Pawn uh the
black king will be in trouble uh King H2
that feels like a great move I feel like
we're playing bullet chess that's the
move I would play and queen B2 feels
like kind of an only option for black
you need to create threats of your own
otherwise your king is going to be in
trouble so
um maybe
Knight takes F7 you can start with but
that if that doesn't work out you might
just be down to piece because after
Knight F7 just to put this briefly Rook
F7 and if you play Rook F3 then there's
this queen B1 check again unfortunately
it just feels a little bit too slow as
the Queens come off the white loses
white just loses so oh my gosh this is
tricky
yeah so here you yeah we are aware that
the evil bar is showing a decisive
Advantage right but just imagine having
this position you've given up your main
attacker and now in order to continue
the attack here
apparently you have to find King hu
degree of difficulty on that sequence is
through the roof first you sack your
main attacker then you play a
ridiculously calm move as you sit down a
rook Jordan's Brooke Burke Jordan's work
is very much cut out for him and I think
there is a very high likelihood that he
plays King H2 in this position doesn't
mean that the draw is then guaranteed
for Anish Gary Queen B2 is a very
difficult move to find and ichigiri's
clock continues to dwindle imagine Anish
giri just such an unavailable task made
even more difficult by the fact that
he's got 13 minutes to make over a dozen
incredibly difficult defensive moves can
you explain something to me so Knight
takes F7
right let's just go for this variation
again okay Rook takes up seven you have
to take with the G row well if you take
with the effort he made it in one
because Queen dates Checkmate good to
show talk about puzzle
uh Rook takes F7 King H2 what's wrong
with King hates getting out of the pin
I'm like not seeing the end result the
evaluation say completely winning for
white I think I see it all right tell me
and I'll tell you what it's not it's not
Queen D4 check hoping for King G8 Bishop
F7 because the Rook is able to block the
check and black wins immediately I think
it's simpler than it appears Bishop
takes F7 Force The Rook off of the
eighth rank deliver the check no it's
not simple then it appears I thought
well can I be forgiven for thinking that
this is winning for white I mean 94. the
Knight comes to the rescue oh my gosh
Black's pieces are so resilient and G3
square is covered why is that a dead end
and has to find some sort of a Perpetual
apparently this is drawn too oh you can
still play Rook G3 and deliver a
Perpetual with Queen G5 Queen D it's
just unbelievable lines
what is the move I have no I
I have no idea it's like eight oh my
gosh what is it it's an impossible move
this move is unfindable so A3 I was
guessing an impossible nope
Rock F1 it's a rook move one
what
oh because 94 this Rook C4 yes oh but E4
is not the only retreating Square for
the night if the Knight goes not to E4
Rook B1
Rook B1 wins you can also win by doing
that maneuver with the check and the
check and then actually going Rook to D1
and there's no way to stop and defend
both of the infiltration squares if Rook
f8 then Rook D7 mates otherwise Rook d8
is for us mate this is not human I mean
the lines we're talking about here are
out of here other worldly first you're
giving up the Knight on F7 your main
attacking piece you don't even have a
direct follow-up you need to see all the
way down to Rook C1 you want to play
Rook F3 as we've been talking about
Queen DHS all of this but no it's
suddenly sliding your Rook away to C1
that is I mean it's not impossible I
will say that some players would be able
to find that but is extremely improbable
I
wow I'm shocked by that
yeah every single move in that sequence
is just in and of itself incredibly hard
to find made more difficult by the fact
that you have to see all of them when
you make the first one you can't just
play Knight takes F7 and say oh well I
just trust that I'm gonna find something
there because it makes no sense from a
conceptual standpoint you're giving up
your main attacker but what an
instructive line play on both sides of
the board some of the hardest moves in
chess to find are moves that occur on
the other side of the board when you're
attacking on the queen side it's a
random move on the king side sending the
Knight away and just exploiting the fact
that 94 always runs in to Rook C4 what
an incredible sequence Robert but if I
had to bet I'd bet that Jordan will play
King H2 here
when that cares any scary chances and
you know if this game you just look at
it it is topsy-turvy it is double edged
all three results possible all three
results likely I don't know what is
gonna happen in this one but Anish he
has a chance and I think he feels a lot
better because even if there is that
crazy winning position he probably
hasn't calculated that he would have
played Rook G7 so quickly if he saw all
the way through with Knight F7 and Rook
C1 to finish off that variation so he
probably is looking at this position
with renewed hope and for Jordan Von
Forest frustration because he feels it's
slipping away black shouldn't have been
able to defend with his Rook coming to
G7
and the time situation could reverse how
easy would it be in this position to
take 25 30 minutes I mean that time
disappears in the blink of an eye when
you're calculating variations that are
as complex as the ones that Jordan is
facing in a weird kind of way Black's
defensive task may actually be more
straightforward than White's attacking
tasks because the ball is in white
scored Jordan is the one who has to sift
through countless defensive moves and
calculate countless variations if he
takes on F7 all in each Geary has to see
is that Rook takes F7 gets mated in one
move so
at this point I could totally see Jordan
getting into severe time pressure and
you can see him intently focused
concentrating trying to figure out a way
to capitalize on this attack what a
shame would it be if Jordan was not able
to convert this incredible preparation
and early middle game play and yet it is
increasingly looking Robert despite the
eval bar
that all three results are possible
really possible for the first time in a
couple moves I'm shaking my head just
because of how difficult that variation
we can look at is defined you have to
take on F7 bring your king to H2 and
then you Rook to C1 these just don't go
hand in hand so for you from forest he
has no idea that he's winning he
probably doesn't think he is winning he
probably thinks that he's actually let
this slip and it's a very challenging
position so uh the eval bar is
misleading at this point because there
may be that only way to be uh with the
advantage otherwise you might just be
worse so Jordan he's gonna sit and paint
uh things are changing in other games so
we should probably take a look at some
of the other action if we go to our
bird's eye view we can look around at
our various games in the top left
between Wesley so and nerdy bet no
deerback abusotarev it looks like Wesley
is doing okay there right he's
challenging flux Pawn structure the
opposite colored Bishops that one should
be a hold but the Magnus game against
prognanda the advantage still in
magnus's favor over there and probably
not is actually giving up a pawn in the
current position
yeah the situation for Prague I think
desperate is a pretty strong word but I
think an accurate one especially just
given the type of position that they
have you have been calling a lot of
moves in that game magnus's Knight has
landed on A4 and now he has just
captured the pawn on B6 much to the
Chagrin of the eval bar I think Magnus
just wants to snag that pawn and then
come back to A4 and then reroute the
Knight to the square that it really
belongs on C5 we can go to that game and
try to understand what about the move
the engine doesn't like but at this
point I think chat should be primed to
realize that the eval bar does not
doesn't just not tell the whole story it
often doesn't tell even two percent of
the story
10 is generous I mean in general with
the pressure on these players uh working
through so many different variations it
is not easy and we see magnuses grab the
pawn in the bottom right he moved his
Knight back so why don't we quickly take
a look at that game I know an Easter is
also in time trouble so we're gonna come
back there but what Magnus just did is
he took a Pawn on B6 and hopped his
Knight right back to A4 so
what's the deal why is programa still in
this game and what's the uh oh
I have an idea now it's still
crystallizing in my mind the move order
but my idea is actually to play Rook
takes B3 trade the Rooks which seems
counter-intuitive because you're down
upon you don't necessarily want to
simplify but after Rook takes B3 and
Magnus kind of holding his pen there and
not writing his move down yet that is
often a sign uh that you've kind of
realized that there are unforeseen
difficulties or a move that you missed
after Queen takes me three I think this
might be the perfect opportunity for
black to take on E5 and the reason after
rooked ac5 you used to have all of your
heavy pieces on the back right now you
have none and the queen can travel to C1
and then deliver a follow-up check to F4
forking a bunch of fonts at the same
time you're gonna lose uh your D4 pawn
and your entire position is going to
start crumbling at the seams now if
Magnus takes on E5 with the pawn which
would be very likely then black gets a
major source of counter play
rocket push D4 immediately you could
bring the Rook into the game but I think
a position like this Robert is a million
times more double edged than I
envisioned this game to be it is more
double-edged but white is a pawn a head
and we like to take stock and note is
easier for white to play and do we feel
like white has more winning chances than
black has chances to hold but it's now
three results it's not just oh black
might play Stubborn defense and make a
draw well I could even win this game
thanks to that past Pawn the offside
Knight I do believe that it is more
difficult for black because her King is
open and that Knight on A4 let's say if
the queen moves up and the Knight gets
to C5 and maybe into E4 uh there is
potential oh oh my gosh what a shock
this what a shocking resource
so Queen before I guess instead of Queen
D3 but that is a surprise out of left
field
talk about that this is literally out of
left field just bang bang bang and this
is how quickly black can win this game
that's nasty like completely out of
nowhere this Fork A4 and E1 how often do
you have pieces on those two squares
that are forked by a queen from A5
almost never so the queen would have
been better serving as moving up to B4
or something of the sort and then the
Knight trying to come to C5 and the
Knight really wants to get on over to
the F6 square and that would cause the
black king some problems so it's a game
with a lot of life left and well we
actually have action I'm sorry to take
us away from here we just got here no no
it looks like Jordan Vaughn Forest he
did make a move in that game and Anish
responded quite quickly because he does
not have much time remaining he's about
a minute per move and it's not getting
any easier for either player
it isn't and it's not going to get
easier for a long time The Rook has
shifted from F1 to C1 but the bad news
for Jordan fans is that he did not start
with Knight takes F7 and King H2 shame
on him for missing that incredibly easy
win really he should not be reinvited to
Titus steel uh instead he played the
immediate Rooks he once and get off me
forcing that pesky Knight to the fringes
of the board and it's happy to go to the
fringes on A4 it is quite a bit safer
than it was on C3 and of course the
queen is now a lot more free uh to go
wherever it needs to go which is very
likely to be B2 probably Queen takes C5
is never gonna work unless Anish Gary
finds a way to sneak his King into the
corner but what is Jordan's follow-up
going to be Knight takes F7 Robert is
still very much on the table but that's
just one of many candidate moves King H2
is still possible I think Knight takes
F7 could force a draw we saw some lines
where the White Queen goes on the yo-yo
string from d8 to G5 back and forth and
that would lead to a drawback repetition
an endless series of checks so for
Jordan right now can he play for a win
there is risk to playing for a win here
because if black can slide that King
over to h8 have you been as you've been
advocating for there may no longer be a
checkmated attack and if that Knight
gets kicked out of G5 the G2 Pawn is a
target C5 is loose Knight B2 is kind of
a threat here forking the queen of the
bishop so I think Jordan has to be very
careful I would not be that surprised if
he sort of bails out and tries to make a
draw by capturing out of seven
and I definitely would not blame him for
doing so especially as his time
Advantage continues to dwindle I'm going
to channel my inner Robert Hess and say
that one of the fascinating elements of
this game is how offense has essentially
is very likely to turn into defense the
fact that the G file is wide open has
benefited white thus far only one King
has been under the crossfire thus far
well all of that could change really
what stands between white and a an
incredibly menacing attack against the
G2 Pawn is that Knight on G5 and for the
first time this game that night has
started to feel Mighty uncomfortable
with H6 on the docket for Anish Guri
H6 Knight B2 the C5 Pawn being loose
it's not an easy way to deal with all of
that you can deal with one threat but
that opens an opportunity for black to
do something else so uh for example if
you play Queen D4 protecting the pawn on
C5 also threatening Bishop takes F7
check because whenever two pieces are in
a row like that think about what happens
with the piece in between moves but the
issue is after Queen D4 I think black
can respond with Queen B2 once again
offering a queen trade if the Queen's
come off the board then black will not
be worse and may just be better if not
winning with the extra material so
Jordan has to be so careful at this
moment there are no easy decisions and
I think Knight takes F7 that kind of
bailout is seeming increasingly likely
I agree I think with with every ticking
second the likelihood increases that
Jordan decides hey I tried my attack is
clearly going in the wrong direction let
me take this draw before it is too late
and uh obviously this is a decent result
for another backup distance better than
Anish Gary winning but Notre back later
tonight is going to look over this game
and let me tell you he's not going to be
having dinner with Jordan van Forest
after the tournament just kidding uh
obviously the degree of difficulty on
the win was quite High even the initial
win with uh Rook C1 and queen E4 again
and again Bears repeating that we take
these wins for granted when we see the
eval bar Skyrocket we have someone
tapping us on the shoulder and informing
us when a direct win exists the players
have no such luxury they've got to
figure everything out on their own
Jordan 30 minutes on the clock
as he stares at the king side trying to
figure out a sequence of moves that will
reignite the Flames of the attack but
Anish giri seems more comfortable than
at any other point in this game
and there are nearly 50 000 people
watching across all the platforms right
now shout out to each and every one of
you this has been a tense Affair between
the top two players from the Netherlands
the Dutch fans they have shown up for
these players we've seen in the
background there is a huge crowd there
are tons of chess players taking part in
this Festival it is a true Festival in
Vikings a each and every year uh players
of all ratings of all strengths they
come to Vikings day to compete in the
open tournament as you see in the
background there's Magnus Carlson from
the background are many fans taking in
the action you can see some Smiles some
serious faces some looks of
consternation after Magnus Carlson this
look is one where does he have winning
chances in this game he needs to win to
have a shot at first place
but his winning chances just took a
major hit prognananda you don't have to
tell him twice the Indian Junior will
not miss the opportunity to muddy the
waters and he didn't miss it he has
taken on E5
and uh Agnes Carlson now has to figure
out how he's going to recapture that
Bishop but all of a sudden Beck is back
black is back from the dead to be
completely honest with you Robert I had
already started shoveling dirt on
prognananda in that middle game with
whitesnites all over the weaknesses in
Black's position and all of a sudden the
narrative has shifted completely welcome
to Modern chess welcome to Tata steel
this is just what happens in this
tournament
yes and prognanda who's had a rough
series of games he's lost three of his
last four he is fighting with the best
player in chess and he's making his life
difficult so we saw the capture on E5
that is no surprise there and well many
players have had difficult tasks in
their games uh probably Nanda anishikiri
a Wesley so game I think maybe we can
show that one in the top left because we
see a position it's an end game now and
suddenly Wesley has stolen in a pawn
that doesn't tell the full story
material isn't the only thing we should
consider but Wesley did just take an a
pawn but it was sacrificed by noting
that he is playing for a win at this
stage Diana if we pull up that game
um
between Wesley there it is no dearbeck
we see that there's a white king out in
the open on F3 so while white stole an
outside Pawn a flank Pawn the move E4
check is likely to be played here
forcing the king back to E2 and after
Rook C2 check is the follow-up the whole
point is the Knight on B1 is stuck it is
not getting out and black has more
activity for the cost of material just
the pawn by the way we are aware that
Jordan continues to throw away his
Advantage he's made another mistake
we'll bring you that game uh in a in a
bit but this game is equally important
and we have an imbalance for the first
time and as you're saying after Rook to
C2 check well Knight D2 looks very
unwise because that Knight could travel
to C3 and knock the Rook off 51 white
could simply lose a piece there after
King F1 I think the big question is how
does notorbeck increase the pressure
because yes the Knight on B1 has
absolutely no Mobility but white also
has this extra Corner Pawn on A4 and
eventually White's gonna find a way to
untangle I actually don't really see a
way for Wesley to remove any of these
pieces from their dominant posts but
Wesley is more than happy to sit and
tread water do you see a way Robert for
notrebrecht tighten the screws in this
position
it's one of those end games where white
can't really move but the extra Pawn is
helpful and then black needs to throw
pawns off the board with maybe G5 and G4
something like that so if all the pawns
if you're a G5 F5 maybe F4 something
like that there would be some chances to
win the game it does feel like that's a
long way away and uh for
Wesley he is of a pawn so eight four to
A5 at some moment might be very useful
distract Black's piece let's say king f8
is playing just to make a sort of random
move
um at some moment A5 can be the choice
and after Bishop takes then Knight goes
out to A3 and is a useful minor piece
it's not just stuck at home so I think
that is the bailout that Wesley has and
he is going to be able to draw this game
but no more than that and Wesley really
needed to win today's game if he wanted
to win the tournament
and notrebrecht definitely could have
found a way just to trade all the pieces
probably could have even offered a draw
but he is fearless he always tries to
play from a position of strength he does
not shy away from complications even
when there is a warm and fuzzy
alternative that essentially guarantees
him a draw but realistically as you're
implying here notrec isn't really
playing with any risk just because he's
sacrificed upon does not mean that he's
got any serious losing chances his
extent of positional domination here is
such that that pawn is not going to go
very far it's not going to go any
further than A5 but very instructive
defensive idea when you've got an extra
Pawn in the end game it's it isn't just
an advantage in and of itself you could
use that pawn as a bargaining chip in
order to extract and carve out uh
important squares for your pieces
neuterbeck does indeed deliver that
check on e4 so we are going to see uh
the position I think after Rook C2 King
F1 happened momentarily getting back to
E2
and and the players have plenty of time
they're nearing move 40. so I think we
should go back and try to look at the
Anish Geary game with the black piece
against Jordan Von Forest uh because
that this game on screen it's very level
but for Anish giri he is in time trouble
he has been putting up amazing defense
and maybe he'll be able to turn the
tides in this game because look at
White's last move Knight G5 back to E4
by Jordan front Force he is backing up
and we don't like to
overstate the body language and say look
at this but Jordan he actually looks
bothered I've been noticing on camera
that he seems to be unhappy with how
this game has gone and for Anish giri he
just brought his Knight down to B2
hitting the queen and the bishop on C4
Knight F6 is just a single check the
king slides to h8 I don't really think
that nisha's in trouble anymore and
Jordan could be if he does not play
accurately
yeah this is it's crazy that we're
saying this but 94 uh is is a sensible
move I mean you're going over to F6 but
Knight F6 I haven't used this expression
yet today is a paper tiger the king
actually wants to go to h8 and how
impressive of Anish to position his Rook
on G7 this is the All-Star Defender this
right here is the MVP of Black's entire
defensive construction because it's
holding both F7 and H7 after king h8 the
king is essentially in an impregnable
spot what is Jordan going to do here
where is he going to move his Queen
where no matter where he moves it Anish
will either be able to take the bishop
and don't forget that white White's Rook
can't really leave the first rank
because of that check on anyone or in
the event of something like Queen B3
Anish will grab the opportunity to
exchange Queens after which I think he
will it's not that it will be a two
result game I mean black could
definitely lose that end game but Anish
will be thrilled to play what probably
objectively is a slightly better end
game unbelievable turn around here and
he's got 10 minutes he's got time and
let's not forget that Anish giri played
against dingley Wren the number two
rated player in the world with the black
pieces and was in huge struggle in that
game he not only fended off that attack
but he won that game and this is kind of
reminiscent of that one very different
positions but the same sort of premise
that Anish in trouble his opponent tries
to take him down and that he lashes out
he strikes back at a critical moment so
Daniel this is a big moment for Jordan
Von Forest he can play Queen to B3 but
the thought of an end game at this point
when you're down in exchange I just feel
like that's completely unappealing to
him but if he doesn't do that already
black is threatening to take on C4 and
just tried to go for the attack there is
a rook on G7 I want to show a quick
Checkmate that white could fall for it's
not going to happen of course not but if
say the move Knight F6 check was played
kicking the king to the corner and the
queen slides up to D4 what a great
Square for that Queen Knight C4 Rook C4
you're gonna see the evil bar drop you
took back a night but you lost the game
because Queenie won check the King has
to go to H2 and after King get your
queen G3 check the rook and queen line
up perfectly and queen takes you two is
mate at the end of the sequence so this
is showing that Black's Rook on G7 is
the perfect Defender because it's
simultaneously playing defense and
offense and that is trouble for that
white king
it is literally the best Square on the
board and I think Jordan might have to
play Queen B3 uh to limit the Damage
Done by his previous few moves he has
indeed played Queen B3 good job by
Jordan sort of accepting the inevitable
uh not continuing to tilt and make
senseless moves you know just because
the attack has evaporated I think we
shouldn't overstate the case the end
game remains extremely unclear why it's
got a lot of positional assets he's got
Pawns in the center that Knight on e4
could jump into F6 at an annoying moment
for black and for that reason I don't
think Anish giri should grab the queen
without thinking I think there is an
alternative in eight seven a five trying
to trade on even better terms because if
white grabs the queen on B4 well after a
takes B4 the threat against the bishop
persists and with the open a file black
could find a nice spot for his for his
other Rook later down the line and Anish
Gary has not taken the queen immediately
he's going to give at least a little bit
of thought to A5 one more point I wanted
to make Robert is that in this type of
situation ignorance is bliss if Jordan
having made the mistake uh of taking on
C5 earlier in the game suddenly realized
that Rook C1 essentially ended the game
it becomes exponentially harder to
maintain your objective because all
you're thinking about is how different
The Narrative could be how different you
would feel if you had just made one move
differently I think we've all been in
that situation where you realize what
you did wrong and then you simply cannot
think about the present course of action
you keep looking over at your score
sheet and you keep scolding yourself for
playing too quickly so hopefully Jordan
isn't aware that he had essentially a
win on a golden platter it would make it
a little bit easier for him to keep
trying his best to find the best moves
and I'll throw in a third option in this
position by the way the A5 looking good
Queen takes B3 of course available just
to trade Queens but Rook B8 might be a
third choice and that way you're trying
to trade Queens on your own terms you
protect your queen the C4 Bishop is now
under attack it's getting very very
spicy here there's some Knight F6 check
stuff to consider but if that Rook gets
active I feel like black suddenly is
very happy and the Knight on B2 is not
going to be trapped that's the most
important part is it looks like it's in
a precarious position but it will be
able to jump out so three different
options here I don't think there is a
fourth you either trade Queens on B3 or
you protect your queen with Rook B8 or
Pawn to A5 but an each down to eight
minutes and it's 31 moves have been
played so he has nine moves to make to
reach time control and they're not easy
moves just because the Queens come off
the board doesn't mean that suddenly the
game is simple
I was opening my mouth to say exactly
that it's I think simpler in comparison
to the middle game I think the margin of
error is a little bit wider in the sense
that black has more suitable candidate
moves as an each does indeed decide uh
to play a No-Frills move he takes the
queen on B3 so he can definitely breathe
a sigh of relief here but that doesn't
mean he can do whatever he wants and
he's not risking I mean you could easily
Envision a scenario where whites Rook
infiltrates the seventh rank the check
on F6 remains pretty spicy as you put it
anishkiri still has to figure out
suitable arrangements for the night and
you definitely don't want to rush Knight
D3 or if you play it you're gonna have
to find a proper response Against The
Rook infiltration to D7 so let's not
pretend that Anish giri doesn't have uh
work left he has plenty of work left to
do he needs to make it to the time
control in one piece and if Jordan wins
this game then his time management will
be a big reason why he has left himself
with right about half an hour to figure
out the intricacies of this end game as
we pull up and remind everybody of the
time control eight moves Robert sounds
like an eternity here with only eight
minutes on the clock yes uh not going to
be easy for Anish he is working really
hard right now and as we're noted you
started with a hundred minutes for 40
moves then you have 50 minutes to reach
move 60 and then finally you get 15
minutes for the rest of the game there
is that 30 second bonus every movie you
make when you press the clock you have
30 seconds added uh that may sound like
a good amount it does add up to a few
minutes but when this position is so
complex it may not be enough for a niche
if he is trying to win this game at this
point and that's the tricky part Donya
is Anish he has remained as objective as
possible but you kind of look at this
position you say now that I'm not
getting checkmated maybe I should try to
win but you need to continue just being
calm and composed and one idea that I
have is A5 for black we mentioned it
before the queen trade A5 right now
trying to throw that pawn down to A4 and
I feel like if white doesn't act quickly
that Knight on B2 Will Survive and the
white Bishop it wants to keep in contact
with F7 which is ultra well defended
here and I just feel like if certain
trades happen Jordan will need to be
careful he might get a second Pawn have
a knight and two pawns for The Rook but
that doesn't mean it's just a simple
draw because of the G2 Pawn that's very
weak here and it's a backward Pawn that
a rook is staring at
definitely the idea of just sliding King
over to h8 and doubling Brooks is on the
table so to summarize I think
objectively Jordan maintains probably a
slight advantage on the board but more
importantly uh compound that with his
advantage on the clock and the fact that
I still think White's position is easier
to play at this point with pretty clear
well-defined ideas of infiltrating to D7
and delivering a night night check to F6
I would not be surprised if Anish Gary
goes wrong in the next couple of moves
and he is not hurrying he's down to six
and a half minutes Roberts we've been
outlining Black's ideas is time
situation has become even more
disturbing
huge time travel for Anish Geary and you
are correct I certainly stand with you
on this it is easier for white to play
that doesn't mean white is necessarily
better from the objective evaluation but
a niche could go wrong as you mentioned
Knight D3 very tempting let's save our
Knight The Rook slides the D1 you can't
protect your knight because you walk
into a pin if you try to go Rook d8
that's bad you're going to lose uh right
away down the D file and if you move the
Knight out the way Rook D7 is you're
highlighting that's a huge problem F7 is
put under pressure C7 the A7 Pawn behind
it so a niche needs to find a move right
now I think A5 is that move he wants to
get rid of that Bishop from B3 so he's
going to almost pre-move A5 to A4 no
matter what Jordan does
that is a lovely idea but it takes
nerves of Steel to push that pawn with
your knight sitting as perilously as it
is on B2 but uh your earlier point is
well taken Anish has to realize that the
Knight isn't actually in any mortal
danger it's got that pathway back to D3
Anish decides to take care of his King
side sliding the king over to h a you
seem surprised by this decision well I
was wondering how that Knight gets away
because Rook to B1 the Knight has only
one safe square that is very oh my gosh
yeah so what's happening here so if we
can analyze for a second uh The Rook
comes the B1 the Knight has to go to D3
only safe score and Bishop C4 where is
that Knight going all of the squares are
under White's control which means you're
going to lose your knight if you don't
do something F5 is that something to
kick the Knight out of the center but
the Knight then hops into G5 trying to
go into E6 and I feel like there's a
fork somewhere but the eval bar staying
center it's saying that oh my gosh
look at this line Knight takes E5 still
not over Rook B5 pushing the Knight away
but black has yet another counter attack
it's like no matter where the Knight
lands it's gonna get pushed around it
was on e4 black had one pawn pawn push
now the pawn pushes to H6 and of course
all of this is made possible by uh the
king Retreat to h8 if you move the
Knight away and black finally solves his
Knight problems with Knight E4 here
Jordan would essentially have to bail
out with a check on F7 and if gear would
presumably take and at this point I
think the Rook end game is well no I
mean the evil bar seems to believe that
this is not the right call for black I
guess the reason is that Black's Queen
side pawns are suddenly sitting docks
and the F Pawn is isolated so Anish
would probably have to leave his Knight
on the board but after 94 with accurate
play he should be able to pull out half
a point but even this line Robert
doesn't look all that easy to play and
this is far from Jordan's only option he
can chase the Knight away he can do it a
little bit differently by playing Rook
seat to and try eventually to stake that
Rook on D7 but I'll just finish by
saying that you need to play Rook D7
with a serious amount of caution because
it could actually backfire if black
pushes the pawn out to F5 the last thing
you want to do with white uh in most
circumstances is trade Rooks if you
trade Rooks the minor pieces do not have
that glue piece to bring them together
you need to keep your Rook as the kind
of supervisor of White's position I
think you just showed that because the
evaluation will change a Black's favor
so a rook B1 Roxy 2 Knight D3 Rook C2
yeah yeah two night before and if you
play Rook D7 after F5 black is suddenly
just winning yeah this is uh clear The
Rook trade is terrible for white you can
no longer uh attack black and then
Black's Rook is free to start dominating
the board so you do not want to trade
Rooks in most circumstances as Donya
just said if you are Jordan Von Forest
yeah and the the exceptions to the rule
are if you can immediately win back the
exchange or if you can get the C7 Pawn
then uh you know the situation
complicates but King h8 I think is a
viable move I I really liked your A5
idea but I think Anish Gary is holding
the fort but he's not really holding the
fort on the clock and Jordan has to find
a way to keep the situation complicated
play on the board and play on the clock
but don't fall into the temptation of
setting superficial traps and each Geary
is a phenomenal Blitz player he is not
going to fall for obvious traps you have
to try to maintain your objectivity and
take your time use your time Advantage
wisely and don't start playing a bullet
game
I just is a hectic position it looks
like it should be simpler to play it is
not uh it is just a situation where
Jordan had the upper hand early Anish
he's shown that he is a cable Defender
he play Jordan plays Rook B1 so he
attacks the Knight the Knight dropping
to D3 seems fairly obvious but and he's
spending some seconds here and does
bring the Knight back and we'll see how
quickly Jordan makes this move that's
the big question at this point Donya is
does Jordan have the follow-up worked
out because with black able to strike
with F7 to F5 uh one more thing I want
to show is let's say you play Bishop C4
and after F5
if you think that you're just gonna take
the Knight and we're gonna have a night
trade this is exactly what you don't
want from White's perspective because
Bishop takes D3 upon takes E4 Bishop
takes E4 but but but I win a second Pawn
Robert you do win a second Pawn uh The
Rook can slide to the E file and go
after the E3 pawn and it's kind of a
mess because the white Brook will slam
on B7 and go after the queen side as
well so it's kind of a mixed bag where
white is holding on to the pawn
structure for the moment and can go
after Black's pawns but two pawns to the
good at least temporarily would white be
for the exchange it's an option and
there's a crucial tactical detail Rook
FEA does not in fact win the E3 Pawn
because of Bishop C6 and white will have
the one tempo that he needs in order to
secure that pawn by pushing it to E4 so
definitely not a given that a pawn is a
worthy price to pay for black to take
the knights off the board although this
position I think is easier to play on
each we'll be able to make a couple of
moves quickly and get himself closer to
time control but as you said a critical
moment here decisions to be made for
Jordan will he slide his Rook to D1 will
he opt for Bishop C4 he's got 23 minutes
to make that call
Let's uh zoom out for a second we have
given this game our focus it is such a
big impact on the tournament standings
but if we look across all seven games
are still going uh
crazy the fighting spirit that these
players are showing this late in the
tournament they may be exhausted but
they're still going to fight and look at
how crazy some of the positions are I
first want to give a shout out to
gookesh who is up a pawn in a rook end
game against Levon aronian so kukesh has
some witty chances the overhead games
are drawn so they say and this one does
look like one where Lavon has good
chances to hold no but
yeah no I was about to say the Magnus
game is wild the parhamaksudu gave its
origin eriggaisi is wow berserk so let's
go to Magnus versus probably Nanda
because the last few moves have been
really important it's the dynamic has
changed where pragnanda was passive he
was worse now all of a sudden he has the
activity and
look at this the last moves played Dania
if we just go back a few
black finally he was able to strike with
the move d4 and then the Rook slid up to
E4 afterwards not moving the Knight
because E5 would have fallen and black
would have been with a check with check
and with a bad situation so he goes
rookie four attacking the pawn after d
takes C3 the Knight is gone but the
bishop is gone as well and now it's up
to prognan who has five minutes to make
six moves it's only move 34. oh not easy
this is really not easy for the
youngster
and the automatic move may seem to be
Rook takes Pawn but there's also a very
enterprising possibility you can push
the pawn down to CT you can give the
Rook up a check because white has such a
hard time stopping that I can't stop the
pawn uh unless he is willing to part
ways with his Rook Magnus will probably
bring his Rook back to E1 uh and then
maybe Pratt can hunt for some sort of a
Perpetual with Queen F2 but that is hard
to calculate I feel like practically
Rook takes E5 might be the easier move
to handle magnus's idea in response
might be to push the pawn up to B4 and
try to force the queen to lose contact
with the Rook that is a terrifying
position to play in time pressure and if
the queen leaves C5 then white will have
an additional check on C8 which may
enable Magnus to snap off this pesky
incredibly annoying Pawn on C3 four
minutes now for prognan to Robert the
position is objectively drawn we are
aware of that but imagine having four
minutes here for six moves against none
other than Magnus Carlson we're about to
see a move here we go chess is
objectively a draw if you find all the
best moves but that's the hard part is
finding the correct choices look at
prognanda he's putting his hand he's
ready to reach is he going to push the
pawn you saw him glance at the clock he
now looks up at Magnus Carlson he wants
the move but isn't certain how could he
be he can't see 20 moves down the line
and that sometimes Is What It Takes
because if you give a rook for example
with the move C2 the White Queen will
snag The Rook with Chuck the white Pawn
can go up to E6 he's played it he played
it it's a brave Choice by a very
talented teenager from India and he has
recognized that the white king is too
exposed so black will be able to survive
in many of these variations
what what a Fearless brilliant move by
pragnananda giving up a rook with shek
and I don't know if we should pull up an
announcement board but presumably Magnus
is going to take a little bit of time
he's probably gonna take that Rook
almost instantly because obviously white
has no other options but the key thing
that Prague had to see as Magnus indeed
takes the rook and Prague immediately
slides the skin up to G7 this is the
live position there's the move E6 Robert
and if you just blindly promote your
queen well actually no this is also a
draw I was assuming that white had
Checkmate here but he doesn't after F7
King h8 all that white can do is
alternate checks on E8 and F7 and force
the Perpetual but apart from that black
I think can actually try to win the game
by giving that intermediate check on C7
so Prague would be spoiled for choice in
this situation this Magnus have to opt
for this line or can he try to extend
the game by bringing his Rook back to E1
and what happens here
yeah he can't play rookie one he could
also play B4 so uh he could attack the
black queen first before playing rookie
one but after rookie one I guess black
has to promote or is there something
well actually if you promote you might
lose
queen queen yeah because you're pumped
down
Queen after the sick I just want to show
quickly that if you promote to instead
of Queen F2 which is just nasty you take
the queen
and then after Queen takes someone hit
E6 I think E6 is winning for white
because Queen F4 check is not a
Perpetual white were push the pawn to
G3 I assume because otherwise yeah
repetition and after Queen takes F3 you
okay well this there's no you're running
out of checks very quickly but Queen F3
this queen takes F7 check let's not
forget that white is up a Pawn on the
queen side over there it's a winning
King opponent
it is Queen takes F7 you have to keep
the material count in mind and this is
an elementary Moon white will bring the
king up to G4 and then use his Pawn
majority to distract Black's King from
the Queen's end just eat up those
vulnerable pawns but if we rewind as far
down the line as Rook takes C1
uh well no this is already lost for some
reason I hallucinated the queen was on
C4 in which case black would have an
intermediate check on F4 but Prague you
should avoid that with a 10-foot pole
and instead you called this a sick move
a sick move it is because you're just
playing down a rook and the key detail
is that if white plays E6 white actually
loses the game because of the
intermediate check on H4 forcing the
king down to G1 and not only do you take
the Rook with Chuck no you come bobbing
for apples one more time you bring the
queen back up to H4 and then you play C1
equals queen or Rook with a Checkmate so
after Queen F2 I think Magnus would have
had would have to move his Rook to the
side where does he move it well after
Rook C1 as after any other Rook move I
think black enforcer Perpetual Queen H4
check Queen D4 check and if white goes
panning for gold with Queen F King F1
he apparently actually loses the game do
you see why
do you want uh oh check
oh my God again you're in The Rook
you win the rook and then you come back
to F4 and pave the way or the other
Queen so suddenly become almost a three
result game Magnus could lose this if he
overpresses
that would be something that would be
unbelievable and it'll be a huge career
to finding win perhaps for prognando
after showing tenacious defense and I've
been wondering if I throw in the pawn to
B4 for white just to kick that Queen
away from C5
where does the queen go it's not an easy
question to answer because if you just
nonchalantly move to the wrong Square
you probably rude this game
I'm just going to use that exact same
word and describing describing the
decision if you're nonchalantly move the
queen F2 don't forget about our old
friend E6 could come with devastating
effect
I mean Prague he's one or two moves away
from holding the draw here I think you
have to stay behind the past Pawn
because if you move your queen away the
White Queen would slide behind it so
Queen C7 does make perfect sense to me
but after Queen C7 we I think we have
the same variations earlier rookie one
but you don't have Queen F2 what you do
have is Queen C4 same idea oh my gosh
that's just nuts you're going Queen H4
check and just trying to but okay why
play G3 can you throw that move in to
stop your only judge this line never
ends and then you just have to I think
you just have to play chess here with
like Queen D3 no that's not the move E6
oh and the King always has this Escape
Square on H3 oh my gosh this position is
so complicated
degree of difficulty off the charts in
finding all of these moves for black
Magnus definitely should play B4 here
that is such a Magnus move posing black
with a dilemma and only four minutes on
the clock if Prague turns this around
and Magnus blunders what will be crazy
is that Prague will join Anish giri in
terms of beating the world number two
and world number one in the same event
because he did defeat Anish uh dingley
Ren at the start of this tournament but
I think that is a very unlikely outcome
I think Magnus will keep his composure
but for now B4 will confront black with
a very unenviable dilemma in which you
have to stay accurate and find the right
retreating score for the queen
now before it's just one of those moves
that catches you off guard because you
have to calculated rookie one you'd be
calculating E6 and then a wrench a
curveball is thrown with B4 just hitting
the queen where it sits and your
previous idea of the queen F2 no longer
work Queen C7 or queen C3 which is more
accurate uh both have some clear
drawbacks but it seems according to the
evaluation bar off the side that it is a
hold prognanda should be able to survive
this game here but you have to pick the
right Square
and it does appear that the simplest
draw is Queen to C3 the point is to
deprive the white Rook of the E1 Square
so after B4 Queen C3 we don't have to
analyze this specifically I think white
will have to resort uh to a move like
Queen E7 loading up well no white
doesn't even have Perpetual in that
position but what complicates The
Narrative is that even after black
promotes he doesn't actually have a a
check with either of his Queens Queen B4
is on the board wow this is a big moment
for Prague Nanda because if we just
continue thinking about these variations
E6 is going to be powerful so if you
play Queen to C7 uh right away or that
seems so natural just making sure the
pawn can't move the Rook slides back to
E1 we were talking about that white
would be a pawn ahead in most of these
positions if you slide up to C3 to stop
The Rook from going to E1 that allows to
move E6 to be played and I just want to
show variation very quickly because I
think the action doesn't conclude when
black gets a second Queen so let's say
it's crazy they just played it was
played okay so Queen C3 E6
okay I think black has to throw in Queen
C7 check otherwise the king is in big
trouble
yes
F4 block the check with your Pawn C1
equals Queen and then E7 now Queen f8
check is a threat to get a new Queen the
black king is oh my God and I think
black has to take on F4 give back a
queen and then find a Perpetual check
which should be there because the white
king is wide open
when you notate this you have to say
queen 7 takes F4 check how often have is
that been written on any score sheet in
chess history the reason is because you
have two queens and both of them are on
the same file so Queen C takes F4 would
actually be ambiguous you have to
indicate the rank that the queen is on
uh according to the rules of notation
and after Rook takes F4 the story
doesn't end here King H3 well obviously
that gets checkmated with Queen H4
Magnus could try to make a Mad Dash for
the other side of the board and Robert
you'll co-sign me on this sometimes the
Perpetual isn't as easy to achieve as it
appears but this is pretty simple
because White's Queen is it it plays no
part in helping the king Escape it's
blocked by its own epon I think the most
accurate move is Queen C1 checking
laterally in order to prevent the white
king from reaching the queen side King
F3 Queen D3 yeah this is just a dead
draw and I think the game is very likely
to end precisely in this way and so
Prague he will just need to find one
more idea Queen takes F4 check is
something he has to see when he delivers
that intermediate check on C7
wow and the King may go run around the
board but we'll see if the king actually
can't escape or black just has a draw so
let's zoom out of this one because it to
my eyes it looks like the game between
Wesley so and our leader Rebecca and it
seems that for Wesley for nordierbeck
he's across the land they have Knight
Bishop Rook four pawns per side opposite
color Bishops so I think that that game
will conclude in the very near future oh
my gosh but look at a bottom right uh to
the to the left of Carlson Prague which
is crazy in its own right there are two
Queens on the board in another game
bachamax Zulu has just captured Arjun
aragaisy's Rook on E8 and made a second
Queen both of those Queens are hanging
this is unbelievable and it's a shame
that we haven't really had as much of a
chance to look at that game obviously we
need to cover the tournament leaders and
the games that impact the tournament
standings but what a crazy tactical
Affair in that grunfeld game as well
foreign
and that position is only just getting
started look Wesley so he makes his move
Pawn up to F4 and wouldn't be surprised
if that's he's going to find no dear
back and back do you wanna just make a
draw you want to get out of here uh this
position is completely even so as we
look at the last move it's the first
time in a while that Wesley's pieces can
breathe they were stuck now the Knight
is centralized on D4 rather than at home
on B1 he pushes the pawn to F4 and
yeah I feel like this game is completely
level
and as has been the case really for the
past 15 moves or so black is
symbolically better you could look at
the position and say well Black's pieces
are more active unfortunately active
pieces do not win games and the reason I
think this game is going to end very
shortly is just because white has no
targets first of all blackened and the
game immediately just by taking on
passant and then trading Knights uh and
then the Rooks will probably come off
pretty soon after that but if black
actually moves the Knight away he will
be playing with a little bit of fire
because then the bishop could come out
to C4 there's a night check on C6 that
could be really nasty I don't think
Notre back should do anything crazy
especially given the fact that he leads
the tournament I'll bet a silver dollar
that we see e takes F3 Wesley recaptures
either with a pawn or with the Knight
and we're probably gonna get a peaceful
result here in the next couple moves
yeah he takes F3 is the type of move
that you just respond to with Knight
takes F3 you swap those Knights off the
world which is forced I might add
because after the Knight temperatures
back on F3 the H4 Pawn is under attack
and we see no dear sitarov on screen he
has been leading this tournament uh from
start and we're about to be at the
finish this is the penultimate round and
if he draws this game and Anish Gary
does not win then no deerback will still
be in clear first heading into
tomorrow's final round yes alpassant is
allowed uh that was just played by Abu
sitarov and I thank Donya as soon as
Wesley takes a seat they will shake
hands and agree for a draw
I completely agree we'll stay on this
game for a bit now what's amazing is
that we outlined the cards that have to
fall a certain way for Notre back to
clinch first place after the penultimate
round after today and just about an hour
ago some of those uh cards seem to be
falling exactly that way Jordan van
forest was well on the way to defeating
the second uh Place Anish giri and now
prognananda is oh so close to holding
Magnus Carlson to a draw and I think
there was one other result that had to
happen a certain way but I forget which
one it is
foreign
sorry repeat that
in order for motorbike to clinch first
place with a draw against Wesley so
there's a couple of things that have to
happen in a certain way no tournament
Forest used to be very likely to beat
Gary yeah but it's impossible yeah
exactly so we see here that noribbeck
excuse me he needs to beat Wesley and
since he's not going to do that it means
that tomorrow everyone I mean the people
who are chasing him still have a chance
what a scrubby couldn't even do that I
mean Jordan van forest was very close to
doing his part now all of that has been
thrown into chaos ragnananda is going to
do his part notarbeck couldn't even
defeat Wesley with the black pieces in
an end game and I just it feels like a
draw for is about to be made he's
looking at a scoresheet in a way that
indicates that the game is about to come
to a close I think he signs even without
Wesley's permission he's just like half
half side here now you signed it he
doesn't have to offer the draw uh
because these top players they know on
the draws deer and in this case there is
no life left in the position I'm very
critical historically on draw offers not
in this type of position when it's clear
that it's going to be Bishops of
opposite color with a rook in three
pawns each that means that it's just a
completely level game and so for
abusatara he wasn't in trouble today
Daniel he wasn't pressed he probably
wasn't stressed but he has impressed all
of us because he continues to lead this
event and he is just a teenager and this
field is super strong yep and we can see
there neuterberg looking up at his
opponent I think he's just offered a
draw we are going to get a handshake
here and there we go our first result of
the day is a draw as the tournament
leader holds Wesley so to a draw he's
drawn both of his games with the black
bases against Gary and against Wesley
from a position of strength so so
impressive and as they sign the score
sheets we have to go back to the Magnus
game because we've got some crazy
developments there
has two Queens on the board and the
situation continues to get more and more
complicated as we have two moves two
crucial moves until the time control
Robert
whoa how did that pawn get up on F5
What's Happening Here the black king
despite blocking up material it has an
extra Queen
how did this happen can we can we just
go back
so oh my gosh Magnus played F4 what a
crazy move wow and it Queen was made on
C1 and then you went F5 F5
that's unbelievable stuff
crazy he's just playing positionally and
he's threatening F6 check with an
obvious Checkmate so Prague has to
immediately evacuate his Queen back to
C7 to cover the F7 Pawn Magnus delivers
the check on F6 no this is gonna be a
draw this is the pro and what an idea by
Prague after Queen f8 Robert it looks
like Checkmate is Unstoppable on G7 but
probably saw this and he sacrifices his
Queen on E5 and the idea as he has just
indicated is to allow his other Queen to
deliver a check on F4 and he has
calculated this out to withdraw and he's
cutting it incredibly close it looks
like white can escape with King G1 and
black does not have the time to take the
Rook but he does not need to take the
rug does he
No in fact after King G1 if you take the
Rook you get checkmated in one move so
instead of taking the Rook after King to
G1 you bet Queen D4 check or queen C1
check uh I'm not sure if there's a
difference but the King goes to F2 the
queen goes right back to F4 and wow has
to run to the center with King E2 and
the queen takes E5 will be check but
Magnus wins these types of positions
even though yes he does the bar saying
white is the teeniest bit better nothing
really there he'll run his King to D3
and after Queen takes F6 he'll try to
say I have an outside pass Pawn
potential with my A3 and B4 pawns and
the black king stuck in place
perhaps Magnus can squeeze a victory out
of this position that would be
ridiculous
that would be the craziest ending to a
game I've ever seen such Brilliance
defensive ruins from Prague only to find
himself staring down the barrel of a
nasty end game against the greatest end
game player of all time he wants to
avoid this if he can and my question uh
is does is there any way to refrain from
taking the road is there a case to be
made for Queen C4 no there is not
because I guess the king is able to inch
its way to the queen side with King D2
and King C2 so I unfortunately for
Prague think he has to accept this end
game and he will still have quite a bit
of work to do obviously that end game is
drawn black should be able to deliver
Perpetual maybe snap off one of White's
kingside pawns but you would want to
finish this game with a Perpetual if you
can you definitely do not want a couple
more hours of Defending a queen end game
against Magnus no you do not and Magnus
will make prognanda work for it he did
that against Wesley so even though the
result was never really in doubt so for
Prague Nana the first bunch of this game
would move around 42. he has played a
great game thus far he was in trouble he
found some great ideas like a pawn
sacrifice with Queen C7 earlier and then
found this second Queen and then a queen
sacrifice to get these checks in but the
game is not over so you can't just uh
count your chickens before they hatch so
they say and let's go away from this
game as we know what's gonna happen in
the next bunch of moves let's go into
the game between Anish Geary and Jordan
Von Forest because in that one
Anish has seen the worst behind him but
the game is far from over with past
pawns running up the board
yeah we just every time we we seem to
get a little bit of clarity in this game
it it becomes in in a certain sense even
more complicated well the knights are
off we forecasted a scenario like that
I'm actually still counting the pawns
yeah so white still has a pawn for the
exchange but more disturbingly for Anish
iri there's that pawn on F5 it's inching
forward to F6 and it is supported by its
two Neighbors on E3 and on G4 but the
one piece of great news for Anish gear
is that he has made move 40 and now has
an additional 50 minutes to concentrate
on finishing off this incredibly
impressive defensive task and let's not
count on a win for either side this is a
three results position and the reason
why is black has it passed a pawn I
don't know how he was able to accomplish
that but that pawn goes up pretty
quickly A5 A4 A3 and so on and for white
you have this Pawn on F5 that is a
really useful part especially if you get
your e-pawn up the board as well the
white King get slapped up to F4 at some
moment so it is a rook for Bishop in one
Pawn but that pawn on F5 is a really
powerful one
it is indeed and Jordan man Forest he is
gonna have to need every bit of the hour
that he has just received to navigate
the intricacies of this end game I think
we're in for the Long Haul in this game
but not in Carolina we have a second
result that game has ended peacefully as
well very impressive opening preparation
by Vincent and then accurate middle Game
Play Holding Fabiano caruana to a very
confident draw in an opening in which
Fabiana karon is one of the world's
leading Specialists very impressive
Vincent kymer coming up with an opening
surprise he draws that game with the
black pieces so two games down two draws
in the books but the positions have been
fighting these are not uh just let's
just be peaceful let's agree for a draw
they have given it their all and the
five games remaining are still electric
we haven't looked at this game in a very
long time it's the one between Parham
magsudlu and Arjun eragisi not neither
player making a leap towards the
absolute top of the standings they're
not fighting for first place but that
probably wasn't even their expectation
coming in Barb wasn't supposed to be
here he was the last second in the T and
he has a few minutes on the clock both
players to make it to move 40 and what
is this position the bar is Sky High
because the black kid was in trouble and
whites up material and Black's Pawn is
just not fast enough I mean this this
obviously is reminiscent of the Magnus
game and that black is trying to make
two queens again he already had two
queens
but I was gonna say Fabiana Parham
captured one of them but now white has
just enough time to generate Unstoppable
threats against black skin I think
that's why this is winning objectively
white probably should give a check on H4
Force blacks King onto a more vulnerable
spot and then try to navigate the queen
over to uh the most Prime piece of real
estate the E6 Square what that will do
is not only Force the king back to the H
file where the Rook can finish it off
with a check on H4 but also if you can
imagine uh it will prevent black from
playing B2 because Rook H4 would be a
discovered check but oh all right I'm a
D7 oh he also is good we want Queen F7
he wants to take away the king's Escape
square and play Rook H4 Checkmate oh
yeah Queen F7 is devastating and then or
Arjun has to try to generate threats
against White's King but how he can give
one check and the King steps up to G2
and
Arjun will have to start throwing pieces
at the king but that cannot possibly
succeed wait a second though let's show
that line quickly because King G2
after Queen A1 check
you don't want to go to H2 because Queen
E5 check would have been there but
Bishop H3 check and if you take on H3
that would be a mistake because Queen H1
and after King G3 you can go B2 probably
you have the H file covered you'll give
up your call and get a new one
I was too dismissive indeed Rook H4
check the sting has been taken out of it
and black is fine what does that mean
that means that after Bishop takes H3
does white have to sidestep the bishop
with King H2
yes and what a move it is because of
their King H2 there's only one check
Queen E5 check but now you no longer
have a check on the last rank as you're
showing The Bishop's pin and King takes
H3 is played and there's not another
check because Queen H5 there's Rook H4
pinning and winning the queen and the B
Pawn is one square short if that pawn
was on B2 you'd sacrifice your queen get
a new one but the opponent's on B3 so
white wins the first queen and you're
not getting a second
black has to resort to Queen F5 check
here and obviously after the trade white
has ample time to stop the further
progress of LAX pawns Barham will have
to work for it for another couple of
moves here but anything wins Rook C7
Rook B7 just don't bring your Bishop
back to A3 because B2 will force white
to give that Bishop away uh Hey five
Fawn actually prevents Rook before but
after Rook C7 I think Arjun is going to
resign what incredible nerves of Steel
D7 and queen F7 giving up the pride of
his position in order to generate a key
Square for his Queen and guess what
Barham had to have seen King to H2 when
he played the move D7 and I think we're
gonna the game is gonna end precisely in
this way okay so as we refresh the live
board we see that uh some a check has
been given King G2 looks to be the main
option here and the players they're
nearing move 40 but the position the
sequence here is relatively forced if
the black pieces don't check the white
king Rook H4 will be decisive so that
sequence with King G2 Bishop takes H3
check I think it's just a force loss
right we just look down the line uh
White is going to be up over Rook the
past pawns are not quick enough so it
should be another victory for magsudu
but we'll see if he's able to manage
that for now because most these games
have reached move 40 and this one is
about to do the same we are going to
take a break and when return It's the
final stretch the home stretch of round
12 here the penultimate round of the
2023 Tata steel Chess Masters we will be
right back
[Music]
struggling to improve your game
chessable is the home for chess
improvers with hundreds of courses by
incredible authors like world champion
Magnus Carlson Christoph selecki and
Josh Toth everyone's favorite social
media troll known as Anish Geary and so
many more chessable can help you raise
your game to the next level
most importantly all of our courses are
powered by chessable's exclusive move
Trader technology which uses the science
of space repetition to make sure it all
sticks
check out chessable today and get 30
days of pro for free go to chessable.com
begin
[Music]
foreign
to the playing Hall in Vikings a on the
screen we have pragnananda who has the
black pieces against Magnus Carlson the
world champion programa has been a
steady Force against Magnus in the
Champions chess store in the online
rapid tournaments here in classical
chess this would be his second game in
their history and it'll be his first
draw if he is able to hold it but Dania
the result it's not in the bag just yet
we know how Magnus Carlson works at
endgame magic he makes his opponents
sweat until the result is agreed upon he
is demonically resilient he always finds
a way to extend the game keep your legs
churning force your opponent to keep
working even in situations where it
appears that a draw is a bygone
conclusion and we will delve into the
end game that Carlson and Prague will
contest for presumably the next hour
maybe even more because there is no
Perpetual in sight and Magnus Carlson
has managed to create a situation in
which his young opponent still has work
to do in order to score half a point
Robert there is a psychological
component to this as well I think Prague
just a couple of moves ago was already
felt that Perpetual was in his pocket
that the draw was right there for the
taking and all of a sudden White's King
has made its way into the center there's
no Perpetual to speak of the King has
way too many directions in which it can
run and as you plan it out a fight wins
this game it will be because Magnus has
a clear plan of creating a past Pawn on
the queen side
a problem though for Magnus is if he
does in fact go and try to create a pass
on the queen side then G2 Pawn is tender
and the G5 Pawn can start pushing so
black is trying to do the same thing
that white is
take a pawn that is preventing your
pawns from getting the other side and
then use your queen to support it so I
feel like prognanda he's doing this
perfectly well uh he has played a great
defensive game but Magnus he will
exhaust all options before relinquishing
that half point
obviously Prague has to avoid a queen
trade like the plague because this king
is way too far away from the queen side
and I think he shouldn't procrastinate I
think he should play the move King to G7
because the issue with grabbing the G2
Pawn prematurely is that white will not
only take on F7 with a check but then
slide the queen to F6 and then to G6 and
then take the H6 Pawn with check that's
totally out of the question so I think
if you're Prague you need to give the
Queen the freedom that it needs in order
to handle the situation on the queen
side and pose the the threat of Queen F1
forcing Magnus to essentially adopt a
defensive posture and delay the progress
of uh the queen side pawns and there was
a question if Magnus helped pregnant
reach time Patrol uh they had a
repetition but that was after the time
control so no move 40 is when the
players got more time the little
repetition happened or I move 41 and
thus the players already had an
additional excuse me 50 minutes on the
clock so this end game it is going to be
a long battle between these two magnets
will do everything he can to try to win
but prognanda he's resilient I think he
will continue to stop Magnus from making
any progress there are no real inroads
to make unless you can quickly get A4
and B5 but the black queen will give
many many checks yeah there's just too
much air space uh in the center of the
word too many directions and avenues too
much stuff to keep track of for white so
unless Prague blunders into a queen
trade or he somehow allows some sort of
Ideal construction and during the break
I was thinking of what that might look
like perhaps you know Queen on E2 and
then White's King in relative safety on
B3 if magnets can achieve all of that
then he'll start pushing his spawn and
that still won't signify the end of the
game even if he manages to create a pass
Pawn on the queen side who's to say that
he will have the Firepower to keep that
past Bond going in order to do so the
queen will have to leave its defensive
posture opening up the possibility of
yet another uh Perpetual so with plenty
of time on the clock no question that
Prague should be able to hold the draw
but should and Will are two very
different things and how many times have
we seen Magnus pull out some magic in
situations like this
too many times if you are thinking about
From prognan's perspective but likely
not this time because Prague is that
strong and let's go to a game that I
believe is going to finish soon we last
left off when they're about to reach
move 40. uh they have made time Patrol
and you know where I was going
to Arjun ERA garci this has not been
Origins tournament if we just scroll
back for a quick second before we get to
the live position everything that we
said might happen did in fact happen the
bishop had to take on H3 check a couple
moves ago but when the king sidestepped
to H2 black has to give checks because
Rook H4 would be Checkmate and after
Queen E5 only then was the bishop
captured and after Queen trade Dania
it's just not going to get the job done
the a pawn is not far enough to help the
b-pawn so look at Rook C7 then Rook B7
the bishop on A3 the pawns are stopped
in place this is a easily winning
position for paramaksudu he's going to
get to an even score Daniel this is been
in incredible term for him he has been
fighting remember his game against
Fabiano caruana where he was pressing
and then he almost lost because he
overpressed I mean the guy has been
giving it his all
and his games have been so fun to watch
whether he's won them or lost them yes
not all games in this tournament have
gone Arkham's way he lost an absolute
Heartbreaker to go cash a game that he
was oh so close to winning he lost an
end game to Magnus Carlson that he was
hoping to hold there have been some
disappointing results but there have
also been some sparkling games
yesterday's game against Prague was
fantastic I mean it was a crushing
Victory with the black pieces and now
defeating Arjun aragaisi in a superb
tactical display he eliminates the pawn
and A5 I think we're gonna get
resignation after Parham slides The Rook
over to B5 eliminating the final Wing
Side Pawn what a performance what
incredible resilience what tactical
Spirit demonstrated by Parham we have a
handshake and we have another win for
the Iranian Grandmaster
and we see that the players immediately
discussing the game they'll go analyze
and a big win for Parham maxulu he takes
on Arjun aragaisi and Arjun has had a
very disappointing tournament I mean he
holds himself to a high standard he is a
phenomenal Force he's also an
exceptionally kind human being but when
you're playing the best of the best
sometimes these results happen he has
lost four games in this tournament he
has not won a single game and he's drawn
the rest so it's been uh rating points
down the drain for him he's not too
worried about that he'll get them back
but it just hasn't been the type of
tournament he would have hoped for no it
has not and eventually everybody's gonna
have a bad tournament Arjun is writing
an unbelievable streak he has
skyrocketed to 27-22 his current rating
he's obviously going to lose quite a bit
of it after this tournament concludes
but how different his tournament Arc has
been from last year where he didn't just
win the Challenger section and the
winner of The Challengers of course gets
an automatic bid to the Masters the
following year he tore through it he
went on a rampage he won it with a
monster score we talked about Arjun not
winning a certain a single game this
tournament well last year I don't think
he lost uh a single game and he barely
had any draws it was an amazing
performance but this is just a little
bit harder Robert just a bit
level of competition only goes up from
the challengers to the Masters and
speaking of the challengers I mean that
servant is taking place right now you
see in the playing Hall uh there are
many people still fighting for their
points in the open tournaments this is a
true chess festival and so the
challengers the winner of that event
moves on to the Masters in the following
year that's what happened with our
generic geisie and we'll see who is next
uh but wow as we look at the cross the
border dingly rent in big trouble
against Rich report where are his Rooks
where is his Rook
uh I don't know we haven't looked at the
game in a very long time
now that's crazy because I was I was
stealing some glances at that game I
mean the position seemed very complex
but it seemed to be a case of you know
dynamic equality ever since they got
into that end game now I look and black
is an exchange down he's got those two
pawns on the king side but they seem to
be fully restrained by the very active
Knight on F5 and The Rook could
contribute to that effort can we uh
steal a a closer look at that game to
see if in fact the game is as one-sided
as it appears
I think it is I didn't sound like much
of a rhetorical question I see the eval
bar through the roof and it's pretty
understandable we look at this and white
is up a rook for a bishop and pawn but
unfortunately those doubled apons do not
help Black's cause because white has a
passer on the C file whereas if can you
just grab the pawn on A6 and put it just
literally doing exactly that yeah just
like put that on B7 then you could keep
control of the past pawns that are
moving off the board but with your Pawn
A7 the C Pawn has free reign free grass
to run through it's a playing field and
only one side is happy about that it is
Richard's report so he had a bad first
half of the tournament done yet but he
started winning games and if he takes
out dingley Rand will go to a plus score
against some ready points and dingley
wren's miserable tournament only
continues it does and he's going to lose
his 2800 I I definitely think he's
losing more than 11 points even before
this game this is not going to help his
cause something is just going very very
wrong for the world championship
Challenger we've talked about it
extensively in previous rounds maybe his
his mind is on uh the upcoming World
Championship which will be held in
Austin Kazakhstan uh just a hair over
two months from now maybe it's the fact
that he has to hide his opening
preparation maybe it's something
something else he just doesn't feel too
good it could be a lot of different
things but dingley Wren is on The
Chopping Block this tournament he'll
move to -2 which is absolutely shocking
for the world's number two I think the
simplest way to win here is to bring the
king over to the king side you don't
want the Rook uh you want the Rook to uh
do the winning and do the capturing King
D2 and then King E3 safely restrains
black spawns let alone uh the fact that
H6 is indefensible and can be captured
at any moment I think we're a couple of
moves away from a result in this game
wow and for dingley Wren he is dropped
below 2 800 and I don't want to sound
like uh pessimistic for ding but you
never guaranteed to get back over 2800.
once you uh drop down it's very hard to
climb back up he is such a good player
and he is a very likable person but
something has gone wrong for him in
Viking Zay and it's hard to play a
tournament when you're going to play the
world championship we know that when all
the players talk about it they say we
can't play our best preparation we're
saving it up all of our energy and our
focus in training is for that world
championship match but for daily rent I
mean this is an event that I think he
would like to forget as soon as possible
it most certainly is and he will have to
forget it because you need to go into
the world championship not only feeling
fresh not only armed to the teeth with
opening preparation across the board
with both colors but you need that
confidence you need to know that you
hold the cycle the psychological
confidence Edge over your opponent and
you know how confident janapomdishi is
that is reflected oftentimes in the
speed of his play and just that energy
that he plays with so you know Jan is
coming in itching to avenge his loss in
the previous world championship match
Ken ding put this disappointing
performance behind him well the first
step of course is to try to have a
successful result in the final game he
will have the white pieces and there's
nothing that improves your mood like a
win in the final round but he definitely
will not score a win in the penultimate
round looks like Richard report is well
on his way and King D2 is on the board
and I think Richard report having a
great day today might be bad news for
one Anish giri because if I'm not
mistaken the those two play in the final
round so uh report gets a chance at Gary
Gary needs to score some victories to
win this tournament because no dearbeck
Abdus tariff he seems like he is not
slowing down uh of course we'll talk
more about what the final round has in
store but I think for the storyline it
really is about dingly red more than
anything I don't know the last time uh
he's been the tournament where he's had
such a huge minus score he has lost one
more game than he has won in this
tournament I can't even really remember
games that he has won so let me look
really quickly he oh that's right he won
the first round against kukesh and
otherwise he's lost two games of
prognada and tagiri so his tournament
Arc resembles that of Magnus Carlson
except Magnus managed to turn the ship
around in the second half of the
tournament but ding has just dug himself
further into the hole he will sit after
this loss on 5 out of 12. you mentioned
we don't remember the last time he was
minus two I don't remember the last time
he had a minor score in any tournament
ding is usually the second seed uh or
the first seed if Magnus does not play
and uh definitely a very very
forgettable performance for Our
Generation also as we see or dangly Ren
well I'm trying to figure out if there's
any hope for him it doesn't really look
like it the white king is running
quickly to help out and stop the past
pawns and there's one just little
variation that I feel like uh is not
funny it's not the right word for it but
it's interesting geometry between these
two players so if you put the king uh
sorry black puts upon G3
um and then white plays King E3
if you played Bishop G4 I think white
can just take this Pawn on G3 and then
bring it to F4 no you sort of yes I did
you forked the minor pieces with your
king
but do not under any circumstances play
the move Rook to G1 that would be a
great example of one of those careless
moves that are so easy to make after
Knight F5 check you might still say oh
it's the same thing King F4 Forks the
two minor pieces but no the H1 comes to
the rescue and if you say well I got a
winning Pawn end game after Rook takes
you for no you have a losing pun in game
because the pawn promotes and is
Unstoppable so light needs to exercise
caution until the end but you're right
King F4 ends the game on the spot and if
black does not play the move G3 then
well what else is he going to do white I
think is now ready to take on H6
alternatively he could bring the king to
F2 first ding might simply resign in
this position the likelihood is that
he'll make a couple more moves but no I
think
I think he's gonna resign the way he
looked before was like a person waiting
for his opponent to come back to the
board so he can give up and this
position is hopeless he knows it I'm not
accepting any ifs ands or buts right now
he's going to resign that's my all well
I agree it's just I hate resigning when
my opponent is not at the board I've
done that like once or twice but
normally I wait for him to come back I
hate that process of signing the
scorching when your opponent isn't even
sitting there
but he's doing it he grabbed the pen
that is a player who is about to reside
I agree with you that he'll wait for
Richard to come back uh
from wherever he is but as soon as
Richard comes back I am feeling positive
I would even bet on it not that I'm a
betting man but I would bet on him
resigning here I was taught by my coach
a long time ago that if you are ex if
you are just painfully winning if you're
expecting your opponent to resign uh I
normally try not to get up
um of course it's not a disrespectful
thing to do we know that Richard report
he likes to walk around the tournament
Hall and he's not doing it to rub it in
or to show the extent of his dominance
he just wants to take a glance at the
other games but there he comes do you
want a little coffee he won't need it
because dangly Wren has resigned call
and big win for Richard report there he
goes to six and a half out of 12. uh
that's making his tournament go from one
that didn't look very good because in
the first half of the event he lost to
noribbeck in round one then he lost the
Magnus Carlson in round seven but lately
he's going on a winning spree taking out
prognanda Arjun era geising back-to-back
rounds and here dingley Wren so Richard
report he is back maybe he's just gone
nowhere and we should have believed in
him the whole time but it's nice to see
Richard showing a good result after the
rough start that he had in the first
half it is safe to say that Richard
report will usually have the most
decisive games of anyone in a tournament
I think para maxoodlum report are very
similar in their playing Styles and in
their just unbridled desire to get
fighting positions every single game it
makes him so fun to watch from the first
move until the last as we steal another
glance at our bird's eye view that means
only three games are remaining all of
them are are in different types of end
games but just because there aren't a
lot of pieces on the board doesn't mean
that there isn't chess left to be played
there is a lot of Chess left to be
played in all three games by the way
for sure and these games are not going
to conclude anytime soon I don't think
and we see gukesh up a pawn against
Levon aronian there's no reason why he
shouldn't press forever the A4 pod does
keep the two white pawns at the center a
game on the bottom row there it does
keep the white pawns honest but black is
very active and going to come after the
various pawns Magnus Carlson in the
bottom right he is trying to win this
end game it's queen versus queen four
pawns per side and then up top we have
Jordan Von forest with a bishop in one
Pawn against a rook but that pawn is
very passed so we see a dynamic material
imbalance but Dynamic equality so uh by
the way
Dania with that loss dingley rent has
dropped below young to promise in the
live ratings so it's it's hard to
imagine that just because Dean Lauren
was 28 plus 28 11 I think his rating was
to start the tournament but he's dropped
23 rating points that is that that is
staggering given where he is Jan is
sitting on 27.93 and uh ding's current
live rating after that lost to report is
27.88 not too shabby but given where he
was
that is just a crazy
precipitous Decline and of course ding
you will have a chance to redeem himself
at the world championship but that
cannot feel good for now the world
number three
well another person who has had a big
result is not actually in this
tournament this year but he will be
joining the field a year from now that
player is the winner of The Challengers
tournament that is Alexander donchenko
and you may look at this and say Mustafa
yamas can win his final game and if
doncheco loses their tide the problem
being for yamaz is that dancheco beat
him head to head and in the Challenger
section there is no Blitz playoff if
there is a tie head to head is the first
a tiebreaker and because don't check out
won their headset matchup he moves
through congratulations to the German
Grandmaster we will see you next year in
the Masters Tournament and everybody
else will see you tomorrow in the
challengers final round donchenko is a
very enterprising young player he's been
a grand master for many years now very
he's young but he's experienced and uh
just a huge huge tournament victory
donchenko was close to 2700 about a year
or so ago unfortunately he had a pretty
steep decline he went from 2680 uh to to
something like 25.90 and now again a
resurgent Alexander dechenko win status
deal gains a ton of rating with that
huge plus score and I will be so so
interested to see how he does next year
in the Masters maybe he'll make it back
up to 2700 by that point
well you know need to gain some
experience gain some ready points
congratulations to Alexander donchenko
there he is going to be amongst the
competitors in next year's Master's
tournament with Magnus Carlson and
Company uh so we'll see you in the top
section congratulations and let's go
back to that top section because in each
Geary and Jordan Von Forest very
important game here for the tournament
standings if Geary can win this game
Dania he will be tied with Abdul satara
for first
he will indeed and just you can see his
posture he has serious winning chances
and it's crazy that we're even saying
this it's crazy that the game is still
going on Jordan van forest was one or
two moves away from crashing through on
the king side now the Queens are off the
board and nishikiri is still in exchange
ahead and now he's got a pass Pawn of
his own he says two can play at that
game he's got a past Apon Jordan has a
past F Pawn it's a wild end game and
obviously the evil bar is showing zeros
because what else would it ever show
chess is a draw but man oh man is this
end game crazy but a niche he's falling
into time pressure again they're only on
move 43 three moves removed from the
first time control and anisha's already
spent half of his additional time
allotment on this important decision he
can bring his King up he could start
pushing his past Pawn I feel like
throughout this game Robert black is the
one who's had the more difficult choices
to make and that's part of the reason
why anisha's been taking so much time
time do you play A5 do you play King F6
or maybe you go after the C pawn and try
to get white to play C6 I think that
probably only benefits white but this is
a difficult difficult dilemma for a
niche gearing
I'm just trying to do way who has better
winning chances here because the a pawn
it seems to be a clear Plus for black
that pawn can go through the board
especially if the Rook goes to A1 so
then the question becomes what actually
are White's threats what's White's plan
so let's talk about it if black starts
with the move A5 just pushing your past
Pawn is it the move G5 for white that
way you're threatening the F6 checks so
if we swap pawns and then black says
give me your opponent on E3 it's going
to cost you more than you get because F6
is a fork your rook and king are both in
check and you're gonna lose your Rook
you are indeed now if you don't take on
E3 well how do you stop the threat of F6
you could bring your Rook up to E5 but
then you have to reckon with a very
nasty check on D7 perhaps this position
is still holdable you can bring your
king back to f8 and a very important
detail is that King F6 does not work
because black can actually take the
bishop and then come back and block the
check on d8 with his Rook so this is one
way that the game could continue black
could
instead of pushing the pawn swing The
Rook to C3 I mentioned this move not
sure exactly what that achieves you
could also play King F6 and prevent G5
entirely but then uh the downside of
putting the king up on F6 is not only
that you're procrastinating on pushing
your past Pawn but later down the line
white throw could try to infiltrate all
the way to G6 and punish black for
bringing the king onto a more vulnerable
spot
foreign
there's so many difficult decisions for
these two players that Bishop on e4 in
the way if that white Pawn could be
picked up and thrown to the E5 Square
white might suddenly be winning so this
is going to be anishkiri's task is he
going to be able to keep that pawn
blockaded or will at some point Jordan
move the bishop out the way and start
pressing forward and I don't think Anish
is in time to rush his a pawn down the
board White's Pawn is more advanced on
F5 and the second half on coming to E5
Anish hesitating there before playing
King F6 it's hard to say exactly what's
bothering him uh and I'm having a bit of
a hard time Robert figuring out Jordan's
next move if Anish plays King F6 I
pointed out uh the idea of Rook d8 but
black could always drop the Rook back to
A4 hitting the bishop and essentially
just forcing White's Rook back to D4
that is definitely an unappetizing
option for Jordan we talked about it the
thing white wants to avoid like the
plague here is a rook trade and being F6
is on the board
so the king blockades the First Pawn the
epon now pretty far away but quickly he
plays Bishop D3 but is his Pawn actually
getting to E5
well it's definitely gonna get to E4 but
it's going to be safely restrained by
The Rook Rook A2 the instant response
for Anish
he was definitely expecting Bishop D3
and okay E4 isn't the end of the world
for black far from it
no The Rook on E7 King on F6 team up
well Rook F2 check can always kick the
king away from that square and a niche
gets up from the board and I'm just
wondering here Donya does Anish giri
have legitimate chances to win this game
that's the question that's swirling in
my head it's he's the worst is clearly
behind him
he doesn't look like he's in any trouble
he could always give a bunch of checks
and move his Rook around so can he win
the game that's the big question and if
he does he'll match the uh photo we have
on screen of him he'll be smiling from
ear to ear
talking about photos that would set up a
photo finish if Anish managed to turn
this game around what an unbelievable
outcome that would be I think there's a
non-zero probability that we get some
sort of repetition if you imagine the
pawn on e4 black could deliver the check
on F2 and then perhaps bring the Rook
back to A2 and then the kick could
Shuffle between E3 and F4 so there's a
lot of repetitions that are usually
possible in positions like this but
Anish giri could also sense hey this is
a golden opportunity this is the best
chance I've had all game let me push
that a pawn and try to strike some fear
into Jordan's heart let me tell you
Jordan's already feeling some fear he
wasn't expecting to even play a position
with the Queens off the board and now
his Advantage is a thing of the past
must be frustrating to play an opening
where you give away material you catch
your opponent by surprise you have a
winning position he may not know how
winning but I think he felt it and then
things started to go wrong so it's good
that he's been able to write the ship to
this point but he has pushed his Pawn up
to E4 it's not getting E5 as we've been
mentioning and if the white king gets
checked away is there a future where you
see even the black king coming up to E5
right to invade on the dark squares that
could be a technique that anishikiri
employs
yeah and after Rook have to check King
E3 black comes oh so close to being able
to play that move immediately the only
reason you can't do that is because of
the intermediate check on D5 so as I
mentioned Anish might very well give
that check on F2 and force the king and
then bring the Rook either over to H2 or
to the other side of the board on A2 the
reason the Rook has sits on A2 is
because it can support more effectively
the progress of the a pawn if Geary
moves The Rook away from A2 and then
plays A5 he has to be very careful uh so
that Jordan does not simply pick that
pawn up with his Rook of course you
could also use that pawn as a decoy and
in the time that Jordan takes to to
capture that pawn and he could try to
whip up some activity in the center so a
lot of complexity behind the scenes Here
and Now another big decision by unusual
he pushes spawn will he give that check
on F2 I think those are the two main
candidate moves
and he's about to answer he plays Rook
F2 check so he wants that King out of f4
and after King to E3 he can just move
his Rook right back to the square it
came from uh I feel like I don't see a
path towards progress for white I think
that much is clear to me that doesn't
mean that a niche isn't necessarily
playing for wind because it might just
be a situation where there is no
progress to be had for either side but
with the King unable to stay on F4
without being checked away I really
don't see a way for white to play for a
win
I don't either and Jordan is thinking
because the King has two retreating
squares King to G3 to my eyes looks less
logical than King E3 especially because
it uh affords black the extra option of
Rook to D2 which actually pins the
bishop so I'd be playing King E3 pretty
quickly here but Jordan definitely has
the time to spend here
and anishagiri decisions to make will he
play Rook A2 essentially an implicit
draw for or will he take significant
risk in order to try to whip up some
winning chances here
I'm really wondering about this like I'm
deep in the weeds honestly in my own
head but I'll share the thoughts with
you uh with this King kicked away at
what point can black try to push that a
pawn uh let's say right now we throw in
it looks like anisha's about to move I
feel like he's gonna play Rook G2
because that forces White's hand I think
to play King F3 mm-hmm
and then in that sequence I think black
can play Rook D2 and maybe just force to
draw on the spot if he wants it
yup because just too many threads you
have to kick that Rook away from the D
file ASAP and the only piece to do that
is White's King agreed Rook G2 is very
likely is there any case to be made for
a move like Bishop E2 or would it be
would it be totally unwise for Jordan uh
to to be the one to refrain from
repetition
I feel like then perhaps the second Rook
is free for black to come up to E5 and
go after the C Pawn Yeah I'm just
worried that as this game continues and
if white is sitting passively and not
just threatening an E5 check that it's
going to be trouble for Jordan and we
see Rook G2 King F3 to my eyes but then
Rook to D2 so we slide behind the bishop
and what else does White have
to do that's my that's my question what
is White's plan
what is White's plan well you're not
getting E5 in anytime soon black is
saying oh for my dead body I'm going to
control this square with everything that
I've got I can't even Envision a
hypothetical scenario where white is
able to push that he pin I think the
only way that he will be able to
accomplish that is if he gets the circle
around that takes three entire moves get
it to G6 push the king back to F7 and
only then will you be able to play E5
but Robert that is three moves in an end
game like this that changes so fast is
in eternity and I don't think Jordan has
even enough time to execute a two move
maneuver much less something that takes
three moves
yeah but he also may be in a situation
where black can't really make progress
because uh The Rook will go up to d8 and
then maybe go to G8 to go to G6 things
of like that and so I do feel that your
has enough play to hold the bounce here
but I think that's the maximum for him
unless I'm really missing something if
I'm not seeing uh the future of the
position well it seems like Anish can
always just pester Jordan's pieces Force
the king to go back and forth as is
needed and so he should not be in
significant trouble anymore
agreed and it's easy to be an armchair
General and say well and you should play
for a win at all costs you should do
whatever it takes uh to generate an
imbalance but at the same time rating
considerations are important yes you
want to play to win the tournament yes
and ishigiri has a chance to win the
tournament with a win in this game but
Jordan pet Forest is an incredibly
strong Grand Master he's got an hour on
his clock you don't want to do something
foolish just so you can tell chess fans
oh look at me I played for a win Anish
giri's and all of these players
Allegiance is to objective decision
making not to doing something
performative
for sure so while Anish and Jordan they
still are playing this end game uh there
are other end games in full swing three
games left in this round this one here
the game between Magnus Carlson and
prognanda in the bottom right and if I'm
seeing that eval bar correctly well if
I'm looking at the position correctly
probably not is up a pawn Donya but it
says slight Edge to Magnus because it's
not about Pawn quantity in the end game
it's about Pawn quality and I guess that
extra Pawn for black cannot mobilize
that quickly that point Bears repeating
prognananda is up a pawn but look at
that G2 pawn it showed us it's just sort
of sitting there it's the goalkeeper and
it's saying you are never going to
create a past Pawn on the king side on
the opposite side of the board white is
just a millimeter away actually two
moves away from creating a pass Pawn of
his own so the most obvious candidate
move here is A4 but you could also try
to Simply take the A6 Pawn off the board
and do so with with your king the other
thing I'd point out Robert here is in
Queen end games it's all about the
relative activity of the queen White's
Queen occupies the best Square on the
board it's sitting in the center it can
easily access either side of the board
it can defend the G2 pawn it can check
the black king I think something has
gone a little bit wrong here for Prague
probably it's still a draw but Magnus
must be thrilled to be in the situation
that he's in
yeah because he probably feels that the
worst that happens to him is that
there's some kind of draw by repetition
where the queen gets a lot of checks
Black's pawns are very far from
promoting whereas with the move A4 I
think that will be magnus's choice he's
his plan is very clear A4 B5 if you
allow it and B6 B7 B8 as you mentioned
the queen on E5 is perfectly placed
centralized and also defending that
promoting square and so I think we can
make a couple moves just because
um an idea that I want to mention is
let's say white plays A4 and the black
queen
we'll slide to D1
to get active and attack the pawn B5
drops the A4 point I don't think you
want to do that because after Queen
takes A4 oh wow that I didn't even
change I would say it's winning well you
don't play B6 here you lose because you
have to keep your queen protected I
think the intermediate check on
B8 yeah and just go B6
and this is winning for white yeah
because the king is gonna walk around
and then it's gonna hide on A7 and I
don't think
it's a position where the black pawn
wishes it was off the board if you got
rid of the a pawn it's the worst piece
on the board
oh my goodness an umbrella
Ella Ella hey yeah that is really
helpful for white
unbelievable Magnus has played A4 by the
way so let me just show this on the
board if black just blindly starts
checking the white king
no you do not take on A6 you use the
pawn as shelter and this is com this is
over why it's gonna look B7 and vacate
the promotion Square
gosh one of those situations where you
would just kill someone to get rid of
your own Pawn
that's unreal so Magnus has very
legitimate winning chances in this
position because his pass Pawn comes
first
and it doesn't matter that black we're
looking is up two pawns if you go Queen
takes G2 we'll be up three full pawns it
doesn't matter because a second Queen
will appear on B8 and that would be a
win for magma so if we just dial it back
a couple turns a queen D1 uh-huh
D1
so
yeah the Evo aren't going back because
the line we went was unnecessary so if
your B5
black cannot take on A4 black can
probably take on B5 and that is what
black wants to get rid of the A6 Pawn so
in many of the positions that we just
looked at you will have enough checks
because you'll get a check on the a line
and the recapture on B5 is not forced
here there is the move A5 you could
weigh the pros and cons of having a
corner Pawn versus the b-pawn but for
the sake of Simplicity after a takes B5
I think the key to saving this game for
black is indeed to eliminate the G2 Pawn
as many moves as it takes you have to go
Queen G1 check
doesn't really matter where white goes
after Queen D4 take the pawn on G2 and
then start running that jeep on up the
board as fast as its legs will carry it
and unfortunately that's not all that
fast but what really really helps black
here is that after B6 G4 the queen is
actually incredibly well placed on G2
it's guarding the B7 square and it's
supervising the progress of Black Sheep
on I think Prague has just enough here
to hold half a point but even this
position is not going to be easy if
white plays a move like Queen D5 the
final thing I'll say here Robert before
I pass it back to you the placement of
Black's King on G8 could actually be a
huge problem in a lot of Pawn races
because the b-pawn will promote with
check that's why Queen D5 is a
particularly nasty move for black to
face you can't trade queens and run the
pawn down the board white promotes first
and white promotes with check
and there's one little thing I'll show
and then I think we can check in on
levana rhodian's game against kukesh uh
just did we go you know this queen D1
variation that we keep talking about uh
it's all about this Pawn race which is
getting the other side if you play A5
instead of B5 I want to point out that
it's not a mistake because at some point
you will play B5 and then spring your a
pawn free and your Pawn's already on A5
which means it's one step closer to
promoting that's a really big moment
here for prognanda he is going to try to
defend this end game and look at the
clock I might add that he is only 26
minutes for about uh seven moves that
may not sound like you know it's a
problem it's plenty of time not too many
moves but you can easily make a mistake
and allow a pawn to start rumbling up
the board and you might not be able to
handle it so I do think the prognanda he
maintains his composure he's doing quite
well so let's go to check on his is
compatriot his fellow teenager from
India gukesh has the white pieces
against Lavon aronian and we're in a
rook end game this time where gukesh
remains upon ahead indeed we've got some
incredibly complex end games I remember
an old conversation I had with my
longtime coach and I'll switch to the
Iranian game here uh left sahas uh the
same one who told the Rodney home off
story and we were discussing relative
complexity of end games can you make a
sort of General philosophical point
about which type of end game is the most
complicated and he actually had an
interesting opinion he told me that he
believes Queen endings in many ways are
actually harder to calculate and harder
to navigate even than the most notorious
type of end game which of course are
single Rook end games and we have it
here with kukesh versus Iranian but when
you've got a queen end game there's just
so many options on every move there's so
many different types of checks and there
is always the possibility of a
liquidation to a pawn end game so he
believed that Queen end games are the
hardest for a human to navigate but
definitely an unenviable task here as
well for The bonaronian Who is man he's
down upon he's got his eyes on the B2
pawn and he needs to keep his eyes there
at all costs you do not want to give
white connected Masters on the Queens
unless of course you can guarantee
yourself a pass Pawn on the other side
of the board
and there are no guarantees there but I
think uh to your point that white might
try to make a Mad Dash for the A4 Pawn
with the King because if you put King D5
King C5 King B5 and go ahead and win
that pawn well then you have two passers
on none over there on the queen side and
the King side is sort of bottled up for
the time being but I think after King D5
and Daniel maybe you can correct me if
I'm wrong then after King D5 the move
Rook C2 can be played it's not about the
double G pawns but here you keep that
King cut off but I'm still worried
because the Rook takes A4 Rook takes B2
the white king is very close and you can
make a move like King to C5 or King to
C6 and Rook B4 is helpful as well but
apparently how could Black Box I think
because because black wins G3 and once
that happens
black will play H5 and and un unbuckle
White's Pawn chain on the king side and
then all hell breaks loose there
so Rook before your intuition was
correct I guess instead of King C5 start
with Rook to B4 uh of course The Rook
trade is out of the question what is
upon ahead you can put your Rook on B3
and you try to use your king to help out
and promote that a pawn it's an end game
that looks very promising for white in
terms of winning chances but the Evo bar
is still saying that black is holding on
maybe a timely H5 will be super helpful
for black just to
dislodge the G4 Pawn from its defense of
the F5 Pawn yeah no that's a very very
important resource which means that even
if black gets into sort of the worst
case scenario which is a position like
this the game is far from over after
black plays H5 and sets his King uh in
motion so that's one way that the game
could unfold of course white could
decide to keep his King on the Kings and
that's sort of the safe option right
that's that's if you want to guarantee
that nothing crazy happens but if you
exchange the a pawn for the B Pawn
congrats you've got the past Pawn but
black of course will keep his Rook
firmly behind the pawn on A2 and you
could get into a situation where there
is just no progress to be made for
instance King F3 Rook C2 takes A4 takes
B2 you could keep your Rook to the side
of the pawn which is often a good place
to maintain your Rook but blackish just
gonna Shuffle the king between G7 and F6
and unless white makes a Mad Dash or the
queen side there's gonna be no way to
make progress and if white does yes he
actually risks losing the game if you
allow H5 at an inconvenience moment
this Rook any game full of life and it's
one of those positions where it seems
unusable for white but as you're saying
if you try too hard to win it can in
fact backfire because black will be able
to spring for your past Pawn on the king
side away from the other action but
right now gukesh is in charge he has an
advantage we'll see if he's able to
convert that and gukesh Avon all these
top players you know they have
opportunities for many more events they
might not be able to take first in the
Tata steel Masters but with so many
chess tournaments available to the
masses these days and for the title
players it's a great time to be a
professional and we are so excited to
announce Champions chess tour 2023 with
chess.com and played Magnus group
officially coming together we're gonna
bring you a chess tour like no other
with the biggest prize pool the chess
world has ever seen two million dollars
it all kicks off with the air things
Masters play-ins on February 3rd with
your reigning CCT and cgc champions
Magnus Carlson and Wesley so locked into
play we'll call the action right here at
twitch.tv chess use the command CCT in
chat for more we will be right back we
look forward to both the air things
Masters part of the Champions chess tour
and the final stretch here in round 12
the action at Tata steel we're back in a
few
minutes
oh
[Music]
three seconds
foreign
[Music]
s
for this cozy coastal town the holiday
season isn't over
in fact the most wonderful time of the
year has really just begun bear Kings on
the board in a handshake what a hold for
Wesley so just didn't give the world
champion a chance
once again vikon Zay starts the new year
as the center of the chess Universe this
year as host of the 85th taught to steal
chess tournament
a magnet for the best players in the
game some recognize the Masters field of
2023 as its strongest in recent memory
of course it helps when eight time Tata
steel chess champion Magnus Carlson is
back Magnus is going baseball if Magnus
plays like this the rest of the way who
knows what can happen the world's number
one looks to further cement his legacy
in this event and the game's history
chasing Magnus will be amongst the best
in chess several have been crowned
Champion here before some have even
shocked the world in doing so
and don't leave out those poised to
capture their first Tata title Anish
Geary is just I mean he beat both world
number one and world number two in the
same tournament
although winter Tata steel chess is also
known as the place new stars come to
bloom
Magnus one here is a teenager this
year's event has its fair share of young
players on the rise each hoping to
follow in Carlson's footsteps motorbeck
keeps his lead with a solid
well-prepared draw against Gary the
Dutch refer to Tata steel as The
Wimbledon of chess for 85 years in
running this tournament continues to be
steeped in Prestige and Legacy and does
so again in this welcoming Little Dutch
town by the sea
mine brynden it's the 85th edition of
the Tata steel chess tournament let's
make chess history together
despite it being into the sixth hour of
play these two compatriots are giving it
they're all fully focused on the
chessboard artist Geary and Jordan
Vaughn Forest Anish he was in trouble
early on Jordan showed Exquisite
preparation but when the moment came to
be ultra precise and to strike with the
Right Moves it wasn't meant to be now
we're in the end game where both sides
have their chances and Dania Anish giri
he is the five-time runner-up in Viking
Zay he has been second place to Magnus
Carlsen three times to Levon aronian
once and to Jordan Von Force he lost
that Heartbreaker in the tiebreaker and
so he needs this Championship I feel
like he really yearns for it that game
was a knife I mean that tiebreaker game
against Ben Forrest I was watching it
with baited breath it devolved into a
crazy time scramble it was anybody's
game game and Anish Gary just didn't
quite have enough in the tank but he's
got another shot at it like I said
earlier he needs a lot of help he will
need Jordan van forest's assistance in
the final round but right now anishkiri
is sitting pretty I think this game is
still very likely to end in a draw we do
see uh the black king having reached E5
once again Jordan can repeat moves if he
wants to he can deliver a check on D5
and then come back to d8 so there's a
lot of different types of repetitions
that are possible we had outlined King
E3 and King F3 before what do you make
of the developments in the last couple
moves here
um the king 95 does strike me as a bit
strange Rook D5 check would force the
king back and I'm wondering if there's a
way for Jordan to attempt to win this
game that's what I've been thinking
about for such a long period if he is
trying to win he will have to play King
E3 at some moment and then when the Rook
slides the G2 put his Bishop back to E2
to retreat the bishop that way the king
is a bit more active and it has the
enemy King in opposition
um the H6 Pawn a bit of a Target if
you're not careful white can throw in
the move C6 himself and then play Rook
D7 offer a rook trade on the seventh
Rank and going for another pass Pawn so
there are many things that black does
need to keep an eye on I just feel like
the pieces are placed on perfect squares
optimally situated are blacks pieces
covering all the dark squares
I'm trying not to read too much into the
body language but if I had to make a
prediction I think Jordan is going to
opt for one of the repetitions uh that
we've that we've talked about it just
seems like the trend of the game is
favored black for so long that white is
you know one inaccuracy away from
handing over the advantage permanently
and the issue with the idea of C6 is
that black stroke uh can pretty easily
stop the depot I mean C6 doesn't
actually threaten Rook D7 uh because I
can take and then take on D3 with check
of course C6 does threaten King E3 so
it's kind of a second order thread and
that it threatens the threat right King
E3 and then Rook D7 becomes a big
problem but black stroke on D2 can swing
back to the open B file and stop the
pawn from the eighth rank as well speak
of the devil C6 is on the board and
Jordan does try to keep the Flames of
his initiative flowing
he wants to play Rook D7 at the right
moment which could be costly for a niche
so say this Rook on D2 just runs
somewhere else to A2 or to B2 I think
that would be a pretty grave error from
Anish Kiri the fact that his Rook is at
the enemy Bishop it keeps that Rook tied
down on d8 but if the Rook were to slide
away to a square like B2 then we're
considering options like Rook to D7 and
you can't afford in some positions the
trade of Rooks if it works on B2 I guess
you could slide back to B8 maybe that
would be bad for white but if the Rook
run A2 then Rook D7 becomes much more
likely there is the possibility of
sliding the king back to F6 in response
to Rook D7 but that opens a can of worms
that I don't know if black wants to open
we mentioned that trade of Rooks is bad
in 99 of cases well this is the one
percent because here if white can trade
Rooks the epon is finally set in motion
if you can get pawns to E5 and F5 that
Bishop is more than capable of seeing
them through all the way can land on C4
then you're able to play F6 and uh
you're able to cover the light squares
and once the pawns both reach the sixth
rank in most cases unless black can
somehow squeezes ape On Through To
promotion uh in time that's unlikely as
well
that does not seem like an appetizing
option even if objectively the position
is drawn Anish with 19 minutes on the
clock he's got another nine moves to
make before he gets 15 more minutes
tacked onto his clock and just like the
middle game situation he's got a lot of
decisions left to make it he's in time
pressure again for the second time this
game
one of the big decisions that needs to
make is when or will he push the a pawn
uh the A5 at some moment could be a
problem for white to do it just like the
black king and with the Rook D5 check
and a king F4 and pawn E5 that could be
a trouble for a niche for Jordan if A5
happens and you can't easily meet that
pawn push that pawn gets down the board
very quickly so uh you know earlier I
was saying I didn't see things for white
but now that he's put his work on dating
played C6 there's a future where Jordan
tries to bring his Rook to D7 and that
forces the black king back and some
sometimes those enf pawns get rolling
and they can't be stopped if we could
bring up an announce board and we will
get to the Magnus game shortly I just
want to point out one more important
detail which is that A5 does have a
concrete problem associated with it
namely white can slide the king over to
E3 and if you play Rook to B2 then
unfortunately the pawn falls off Rook D5
check King F6 and white can snap the
pawn off now even if white does that the
game is far from over because then C6
becomes a liability and black could try
to surround it with his Rooks so you
know even the worst case scenario isn't
all that terrible but obviously Anish
would like to avoid this if he can he
can avoid it by bringing his Rook to A2
but as we have already established this
increases the appeal of Rook to D7 I
actually think King F6 if is forced in
this case and hey try evaluating this
position with 15 minutes left I know the
eval bar is that is dropping down but I
think you'll co-sign this point I would
be terrified of playing Black in a
position like this when Bishop C4 and F6
is pretty imminent I guess the a pawn is
far enough Advanced to offer black
significant counter play but Anish with
some very difficult decisions to make
here
yeah this type of endings that could
just be losing on the spot for black
instead it'd be winning just because
that a pawn is going to run to the other
side so it's something to keep in mind
you want to Envision a future that looks
promising for you not just in life but
in chess as well and here whether or not
the pond gets in Rome is the big
question A5 finally played by a niche he
made that move pretty quickly and he
also looked confident doing it well
whatever my promising future looks like
I think it involves compensating with
Robert Hess but um hey I gotta I got a
big compliment from you earlier with
Queen D1 I gotta return the favor we
gotta be square but A5 is on the board
and Jordan immediately responds with
King three so it's obvious that he's
trying to play the clock as well as the
board
and now another big dilemma Robert will
Anish Gear Well I don't even think it's
a dilemma I don't think emotionally that
I would ever be able to part wizard of
the pawn
and he doesn't he plays a different move
Rook to G2
and what do you make of this I was not
expecting that
well Rook D5 check the king will have to
slide back to F6 and if you take the A5
Pawn you lose G4 and there was a past
Rook Pawn that was a separate different
password upon the other side of the
board and for black that means White's
pawns are less scary and you still get
to keep your past pawn and all the other
pawns are stopped in their track so I
think that Anish made a good decision
just now and I think there is a path to
a draw that involves like sacrificing
The Exchange back and winning some of
White's pawns getting into a drone Rook
end game if Jordan plays Bishop back to
E2 which I think he's quite likely to
play Anish might slip back to F6 and
then he actually might take the bishop
on E2 and then capture the pawn on e4
and go back around for the C6 spawn in
the meantime Jordan of course presumably
would go Rook D5 takes A5 so we could
get a two on two Rook end game where
black would be completely out of the
woods that's one way the game could end
or we could still get uh that very same
repetition we've been talking about for
the last couple couple of moves
complicated these types of positions
where
you know you're doing okay of at the
moment but can you play for a win how do
you play for a win do you risk much by
trying to win the game because that can
really backfire so that a pawn is pretty
fast I'm gonna add that point A4 A3
happens before you know it and Jordan
needs to keep an eye out for that but he
also has Rook D7 as an option he has
Rook the king ever goes back to F6 he
can put his work on G8 and try to bring
his hook to G6 so it's not just black
who is threatening things white can
threaten things as well absolutely he
can and Jordan will continue to think of
ways to keep this game going and keep
his winning chances alive he's got
plenty of time on the clock what a
defensive effort by Anish giri and so
far things are looking really nice for
him the likeliest outcome is of course a
draw well the likeliest outcome in
Magnus Carlson's game has been a draw
for a long time but the world champion
continues to make progress that's on the
bottom right of your screen he has just
blocked prog's check with Queen to D4
and you called her Robert he actually
has played the move A5 before playing B5
it seems counterintuitive but Tempo wise
it's exactly the same thing Prague is
now up two pawns but White's got the
better pass Pawn what a fascinating end
game we're about to get B5 there is on
the board
G4 was playing the eval bar went very
high up there so I'm wondering if that
was a fatal error from aronian and that
would be a huge victory for gokish if he
is able to secure it it would indeed and
that game has exploded we do see a white
Pawn in H5 that can only win one thing
Levon did carry out his main counter
play plan which is to separate White's
Pawn chain he's captured on F5 and he
has two pass Pawns of his own but one of
them is about to disappear I think ukesh
is gonna take on F7 and the eval bar
seems to believe that White's Pawn chain
and uh connected passers on the queen
side should with correct play decide the
game
so why don't we go to that one because
we haven't looked in a long time and I
feel like the Magnuson program on the
game will stay put for yes it will at
least a little so as we tune in to
gukesh against
levonne aronian we see that lavon's last
move was Pawn to G4 so googesh did win
the A4 Pawn
um Levon won the case side and G4
apparently was a pretty big inaccuracy I
guess giving up the pawn on F7 with
check wasn't the way to go but I
understand why he didn't play F6 I think
F6 allows White's Pawn to sneak through
to H7 where it will suddenly be defended
by that Rook so that was in the very
appetizing option there was also the
possibility of sliding the king back to
F6 but then you essentially put your
king in front of one of the past pawns
apparently that was the correct move you
don't need to tell go cash twice he
grabs the pawn in F7 but what is he
going to do now where does The Rook
belong after the king moves on to G5
which it just did
I wish I had the exact answer to that
question I'm trying to work it out
myself but I feel like the white king
you know if it tries to go all the way
to the queen side and then the Rook will
sacrifice itself for the g-pawn so you
said you have two pass pawns with your
King's help Against The Rook in many
positions uh oftentimes that will lead
to a split point so where does The Rook
belong that's the big question
still think it has to go it's back to
like F1
yeah I mean it needs to be at a spot
where it can easily sacrifice itself for
the Jeep on when the time arises so
let's forecast a couple of moves here
let's say white plays Rook F1
presumably aronian will have to
eliminate the H Pawn that sends the eval
bar even higher up does white just start
pushing his pawns but if you do it in
cautiously you run the risk of losing
one of them like if you play A4 lock
will get his Rook to B3
but maybe it can just be chased away
with a king
what do you think A4
wow and if Rook B3 you're saying Rook I
want to be defend them that way that
makes perfect sense because G3 the G
Pawn is too slow the white king comes to
C4 and now your pawns go your Rook is in
the perfect location to push your pass
pawns and get ready to sacrifice for the
enemy passer this is a winning position
while basic this is such an important
plan I think it Bears demonstrating just
as as in a scenario what exactly do we
mean when we say the Rook sacks itself
or the j-pawn well we literally mean
first of all you Force black to spend as
many moves as possible getting the pawn
up to you you still don't need to play
Rook shoe one takes G2 you can keep
pushing your Pawns
when the king let's say appears on H you
still don't need to do anything no
action is required but if you wanted to
you could play the move Rook to B2 and
at this point Rook takes G2 is just
totally one-sided because the
combination of White's passers
supervised by the king is way too much
to handle for blackstruck and Black's
King is way too far away white just
plays A6 A7 and then B7 and you won't
even have to win queen against Rook
you're just gonna get an actual queen
against King so this is the nightmare
scenario for Lavon and it increasingly
seems like he won't be able to avoid
that scenario because of how long it
takes for him to promote his g-pawn
wow so good guys could pick up an
important win as he you know has had a
much better
kind of a comeback than the start of the
event he was struggling he was losing a
bunch of games but now he is in great
shape to win this one if he Retreats his
Rook
back down to F1 do any other moves keep
the lead for white that's the big
question can he start with A4 because
it's very tempting just push your past
Pawn but if you play A4 The Rook then
goes to B3 I guess yeah that's a hard
position to make heads or tails because
then you could go Rook F2 but but then
problem four is G3 with tempo over
before as well you win the A4 oh that's
exactly right
no that's why you need the Rook on the
first round because it's not only does
it guard the G Pawn
but you also can bring the Rook behind
one of your past pawns if necessary
so Rook F1 is a pretty critical move I
would say the other tempting move here
is King C4 to stop Rook B3 to bring your
king closer to your own pawns and it's
not abundantly clear to me that black
has some kind of he's played
over as a mistake
and he's got seven minutes I let's not
forget that he's he needs to make eight
more moves
it's a natural move
why does that bar drop
King C4 looks to my I mean maybe I know
why
is it because I'm kind of Rook F3 in a
timely fashion I think it is Rook F3 but
more importantly the reason the King on
C4 is so awkward is that later down the
line I think black will be able to give
a check on F4 and there's this very
typical idea where you bring the Rook
forcibly behind the past Pawn so for
example after Rook F3 ukesh is relying
on Rook G7 check King takes H5 and A4 we
will almost certainly get this position
on the board then black plays G3 and if
white kind of nonchalantly brings the
other Pawn up well after Rook F4 check
this is why you didn't want your King on
C4 The Rook is able to get to G4 and
more importantly although white is able
to bring the Rook behind the pawn I
actually think black does not need to
get the king to F2 or does he no no I
guess
wow King G6 apparently is the only move
you kidding me what's the difference the
King goes oh no no so just leave your
Jeep on where sorry put it back on G3 I
guess just run with the King start with
the King for some reason I don't get the
mathematics of that though how could G2
possibly hurt your cause
oh I got it oh my God this is beautiful
G2
I think the reason is that when the pawn
gets to A7
black needs to be able to stop it with
Rook J what's the problem the problem is
that you actually helped quite by
allowing the deflection Rook takes G2
whereas if you keep your Pawn on the
third Rank and we repeat the same line
when push comes to shove after Rook G8
black Jeep on stays alive
and of course I made some inaccuracies
there but you get the point white does
not have Rook takes G3 and black can
take that Tempo to eliminate the a pawn
oh my God this is all very easy to see
that's a mess yeah I mean no it's so
easy to see how could it take you so
long to figure all this out I mean I'm
losing my strength and I'm getting old
I'm almost 30.
and I've already passed that so don't
you worry I lost my strength way before
that but the point is this end game is
like like crazy deep you need to
calculate so many moves ahead and it's
teetering between good winning chances
for white and black hole in the game
Lavon he had that draw earlier in the
tournament against origin era geisi
where he outplayed Arjun he found
himself in a winning position but that
triangulation was very hard to spot here
with the black pieces he's going to use
his experience he's going to try to hold
this game although Eva Bar says he's
losing I don't understand anything about
this end game for some reason taking on
a try first doesn't work but playing
Rook F3 first does oh and I guess it's
because Rook F3 saves a Tempo in
comparison here The Rook can get to H1
in one Fell Swoop whereas there uh black
saved Tempo on the Move Rook F3 if you
play it now gukesh will give a check and
go to H1 you have a Tempo up compared to
the other position and that is the tempo
you need to squeeze that pawn into A8 I
think this is now winning for gukesh
just one of those positions where I'm
often going to be like I think I think
that looks good question mark Maybe
maybe you make the move and then the Evo
bar rejects you it laughs at you and
says try again next time do better yep
it's a very difficult end game because I
would say it looks winning for white
like if you just showed this position
you flash it in front of a someone's
eyes they're like What's winning two
connected past pawns aren't we always
told that rook and two connected pawns
beats rook and one Pawn on the other
side of the board and here the answer
seems to be that Black's past Pawn is
more advanced and that should keep him
in the game but it's not going to be
easy for levonne Ronin I mean even the
evil bar isn't really making sense of
this position back and forth hither and
there it goes and now it sits on the
incredibly ambiguous assessment 1.3 what
the heck does that mean because this
position is either winning or drawn
there's no middle ground either white
promotes a queen or Black's King stops
the puns there's nothing uh in between
and Robert I got a little irritated at
the end of the commentary three days ago
uh when Notre breaks saved that Rook end
game against Vincent because you know
the chat is going crazy and it was a
winning end game for Vincent according
to the engine but I kept repeating the
point that from a practical perspective
actually winning that end game was
tremendously difficult and I really
think that a lot of Chess fans they fall
into the Trap of assuming that just
because there are limited pieces on the
board and just because the computer
assessment seems very decisive it's
saying plus eight or something that the
win is easy in fact there's an inverse
relationship between the number of
pieces on the board and complexity some
of the most complicated games and
positions in chess happen when there's
only two or three pieces left on the
board
couldn't have said it better myself not
even close and we are looking at a
position for levonne Rowan he has plenty
of time I think that's something he
needs to use to his Advantage because
there might be a moment where kukesh is
only one path to Victory and with seven
minutes and 37 seconds for seven moves
one minute per move is not a lot so
isn't even at the board right now which
is surprising to me oh there he's right
now he is he was in the immediate
vicinity
okay
so Rook H7 is
mandatory
and he's gonna play it
and and by the way we can use the table
base right there are my math is correct
there are seven pieces on the board so
on chess.com events you can just click
on table base and find out what is going
on here is it objectively when what is
that winning path so that's the cool
thing about the seven or fewer pieces
I'm actually setting it up on the table
base and we will find out very shortly
but once again we'll be setting it up
just click on it on Just Like Home
events it's right there oh yeah I mean
I'm there's a table basis available
elsewhere as well it is a draw
it's a draw
wow so it's one of those evaluations
where the the Horizon effect the engine
doesn't see all the way down the line oh
my God you've seen this even in World
Championship matches right where uh the
game one of karyakan and Carlson it said
that Magnus was winning but they agreed
in the draw because there was a fortress
so what's your oh my gosh for the
drawing idea and I'm maybe exaggerating
a little bit but the drawing idea is
pretty incredible
um and you could just spend an hour you
know navigating that the complexities of
this and even with table base available
after Rook to H1
um and yeah lavon's already played King
G6 black of course plays the move G3 oh
sorry now black does not play the move
G3 that's the whole point how tempting
is it to play that move this allows
white spawn to squeak forward you
actually need to play kind of the
Ventura idea by giving a series of
lateral checks with the rook and the
King has nowhere to hide it can run to
A6 just keep checking it it runs to B4
you keep checking it ultimately the king
will have to step back and the moment it
does that's the perfect opportunity to
play the move G3 you force the king onto
an awkward spot then you push the pawn
and you have just enough time uh to
ultimately stop White's pawns with
Black's King even if I had access to
table base it would be hard to reproduce
these moves
yeah this entire position where the king
is cut off is really important it's very
instructive that the Apon wants to
wander up the board but if we actually
just make a couple moves here so um
A5 let's say okay
King G5 and A6
right the pawn is going really fast and
if you play Rook F6 that's normally the
way to stop the pawn here The Rook
slides to A1 and gets behind it that's
really important because now the Pod is
promoting so even if the if the Rook
were not able to go to A1 then black
would hunt down that pawn but it's not
meant to be in this particular position
but if you had to give up that Rook on
H1 for the g-pawn that's how you stop
white from making progress you cut the
king off but here again I think you use
the same technique in this specific
position Rook to uh f8 as we discussed
it loses to A7 you have to start giving
those lateral checks again and the
moment whites King slides forward to A4
you have to find the very difficult
moved Rook to F6 this is such a hard
move to play but the point is either
white loses the a pawn or the King has
to expose itself again and then again
there go the checks the king can hide on
A2 but when it does that again you come
back to F6 and the a pawn is the sitting
deck so ultimately the issue is that
white has to start pushing one of the
pawns and the other Pawn isn't able to
support it while the king is just too
exposed to the lateral checks but all of
that is hard to figure out guess who has
already figured it out that would be
Lavon aronian ladies and gentlemen
levarian you know he is a veteran player
he has faced off against Magnus Carlson
and beaten him on so many occasions he
has of course lost his fair share of
games but the point is he has experience
at the highest level the world champions
he has faced all of them and he has
scored impressive victories and now it's
about showing off that defense has he
been able to discover the exact path
towards a drop maybe not but he's
playing accurately thus far and it seems
like the white king all the way up on B5
should be helpful at first glance but
Rook F5 check keep checking the king
eventually the king will have to drop
back to the A3 Square
yeah and I'm I'm digging through some of
these lines Black's task uh is is not
over there's a couple of very hard moves
that black will have to find in the
event that gukesh runs to A3 that's what
he has to do in order to meet uh the the
third ranked check with B3 and at some
point there's a position in which black
actually has to put the king uh and
block the rook's access to f8
temporarily and that's the only way to
draw I mean man Lavon he will need to
use every one of those 38 minutes if he
wants to uh finish off this incredible
defensive task
yeah I'm not jealous of him right now
new right this is going to be difficult
and uh for Lavon he has the right
pattern though he is checking the king
he'll Force the king back to A3 and then
he can make use of his own past Pawn so
he knows what he's doing I'm watching
him on the screen here just he seems
like he's going to keep giving the
checks
and then the king will have to be pushed
to the rim on A3 and it doesn't help the
pawns go promote just yet and so move 52
King to C4 that is going to be the
culprit if Lavon Saves the Game
man what an unacceptable Lincoln
performance request how could he have
missed that incredibly Elementary win
in this incredibly Elementary position
sarcasm is dripping yeah though this has
been it is challenging ending um most
endings have more to them than if she
meets the eye but for Lavon and for
gukesh here this game not going to be
consequential it doesn't appear for the
top of the leaderboard because right now
Lavon can at best draw this game and
that means he is out of contention for
the fight for first place so Magnus
against pragnanda we have Jordan Von
Forrest against whoa wait a second
yes and he scares Pawn on A2
is Anish Gary's Pawn on A2 I believe it
is that is a factual statement
how did it get there in like two seconds
and also why is the position better for
white so anisha's pawns on A2 but white
is the side that is preferred according
to the email bar
so many questions not a lot of answers I
don't know if the players have the
answers Jordan though has put himself in
a position where he can finally push
that pawn forward to E5
and maybe that has to do with the reason
let's pull up that game and we see there
is a Pawn on A2 over here and okay the
Evo bar is still hovering towards the
center at first it must have liked
White's position but now it's realizing
not so fast and I think the reason why
is because E5
threatens F6 check winning material but
you can play Rook E8 I believe he gives
that Rook on A8 is tied down to the
promotion Square so you can throw in
rookie eight and if F6 check the king
will slide back to f8 not F7 you don't
want to stay on the light squares avoid
the light squares if you can but the
King goes to f8 you cannot afford to
trade Rooks if you're white and now the
question done it is the A2 Pawn is that
going to become a queen oh my gosh and
what makes this even crazier is that you
can't just step away to any Square Rook
A4 Rook C4 check and now you're forced
to take your eyes off of the a pawn but
if you go to A5 Rook C5 same idea and
black is able to eliminate that e51 if
he manages to do that and he's totally
out of the woods where else can The Rook
go well it can step back to A3 maybe
this is the solution but
I don't know what Black's best move is
here what's amazing is that even the
white has reached E5 with his Pawn those
pawns still have a very hard time
progressing if you play E6 you give up
the F6 square and if you play F6 you
will need the services of your Bishop to
further the progress of these pawns
maybe black will step over to F2
familiar Square in order to keep that
Bishop immobilized E5 is on the board
foreign
this position is complicated the players
are about to approach move 60 and that's
good news for them because they get an
additional 15 minutes on the clock as
soon as move 60 is played so rookie
eight
Anish says please take my Rook oh no my
Rook but if it's captured the a palm
promotes and black wins the game so Eric
rosenstyle tricks not going to work on
Jordan Von forest and said he is going
to move his Rook probably to A7 because
of what you were just saying Dunya if
you bring a rook to A5 there's Rook C5
you bring it to A4 there's Rook C4 check
which immediately wins the game so The
Rook at A7 it feels like the safest
square and it threatens Rook takes C7
with check so I feel like Rook A7 is the
right Square to place your Rook on
agreed completely Rook A3 is also
possible but Rook A7 is the most
invulnerable Square relatively speaking
and then Anisha will have to find a
suitable response to the devastating
massive threat of Rook takes C7 maybe
he'll move his King back preemptively so
that the move doesn't come with check
maybe he'll bring his Rook to C8 but
that looks pretty passive a lot of work
left to do for Mr Geary
yes he is going to continue with his
pass Pawn but also white pawns are free
and becoming passers themselves it's a
wild one and both sides have their
chance this is a three result position
even if the evaluation Bar says it's a
level game it's not just uh King and
Rook versus King and Rook where it's
obvious nothing is obvious about this
one the only thing that's obvious is
that's not obvious and so while the
players they are thinking move 60 is
being reached I think we are going to
zoom out for a moment here and with move
behind us and the player is getting the
more time that game between Magnus and
Prague after our break we're gonna dive
right back into that one because white
has passed pawns black has a pass Pawn
whose pawns will get there first that's
the big question but for now short break
and win return it's more from round 12
of the 2023 Tata steel Chess Masters
oh yeah
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
is your world champion in classical
rapid and Blitz chess Magnus Carlson the
number one rated player in the world for
a dozen years now he takes on the Indian
Prodigy pragnananda and Magnus has been
pressing in end game for hours pragnana
has been defending admirably and
accurately he looks to hold a half point
four results are in the books from
today's round 12. we saw Wesley so he
was not able to take down Nordic
abusatara so abdusitarov remains in the
lead Jordan Von force and Denise Geary
still in session if Anish wins he ties
abusotav in the standings Magnus and
prognanago and added Fabiola and Vincent
kyber and a very entertaining draw who
cash and levona run in a rook end game
and down at the bottom of these matchups
Hara maksudu took down arjunera geisi
Richard report he started steamrolled
diggly run in the end there so report in
maksudu a great day for them we'll see
if others can join them on the
scoreboard so Dania
Miss Magnus Carlson endgame I feel like
we've seen it before see it again
deep down
into the sixth hour of play he is trying
to win a game that it would seem he has
no business winning
and it seemed that he had every business
I guess that's not a usable term but he
definitely had business winning the game
in its first half he was dominating out
of the opening we expected a smooth
Victory but Magnus Carlson this
tournament he's made some
uncharacteristic errors he let
pragnananda back in the game and some
tactical magic near move 40 allowed
Prague to get the game into the queen
end game that we now have in front of us
and I think prognanada has actually
identified a very important defensive
construction he correctly went after
white sheep on because the only way
you're gonna save this game with black
is if you create a pass Pawn of his own
and not only has he created one but he
has advanced it all the way to G3 and he
is very likely I think to play the move
G2 in this position when White's Queen
is saddled with the additional task of
guarding the promotion square of course
the only way white wins this position is
ultimately by getting a queen on B8 and
smoking Black's Queen out of its
blockading post but Robert if the pawn
lands on G2 where it is nicely protected
by the queen I do not see a way for
Magnus to make any appreciable progress
no he's going to try to bring that Queen
up to B8 he wants it to be more active
rather than defensive but we might see a
situation Dania where one pair of queens
is traded and then a new pair appears so
what that looks like is if white is
going to play the move Queen to B6 in
the near future so G2 looks automatic
for a white sorry for black and then the
response is like the queen to B6 that if
you do eventually get queen beat I have
to move my king off the last rank so I
don't get checked or move let's make
those moves yeah let's do it let's show
what that looks like so Queen B6
and now the question is do you play King
G7 seems fine if Queen B8 is played
and you trade on B8
white gets a new Queen but so does black
and now we have another discussion black
is up a pawn but White's Pawn is more
advanced do not play A6 in this position
I just want to let everybody know that
A6 would be a tragic blunder king and
queen are in the same diagonal so Queen
to G3 check or queen H2 check picks up
the queen on V8 that would be a tragic
ending to what has been a very
interesting end game countless Blitz and
bullet games end precisely in this way I
even know of a few classical end games
that have been decided with uh crazy
blunders it's never too late to make a
fatal mistake in chess but we're
actually quite likely I think to get an
end game like this what do we make of
this new type of Queen end game well the
problem for black is that White's got a
second pass pawn and it's pretty far
Advanced black has his share of past
pawns and he might have to adopt the
same exact strategy that he used to get
this end game uh namely just drive that
H Bond down the board as quickly as he
possibly can again and use a series of
well-timed checks to drive whites King
onto a compromised spot Force white to
take as long as possible uh to get this
Pawn to A6 and by the way Robert even if
the pawn reaches A7 that doesn't mean
the game is over in these types of
positions it's actually very very hard
to dodge the barrage of checks that
Black's Queen will undoubtedly deliver
to White's King so I think Prague will
want to avoid this scenario if he can
but I don't really see a way for him to
do that do you
no I don't but I think your point is a
good one that the white King has nowhere
to hide unlike in the position when
black had an eight pawn and the King ran
behind it there are no pawns remaining
the only pawns are on the king side away
from the rest of the action so I do
think that in a sequence like that
probably not is still going to find
himself drawing this game this is really
impressive stuff from him there are so
many opportunities to go wrong he had a
very rough position early on he
sacrificed the pawn was able to then go
and get an imbalance where he had a
second Queen but there was a rook and a
queen for Magnus and he was able to spot
the Tactical line that kept him in the
game and he's not just in the game he is
well on his way to holding this what
incredible composure to just hold the
position that he had against the world
champion in the midst of a very rough
patch a disappointing loss yesterday and
yet Prague has brought every ounce of
effort to this game name the question
now is whether he can complete the
effort we should point out that he's got
four minutes now on the clock and two
moves before the second time control he
will get an infusion of 15 minutes when
move 60 is executed the problem is that
15 minutes doesn't solve all of your
time issues and one strategy Magnus
could try to adopt is just to exhaust
products clock make moves and moves and
moves try to make as many moves as
possible that Force black into tough
decisions and if Prague has to defend
this position with you know three four
minutes for the rest of the game it's
very very easy to give a wrong check or
to blunder some sort of Queen
interposition with check so that's
something Magnus will have to try if he
wants to pull a rabbit out of the Hat
here
I think Prague has got this I just don't
think the white king is if you were to
run so I feel very confident in Prague
Nana's ability to make this drawn for
Magnus Carlson he had an oppressive
streak of games where he was winning it
seemed like he was going to come back
and take this tournament and even if he
draws he still will have a chance
because it'll be a full point behind
nordia Abdus atarov the problem is
abusitarov gets the white pieces in
tomorrow's game and if you need somebody
to lose you prefer to have the black
pieces but abusot does play Jordan Von
Forest tomorrow so that should be a
battle because Jordan he doesn't back
down to anybody even against dingley
Wren with the black pieces he played
such an exciting opening it was just
Rich it was new and it was a struggle
from the outset so I think we can go
back to our view of the other games
Dania because I really do feel like
prognanda has us under control and he
has played G2 lending even more Credence
to that idea this game it's likely to
last for a while Magnus plenty of time
on his clock and I think you you said it
Jordan man Forest he knows he can't win
the tournament anymore but he also knows
that he's got his chance to put his
fingerprints all over the conclusion of
the event with a win in the last round
and his State of Mind in preparation for
that all-important game against the
tournament leader is largely going to be
determined by the end of his game
against Anish Gary things continue to
sharpen up every time we think that we
think that things are nearing their
conclusion that a repetition of moves is
inevitable
Jordan app finds a way to add some
Tabasco sauce to the position and there
is a lot of Tabasco sauce in the center
there's a pond sitting on E6 and he is
one move away from getting both of his
past pawns to the sixth rank he has
managed to drive Anish Gary into a very
tight spot
yeah it's uncomfortable when you see a
pawn sitting on E6 there's a pawn chain
uh a niche has been pestering Jordan so
as we pulled this game up on the big
screen here for you all that the last
move played for black was going Rook F2
because the King was an F4 so he's just
saying your Bishop is not going to move
because all white needs to do to win
this game is for the bishop on D5 where
it attacks the A2 pawn and will win it
but also protects the E6 Pawn so F6 will
happen next
sorry what's up no no go ahead because I
was going to say something unrelated and
totally irrelevant to our understanding
the position please continue no I think
that Anish has to play rookie too like
it is fourth here because if he doesn't
stop Bishop to D5 he is likely just
going to lose the game so Rook D2 is
forced and that is good news for a niche
for some of his decisions are made for
themselves like he doesn't have a choice
hmm there is one interesting detail
that I'm spotting here if you do allow
Bishop D5 there's the interesting
possibility of actually playing King E7
now that move doesn't work in most cases
because you blunder the C7 Pawn with
check but in the event that white has a
bishop on D5 after Rook takes C7 King T6
suddenly Black's King is making contact
with both the rook and the bishop at the
same time white can solve that problem
with a check on D7 let's not forget
about that little Pawn sitting there on
A2 so you could actually Envision some
scenarios where white sacrifices his
Bishop for that pawn and tries to use
what could be three past pawns to
overwhelm the combined defensive efforts
of Black's King and Rook this could
actually end up being our Most
Fascinating end game of the day it's got
a lot of competition
laughs
yes the competition all across the
remaining three boards and as we look at
this one that would be something if you
get to take this Pawn on C7 for check
have a new passer uh that would be
difficult to assess so
for Anish giri he needs to win this game
to catch up to the Rebecca dusotarov and
Jordan Von Forest he is playing the
ultimate spoiler because he has to play
against noribbeck who's tariff in the
final round so going into round 13 in
front of the pack you're already back up
due to Tar was proven he can hold up and
perform Under Pressure here's what he
had to say about how he does it and he
will play Jordan in route 13. let's hear
his interview
uh I think it's my character is uh
uh his calm and yeah I don't
express my emotions
so yeah it's known that I am very calm
and
uh without emotions
he said he said calm without emotions
and then he smiles I feel like he
made himself hard to believe in a sense
but he is a killer over the board that
is clear it is abundantly clear and his
boys his composure is so impressive for
his age I mean we now take these things
for granted but this this new crop of
talent they don't care who they're
playing they don't care about the
tournament situation they play the same
way every game and that votes very very
well for Notre back's chances to build
what is already an incredible chess
career and has every Prospect of
becoming more incredible Through The
Years by the way let me just get this
out the relevant thing that I had to say
is that I am a massive spicy food nut I
love spicy food of all kinds Thai food
Indian food I'll get the spiciest option
at Thai restaurants and when I would
come to Europe uh the first thing my mom
and I would do uh is go to the
supermarket and try to find hot sauce
because my preferred snack when I was
younger would be crackers or bread
dipped into hot sauce and the only hot
sauce that we would find on the shelves
of you know most supermarkets in Spain
and the Netherlands uh was Tabasco sauce
and so I have a uh unique emotional
connection I'm not Vasco isn't my
favorite hot sauce but I'll put it on
anything I'll put it on pancakes
first of all what's wrong with you
second of all I love a lot of things I
love that you love Tabasco sauce so much
that you're to tell us all this
completely irrelevant story because you
said the position was getting you know
it's hot and spicy like Tabasco hey I'm
Mr Irrelevant
first of all you're not Brock Purdy come
on why don't you do that I know you I
know you're a 49ers fan but don't you
make yourself out to be someone you're
not
I'm um I'm speed well I did use the word
Tabasco that's why I remember this story
I said Jordan Addison's basket and I
thought well maybe our European viewers
uh don't necessarily understand that
reference it's not you know
it's not the most famous sauce in the
world I don't know what the most famous
sauce in the world is probably ketchup
yes I I did see and I heard so my senses
are really working well at this point
more hot sauce stories please or peas
missing an L there the basketball
pancakes is definitely an accuracy yeah
I'm gonna have to second that
considering I first said it first so
it's really not much of a second but
that's not the here nor there there is a
past Pawn a chain from G4 to E6 and it
is a niche biting his shirt right now is
that what I'm seeing him do
he he looks like he is really
concentrated and he forgets that cameras
are on him and he is trying to stop
these Pawn failings from G4 to E6
meanwhile Jordan would love to bring his
Bishop up to it get anisha's pass Pawn
so uh I don't know what's going on with
anisha's shirt but I can see that his
play is quite good
and despite appearances I don't really
think that Jordan is risking now he
might have to take some serious risks in
order to keep his winning chances alive
but as things currently stand if he
really wanted to draw
um and and if he got cold feet he could
play King F4 Rook F2 and come back to G3
this repetition has existed now for well
over 10 moves but if he wants to keep uh
the fire burning he could actually try
to shift his King over to E3 and get the
D2 Square under his control so that he
could then get his Bishop to D5 and if
he manages to do that things spin
completely out of control
he does have that additional 15 minutes
tacked onto his clock
the clock shows eight minutes but when
it goes down to zero fifteen minutes are
going to be automatically added and he
needs every single second to keep
himself composed Within These incredibly
complex end game Waters
well what you're saying could have
happened the king went to G3 when The
Rook was on F2 so after King F4 Rook F2
will likely be the response just
repeating the position and then the
white king can't come to E3 but I think
you made a very astute observation that
even if the king does go to the E3
Square Black's Saving Grace will be
bringing the king out to E7 and then to
D6 or to F6 depending on what the
reaction is so I think that the king is
going to save the day for a niche as
long as it doesn't get in trouble as
long as it's not falling victim to a
swift attack I believe he can use it as
a weapon and to attack White's Pawns
absolutely well this game remains
incredibly complex but for the second
time in the Magnus broad game there are
three queens on the board ladies and
gentlemen so let's take a gander at
what's going on in the world champions
game yes there are two queens for white
and only one for black but that is about
to change Prague has allowed white to
promote the Apon but he has given a very
important check on C3 in order to cover
the h8 square and on the next move
Robert it is a very likely possibility
that Prague is going to promote to a
queen so that he could cover the check
on e4 with Queen to G6 I still think
he's got everything under complete
control
foreign
so the check to the king where is the
king going to go that's the big question
um there's nowhere the queen blocks on
D4 but yeah once the Queens are traded a
new drawing appears on G1 is a draw for
sure uh the reason why I say draws while
black is up a pawn White's Pawn is more
advanced so black will be forced to just
check that King and look at Magnus he
knows it's a draw
yeah
a dropper might already be forthcoming
there are no and the thing is black
might not even have to push the h-bomb I
mean H5 is one way to draw but I I
actually think black can pursue whites
King to the edge of the Earth the queen
on A8 does not offer the king really any
sort of shelter and you often want to
give diagonal checks these types of
positions in order to avoid the
possibility of the queen blocking that
check just the way that Magnus is moving
I think signifies the fact that he
understands that his winning chances
are no more
there's only one way he could win and
that's if prognatically Queen G6 here
check I might add and then the White
Queen goes to E4 because a queen trade
is immediately winning for white the a
pawn is too far Advanced so don't trade
Queens of your prognanda he of course
knows that he will not trade Queens
he'll give a check probably on D1
because the king can't run can't run to
the E4 Square that's for sure then Queen
H1 check will pick up the queen a skewer
on the diagonal and there's one other
thing you want to avoid like the plague
and that is to push your F money or F
Pawn is what gives the king the shelter
that it needs to dodge the possibility
of White's Queen interposing a check
with a check of its own if you play F5
either after Queen G6 Queen E4 or right
now unprovoked you give the White Queen
access to the seventh Rank and that's
the best way to complicate the process
progress and hesitating Queen D1 check
is on the board this is Child's Play
This is basic Betty and uh I think we're
gonna see a peaceful conclusion in a
couple of minutes here
it looked at the start like prognanda
was going to lose a fourth game in his
last five but the resilience he has
shown is a testament to his strength I
mean his age belies the fact that he is
a true fighter he has had a lot of
experience in many of these events he's
just going to give checks he knows he
has the draw so he just is going to go
back and forth and he's going to split
the point with the world champion a
great showing after a tough stretch from
prognanda
a great showing indeed he is going to
cherish this result for a long time
holding the world champion to a draw
with the black pieces is no easy matter
Magnus continues uh to think he's trying
to find some pathway with his King uh
that generates more Intrigue but I think
it's just Perpetual check there there's
nowhere to go and Magnus might very well
just repeat moves with King D3 and King
E3 but a great thing if you're Prague is
that you're one of the low rated
participants in the tournament and even
though he's got a minor score at this
point I think he's actually gaining
rating or if he's losing rating it's not
very much so he is still very much on
the path to 2700 and Beyond
okay and looks like it is about to be a
three-time repetition uh Prague looks up
at Magnus he knows this draw here's the
draw agreed and the clock is stopped and
Magnus and oh no that's not where the
King goes no no no no no Magnus you
didn't win the game
that's funny you put the Kings on the
light squares like that when white wins
you put them in the dark squares and
black wins but you put them in front of
each other when it's a draw so that was
just you know a Mindless Thing by Magnus
after a long game a cheater they're
talking about it uh they're gonna
analyze a bit and there is a lot of
respect between these two of course
everyone has respect for Magnus
Carlson's chess he has been the best
player in the world for so long now but
prognanda he's on the rise and he has
secured a draw against Magnus Carlson
and these two draws that Magnus made
against the Indian Junior skukesh and
pragnananda they have really sunk is uh
attempt to complete the comeback and
come back to win the tournament now with
a win in the last round he can still put
himself in Prime position to score uh on
the podium but obviously this is going
to be a very very tough build to swallow
especially given the kind of position
that Magnus had after the opening those
are games that we are accustomed uh to
the world champion winning you know nine
times out of ten and this tournament
he's just been topsy-turvy he's made
uncharacteristic mistakes but taking
nothing away from prognananda who should
be proud of this game and his defense of
resilience
yes great game for probably not enough
for Magnus Carlsen he moves to seven
points out of 12 games so he remains a
full point behind the leader no dear
back up to satara Niche Gary in second
he still is playing his game uh well
whether he will draw win or lose that is
up in the air nobody knows not even him
or his opponent because it is an end
game but it is complex of Magnus and
probably gonna still talking about this
game that they just played uh the
players must be exhausted but they love
chess they want to talk about it they
want to see what the other person was
planning if they had changed their moves
throughout the game and they want to
know the truth they want to know the
truth about the position they are
scientists and uh these are people who
have dedicated their entire lives to
mastering their craft and if you know it
means sitting at the board for another
five to ten minutes after a six hour
game then that's what they're going to
do Prague gets up they're going to get
some dinner and get some rest before the
last game aronian isn't able able to get
some rest just yet he is knocking on the
door of a very impressive defensive
effort against dukesh but he has a
little bit of work left to be done white
actually has two extra pawns at this
point but I think it's a situation in
which there is just no progress to be
made without giving one of those pawns
up
it looks like gukesh is trying to see
what's happening at the other boards
magnus's game has just concluded but
lavona Ronin he has shown great
technique in this end game because he is
down two full pawns at the moment but
the game is a draw the white Pawn A7 has
gone too far that means The Rook on G7
is stuck on the seventh right going back
and forth to the defend the Rook on h8
covers the promotion Square the one
thing black should not do and Lavon of
course knows this is he's not going to
play Rook 8 and quickly take the pawn on
A7 because that's how you lose games
like this if you play brocade and the
white king goes to C4 and you take the
pawn you're about to see what the evil
bar is going to do it's winning for
white because of the Rook trade and King
to C5 uh well qb5 there's Kingdom yeah
King C5 you get to initiate the
opposition and that would lead to a win
as the B Pawn will promote so indeed
look at Lavon he gives a check he'll go
right back to continue the checking and
then bring his Rook to the eighth rank
as is needed and that should hold the
balance yeah you literally don't have to
do anything if you're black and you
should not be afraid of the move B5 why
can push the pawn up to B5 but he can
push it no further the king is going to
remain on B6 as long as the Rook stays
on G7 the moment moves away black
captures on A7 and when you're trying to
defend King rook and pawn versus King
and Rook the easiest type of situation
is uh either a corner Pawn or a night
Pawn because when one side has a knight
Pawn you don't even need to have the
Philadelphia position you can actually
keep your Rook uh passively on the
eighth Rank and there isn't enough real
estate in this case on the left side of
the board to push Black's King off of
its defensive post this is a dead drawn
the only question is when gukesh is
going to sort of admit that there's a
funny way that black can lose this game
let's say King B3 mm-hmm
Rook H3 check King A4 and you get clever
and you play oh I gotcha
put a queen on the board for a second
and you're gonna see the eval bar drop
because Rook A1 is check and you screw
up the queen on eight and get into a
drawn king of rook and pawn ending but
you promote to a knight with check and
that allows white to win the game
because the King has to move that means
now oh look at this baby
nasty yeah even without the Checkmate
you're gonna win but that is just
grotesque and so that's what you have to
avoid is getting fancy Lavon knows he
just needs to just slide his Rook back
to the eighth rank not the first Rank
and that means the pawn is stuck in its
tracks one of the truest cliches in
chess is that you can always find a way
to lose there's always meat on the bow
no matter how basic or well defined the
position may appear but even if Lavon
misses A8 night there's just no need uh
to move the Rook away from the eighth
rank unless of course you are giving
checks kukesh still hopeful he plays the
move King B3 Lavon could throw another
check in on H3 and he does good call by
you but we are going to see Rook h8
rather than Rook H1
what's always fascinating me about Lavon
is that he makes moves with his left
hand but he's a ready because I feel
like that is convenient and it's
efficient because you make a move then
you write with the other hand but most
people make their chest moves with the
same hand that they write their notation
so they were all inefficient and Lavon
just you know he knows what's up but it
has always stood out to me for some
reason
yeah that's an interesting property and
I thinking about myself I almost never
make moves to the left hand just feels
like I have better control over the
pieces but you know to each their own
and through cash setting one final
Pitfall it's easy to get excited at the
prospect of Rook takes H7 and Rook to A7
check winning the newly minted Queen but
in that case White Once Again gains the
opposition with King A5 avoid that with
a 10 foot pole move the Rook anywhere
else along the eighth Rank and white has
no way to make progress
that's a really instructive line just
like the variation we're showing earlier
the king and pawn end game is winning
for white because you're the one with
the white pieces who creates the
opposition and black is going to have to
leave that opposition and then the white
king will inch forward help the pawn
promote so that's an elementary King and
pawn end game should learn that it would
be very beneficial for you and of course
Lavon knows those end games that's why
he just moves his Rook away and he is
not RP he is not going to take the pawn
A7 so after a draw has been agreed
actually they shake hands because the
one would not have taken the pawn
instead it is a split point and Levon
he's kind of hitting his head but what
was I thinking at this point why did I
do that I got in trouble for no reason
yeah this was a a very quiet game
initially it was a regosan where Lavon
looked very very solid but then he kind
of stumbled into this Pawn down end game
and we do believe at least according to
our superficial analysis the gukesh did
have a uh a win at probably at least one
point uh where he dropped his King back
to C4 instead you should have
prioritized uh optimizing the placement
of his Rook he's definitely going to be
kicking himself for that but the chest
gods they have a way of sort of
balancing things out you get unlucky
sometimes but of course kukesh also had
that game against barhamak Zulu that
could have very easily gone the other
way
right so he was fortunate to receive
that point here a bit
not to be disappointed or displeased but
he was playing it seemed like a nice
game after the opening and he had his
chances but Lavon remains solid Stout
defense he made the draw so that leaves
us with one game remaining the one
between Jordan Von forest and Anish giri
and Dania I I think we're in a position
that comes as no surprise The Rook slid
all the way to B2 because it could no
longer cover the D5 square and it was
under attack on F2 and so it Bishop D5
black is going to bring the king up to
E7 and the king is going to get out off
the last Rank and it's anybody's game at
this point yeah but
yes black will do that but it will come
at a very very steep cost white will
finally be able to eliminate that uh irk
some demonic Pawn on A2 and of course he
will breathe a lot easier once that is
completed but you're right if black
improves the placement of his King
White's pawns kind of gets stuck because
white doesn't have that dark squared
Bishop to push the F Pawn forward to F6
or the epon up to E7 and at that point
it would be very easy to lose control of
the game so yet again for the umpteenth
time Jordan has a decision to make he
can bring the king back to F4 calling
for a repetition of moves that black
obviously cannot and will not refuse or
you go right into uh the line that we
are discussing with Bishop to D5 what do
you think Jordan is going to do
hmm
and these are a bishop D5 I I believe
that he's gonna go right after the A2
Pawn C7 is loose and some of those
positions could be very good for white
even if you it costs your Bishop for the
A2 Pawn you'll have a three pawns three
pass pawns for The Rook so Anish gear
right now with the black pieces against
Jordan Von Forest he has the white
pieces in the last game so he would love
to win and be tied with abusotarev but
let's say he only Drew he gets white in
the final game he's got his chances if
not your back is unable to win his so
you can't put all your eggs in one
basket you can't go all out in this game
you have to play the position and I do
think he has winning champions here with
black if his King can get out in the
open Anish Gary can take down Jordan
from force and that would be so
surprising given the start of this game
yeah that would be insane and I think
the players have saved the F the best
for Less we're about to get some
fireworks because Jordan run for us he
hasn't played Bishop D5 he's played a
different winning attempt King E3 2D
Force the King has maneuvered its way
from deep into the king side now to the
center and the ball is squarely in a
niche Geary score now the issue as we've
outlined before with the move King E7 is
that white captures on C7 and with the
King on D4 black can't even move to D6
because the king just gets checkmated
with Rook D7 while if the king moves to
F6 it can always be checked away from
there by uh Rook F7 check so the ball
back in an initi Gary's Court he's got
19 minutes or so on the clock those four
minutes are gonna turn into another 15
minutes since the final time control has
been reached but I don't envy his
position
Robert what comes to mind here does he
go back to F2 does he give a check on d8
I'm kind of at a loss here
I'm looking I'm trying to better
understand because if your king goes up
to E7 you're saying Rook takes C7 check
the king would have to go up to F6 at
that point
is the king somehow like running up the
board but those past pawns looks way too
scary
and more importantly The Rook just comes
back to A7 and I don't even see a way
for black to force white to give up the
bishop for that pawn you just lose the
C7 Pawn
so what is White's next move going to be
let's think of it let's try to reverse
engineer this is Jordan's next Bishop D5
or is he actually trying to go King E5
and squeeze the king into F6 wait that's
really scary now that you've made
terrified variation I think that might
mean that black has to run up with the
King because oh no let's say you make
let's say you make the move Rook C2 just
a random move
King E5
and the game is over it's winning the
king is just going up the board and then
Bishop D5 will happen Okay you can play
Rook D2 at some point let's go Rook D2
instead oh my God can I show a beautiful
line though I I know exactly what you're
gonna show if you do allow Bishop D5 and
you just continue shuffling look at this
Rook A8 and that pawn on C6 is gonna be
the unsung uh I was gonna say The Unsung
Tyler the unsung hero that would be way
too obscure of a reference uh to The
Mating construction the bishop delivers
the Checkmate on F7 but pick it up from
there black and of course play the move
Rook D2 where is the crusher here
oh
no I was I would say is it bring the
Rook to the H file like swinging it
around is it G5 H5 yeah nicely nicely
spotted who would have thought that the
bishop would land on H5 we thought it
was like on conclusion that Jordan was
gonna stick it on D5 here it attacks The
Rook from the other side and should The
Rook move E7 and white can simply
promote to a queen The Rook has the a
pawn taken care of
The Rook on A7 is doing so much it's
covering the A1 promotion square and
threatening Rook takes C7 in many
positions include the light position
because the niche Geary he brought his
King up to the seventh rank he went King
G7 King E7 probably could have been met
by some kind of King E5 so he wants to
stay farther away from that King and he
was King G7 and now if Rook takes E7
check he's going to go King F6 and it
looks almost like the black king is made
Let's just put that on the board for a
second we can of course right back to
the Y position but King F6 Rook F7 check
is not mate oh King slithers out to G5
and then to F4 wow wait a second there
could be a mating net that King on D4
doesn't have much room to operate either
it certainly doesn't and The Bishop's
gonna be hanging and after the move Rook
to A7 you'd be forgiven for thinking
that white is completely winning but no
the D file is now wide open and it's for
it's it's there for the taking and black
will take it Rook d8 check sending the
king stack now the other Rook goes out
to F2 and we just have total pandemonium
just utter chaos on the board but black
definitely has the idea of playing Rook
D1 and promoting to a queen of course
Rook D1 is met with E7 so be that as it
may this is one way that the game could
explode but I have another proposal for
you Rook takes C7 is not forced and I'm
struggling to find a response here to
the move King E5 with the idea of
meeting the check on B5 with Bishop to
D5
or is there rook d8 in that case Rook d8
there is you can show that variation oh
it's so important good for black Rook B5
check
and after because of Bishop D5 rook d8
and you win that bishop and of course
it's still oh I should say is of course
it's still gonna be equal no it is not
it looks winning it is winning you take
on D5 with check Rook D7 is too slow A1
equals Queen with check so that means
that black is either going to promote or
win that Bishop 1 D5 and maybe just both
and initiary had to foresee that detail
when bringing his King up to G7 wait go
to that line again okay this is crazy
Bang King E5 rugby five Bishop
Rook d8 Rook takes C7 check okay
King G8 oh not
uh yeah King Jade okay uh Rook A7
okay
Rook eight takes D5 and King F6
threatens you know a Perpetual check
with rookie eight Rook a seven or the C
Pawn going out to promote but after Rook
A5 and that's why you took with the d8
Rook you cut the Rook oh and you're
gonna promote the check and it's so
crucial to that you promote this track
otherwise you lose white plays C7 and
makes him queen of his own with
immediate ladder checkmate but A1 Queen
is a track and whites King has no other
options it can drop back let's say to E4
and maybe it should
Rook A5
and if C7 you take the Rook on A7 and
once the promotion happens oh my God you
just run your king to H7 and you're
gonna promote A1 that's Unstoppable and
Rooks on the seventh rank have been the
order of the day for Anish Curry first
that Rook on G7 the MVP of the middle
game The Rook on A7 here is the MVP of
the end game because after King takes D1
nope you not make a knight uh you make a
queen there are no checks on the seventh
right the king is safer than it's been
all game long what an insane set of
lines the ornament Forest is cupping his
head with his hands and for very good
reason
what a wildly complex position and a
major choice to be made here between
Rook takes C7 check which I think he's
going to play and King E5 and those
moves aren't forced either there's also
our old friend Bishop D5 which needs to
be considered as well but I think it's
very unlikely because that King on D4
could be victimized with Rook to d8
yeah that looks like a problem four
white so Bishop D5 is what you want to
play it doesn't look like you can get
away with it so I think he's just gonna
go ahead and take this Pawn to C7 with
check and after the king runs up to F6
he will have to bring his back towards
A7 and cover the A1 Square you cannot
afford that pawn getting to the other
side no you can and I just have to
commend the players on maintaining their
objectivity deep into hours six uh sorry
into the seventh hour of their game
they've been playing for six hours uh
and a couple minutes so far it's been a
pretty flawlessly played end game ever
since the Queens uh have been taken off
the board of course the ordin's grave
mistakes came earlier in the game but
Robert as we both know as the clock
inches down to zero and as fatigue
continues to pile up mistakes and major
blunders they become likelier than ever
and for an East carry he can't afford to
slip up here he's played such a good
defensive game and there was that moment
where he probably was objectively lost
the engines found some wild uh sequences
to win the game for Jordan but Jordan's
only human and in this position it's
still possible for black to lose look at
how many past pawns white has but and he
cannot afford to drop this half point
because he at the moment is one point
behind abdusitarov when he draws if he
draws he'll be a half Point going into
the 13th and Final Round And in each his
opponent for tomorrow is somebody who
has been on quite a tear in recent
rounds it is Richard's report so Anish
gets the white pieces in round 13
against Richard report a few rounds ago
was that's a great last round pairing
right now I'm not so sure yeah I mean
research report with just a crushing win
today against dingley Wren he always
plays creatively it is a good pairing in
so far as you know that you will get
your fair share of chances report isn't
just going to try to go for a cowardly
draw in the last round he's going to
play something interesting but Anish
giri has to avoid losing this game if he
wants to keep his chances alive his
realistic chances alive King to F6
Jordan has indeed taken the pawn on C7
there's that additional check on F7
driving the king further into Exile on
the king side and Rook has to return to
A7 and it does
yeah you may think why would you help
the black king go off the board because
that means it's more distant from the
pawns that are trying to promote there
are three past pawns a C6 pawn and the
F5 Pawn as well so if black plays King
F4 and releases control of the F6 Square
maybe what even plays the move F6 giving
up the bishop on F3 because all of the
pawns are running to the other side this
is a position that is impossible to get
a grasp on and of course the eval bar
saying zeros it's even yep what a head
spinning position but Anish Gary
believes he has a grasp on it because he
has played very quickly once again if
you're just joining us do not be fooled
by the clock times there is an
additional 15 minutes waiting for the
Players Once the clock time goes down to
zero but still 18 minutes 16 minutes
that is absolutely nothing in a position
of this complexity but Geary instantly
delivering that check on d8 he believes
that it's a pretty non-committal move
and it helps Black's cause now another
choice for white you can see five King
E5 King C3 King E3 Bishop D5 there's
like six different ways to block that
check Robert
yeah where is the king going uh
King C5 or King the C file in general
Rook C2 check looks like a good option
and what if the king runs all the way up
so King C5 okay let's pull up our
analysis board which we'll need a lot of
if you're an fc2 check can't the king go
up to B6
that's exactly where I'm going and now
you see
white is better here black loses
instantly if white picks up the a pawn I
think I understand what black needs to
do I think you need to get this position
and you need to chill out and play a
move like King back to F6 and the point
is that the moment white plays C7 he
loses the umbrella for the king and now
you start the series of vertical checks
the king can't step onto the a file
obviously and if it steps onto the C
file it has to maintain contact with the
C7 Pawn otherwise black can actually
capture it with his Rook
so we might get a repetition kind of
like this if
uh in fact Jordan goes up to C5
wow wait until the pond goes One Step
from promotion and give an endless
series of checks but that's not the
first time today we saw what happens if
there's a pawn shielding the king in
Magnus Carlson's game against Prague
Nanda if Max could get his King behind
Prague down his Pawn we saw there was a
variation where it would have been
winning Paragon did not fall for it it
was able to hold but that is important
to note that the white king would like
to be on C7 so that it is shielded from
checks not going to happen
Jordan is thinking right now if he
brings his King back to C3 where he
attacks The Rook on B2 I think the black
Rook is going to slide over to the F2
squared to attack the bishop gain the
tempo and the bishop will have to find a
place to go and I think the Rook will
continue to chase it yeah that Bishop is
short on squares D5 is covered it can go
to up to E4 but you're right the Rook
can continue to chase it with rookie two
uh and if Bishop H1 Rook H2 kind of
similar to anishkiri's earlier idea with
the Rook deflection right rook d8 and
Rook D4 wherever weitzer it goes black
black stroke goes there too I'll have
what she's having and I if I had to make
a prediction I think we're gonna see a
draw along the lines of King C5 King F6
and then C7 it's amazing that White's
pawns aren't more mobile than they
appear I mean this looks so impressive
but that Rook on d8 is doing a fantastic
job of taking the sting out of White's
passers
I think Anish just left but I'm not sure
what it was about it this position is
one that you can't help but smile at
because when you ever see a game with
these connected past pawns like white
has and a bishop for rook and then black
has this Pawn A2 I don't think I've seen
a position like this ever it's really
crazy
and I don't remember who it was uh but
there was some Grand Master and some
obscure interview who I think advocated
for four stages of the game in some
cases so if we were to trace uh this
game and that would be a hard task in
and of itself because of how many
Transformations we had there was the
opening phase where Jordan demonstrate
excellent preparation the middle game
phase where Jordan had a win he could
have capitalized on his attack but
instead committed several errors and
enabled Niche to trade queens and there
was the sort of positional end game
phase where the Queens had just gotten
traded the players were posturing for
position trying to get their pieces to
the best squares but now we almost have
a fourth stage of the game which I would
call a tactical end game this type of
end game has very little to do with the
type of position that we had when the
Queens first came off the board in this
position calculation is the only thing
that matters general principles and
peace placement all of that goes out the
window it's all based on calculation
and they're going to continue to
calculate here because it's not it's not
basic this is actually quite an
interesting end game because when The
Rook comes to F2 to attack the bishop
the second Rook for black would love to
come down to D1 and help the pawn
promote but white has two passers of his
own you see how quickly Jordan brings
his Bishop to E4 now and if you give him
a free turn he might have Bishop back to
C2 Donya cutting the Brooklyn F2 off
from the Pawn on A2 and not only Mighty
played I think he has to play it because
if you say okay time for a draw and you
go back to F3 no no no their Bishop
actually gets picked off by blackstroke
same goes for Bishop H1 white black
plays rookie one with a double threat of
Rook takes H1 and A1 equals Queen and
sacrificing the bishop here isn't
something that white can afford because
the pawns they are not going to promote
without the supervision of at the very
least White's King and White's king is
too far away so after rookie two Bishop
D3 Robert black will probably play
rookie three and we might after all get
a bishop sacrifice
wow weird way but spoiled here what is
white no no no no rookie two will play
Bishop C that's Bishop C2 okay yeah no
it's we've uh been at it for six and a
half hours you're forgiven don't worry
but Bishop C2 Cuts The Rook off from the
A2 pawn and I but even that's not over
like if we
he's going for it
okay so I will I won't make the moves
I'll let the players make the moves
he's about to do it but I was going to
say that the Rook on d8 will slide up to
D6 and win the C6 pawn and then we
didn't figure out does that offer
winning chances for either side
another transformation
yep
and I could see I mean I could see the
game fizzling out if in fact
black at some point plays H5 and cuts
into White's Pawn chain and then the
worst case scenario black and Sack a
rook for the two remaining Pawns of
course oh my gosh let's not even mention
that possibility because we're gonna be
here until uh the round starts tomorrow
at 6 a.m two hours earlier than normal
well King takes G4 is possible I'm
wondering about that right now
because
here's rookie two but now I'm wondering
could you play King takes G4 just a
second ago
the white pawns are are Advanced but
they're not actually able to get to the
other side
that is a can of worms I don't know if I
even would want to consider now I think
it's almost a certainty at this point
that we will get a trade of the C6 spawn
for the A2 pawn bishop C2 is forced and
Jordan does not Tarry
and Rook C8 Rook D6 I think that leads
to the same outcome
yes because Rook C8 there is no Pawn to
C7 The Rook will take on C7 and that
will distract the white rook and the Evo
bar is starting to suggest maybe black
is the tiniest bit better here
yeah I mean in the resulting position
white actually has you brought up a
great point which is that G4 is hanging
right it is and in the right set of
circumstances it could be captured by
the king because F6 could uh signal the
death of White's kingside Pawn chain and
if black is able to you know Massacre
White's gang side bondsman black is
still up in exchange that's uh the
fundamental fact about this position
which makes it so hard to play for
Jordan
I'm just looking at these two players
and I'm kind of in awe the amount of
calculating they have done throughout
this game it's been a maze tons of
landmines it's a an obstacle course
where instead of you know having a ball
pit where you're having a good time
you're just like dodging uh those
uh what do they call them like the
punching bag that's being thrown towards
you and it's gonna hit you in the face
but somehow these two have really been
proving their strength throughout
there has been a situation where white
at the upper hand and then Anisha found
some defensive resources and since then
the eval has not changed it has hovered
around zeros
ever since they entered this exchange up
end game for a niche where White had
they passed pollen so crazy stuff and
kudos to the players and kudos to Jordan
who's declined about 17 repetitions the
only issue is that I'm getting slight
maksudu caruana Vibes where haramaxulu
did something similar totally different
types of type of position it was more
manageable tactically but it was a dead
draw maxoulu kept trying and kept trying
and he got a peace and balance and
ultimately he declined one last
repetition and he got himself into a
losing Queen end game so the ornament
Forest it's important to draw the line
somewhere and he might have already gone
one step too far at this point Black's
task might be just a bit easier
and Rook D6 is on the board of Niche
giri I think by getting up from his
chair and he didn't do that for very
long I think he's feeling pretty spry
right now
yeah I think he sees the draw in this
game because uh I don't think that black
can really win as soon as king takes G4
out well he can't really play King James
before in many of his positions anyway
because the bishop D1 pins and things
like that but if he's gonna take out C6
first the white king is gonna slide over
to D3 to attack that Rook on E2 and then
and each needs to find a good Square for
that Rook along the second rank or along
the e-file
yeah I think probably he will keep it on
the e-file and Jordan can keep pursuing
it with this King we could get another
of these types of repetitions with
endless Pursuit
but Jordan needs to play with energy
here as I said earlier you can't really
afford to give up the G4 Pawn because
the corner Pawn on the opposite side of
the board might then decide the game
right you can only give the G4 Pawn if
your f-pawn is free but Rook takes C6
speaking of free that's a free Pawn with
check Anish finally plays it and I think
they're
trying to avoid their own exhaustion
like 66 was obvious but you don't want
to make a quick movement blunder when
you've already been playing for 70 plus
moves and they're undoubtedly the tire
doesn't cut it they're white
there's a point at which you stop seeing
straight where you literally start
hallucinating that the bishop is on B2
rather than C2 and uh that is a very
disturbing point in the game and you
need to have as a top player the
metacognition to know when that level of
exhaustion has been reached I think this
is what you're saying it has been
reached on hours six and a half of the
game
so you need to double triple check stuff
because you know at some point you make
the kinds of blunders which you would
never make in a lifetime but the rules
are different when you've played this
freaking game for six and a half hours
and counting
well the rules of the game still remain
the same but yes for these players they
just have to Parry off the exhaustion
you know thoughts that are not about
Chess and you see Anish he's grabbing
his Rook he slides it all the way to H2
kind of an important lesson even though
most of us kept the balance he put his
Rook on H2 to be on the opposite color
of the enemy Bishop so there weren't
going to be checks last king's not dark
square but you know what I mean Dania
you just want to avoid
that possibility
for sure you want to build into your
moves a sort of Fail-Safe mechanism even
if it's not likely that a bishop lands
on e4 if both moves lead to the same
conclusion why not make the one that uh
is less likely to get you into trouble
tactically Rook H2 is on the board and
obviously E7 does not promote the pawn
the other Rook stops it from the eighth
Rank and after E7 Rook C8 Jordan could
try to find a way to sacrifice his
Bishop in order to complete uh the
progress of the pawn and that is one way
that we could get liquidation and a draw
for instance if we could pull up an
analysis board one more time after E7
Rook C8 obviously the bishop is pinned
so you can't go Bishop A4 you can
however play the move Rook to a six and
after Rook takes C2 the simplest path to
a draw is actually to promote
immediately and now black has a choice
you could take the queen and take G4 or
you could force a repetition by giving
an endless series of checks of course
the white King has to remain in
permanent in contact with blackstrokes
to be able to capture it once black
takes the queen could the other Rook
take on C2 like instead of
that's funny
oh whoa
it can can't it yeah oops
no no no and as a king and actually
white has to I mean without ding D3
would be losing yes and I black should
probably not take on E8 because you take
the queen does Rook G6 check Intermezzo
and you have to be real careful there
actually King F3 also leads to a draw
which is crazy because after Rook takes
the gate no this isn't mate but it is a
Perpetual where it takes H6 and Rook G6
that would be a really funny ending to
the game but you already you won't play
with fire uh if he goes down this line
he's gonna go for the simpler draw and
e7's on the board I think we're very
likely uh to see exactly this type of
conclusion
and that would be a fitting end to what
has been a mesmerizing game a repetition
with the Rooks checking the king and the
King unable to escape because uh their
queen that was just promoted will be
captured so these two players what an
effort they have given uh still some
details remain they need to make sure
that they blunder check that works to
sieto seems to take care of business and
a niche of course is hovering around
that Rook he's going to play Rook to C8
only move but he is tired he's making
sure that it is the correct one and
actually at this point Jordan has to go
for the draw here because if he Dilly
Dally's first of all there's just
nothing productive that he can do
because the bishop is pinned but it
makes him move like Rook B2 Geary will
go after the E7 pawn and the last thing
you want with white is to have to defend
a worse position for another 50 move so
Jordan's gonna move his Rook it doesn't
matter actually where he moves it A6 A7
because the response to Rook takes E2 he
will promote to a queen I would move it
to A6 so that in the event the black
takes on E8 you are making contact with
the H6 Pawn crazy line so Rook uh A6
okay
I was just thinking if you invert the
move order and after Rook C takes C2 so
that work takes do not play Rook G6
check
because the King goes to F4 and now
after E8 equals Queen The Rook comes to
D2 with checkmate
oh no you didn't
yep never too late to blunder
so yeah here you have to remote without
procrastinating and we've already been
through this line I can take with either
rook and either check along the rank or
check along the file all of it leads to
the same results and Jordan leaning back
in his chair I think he has accepted the
inevitable you might offer a draw or he
might play these moves out one way or
the other the result is finally not in
question
Rook A6 Rook A6 we are going to see Gary
take this bishop on C2 and he can take
with either Rook but look at him he is
fully concentrated uh that is a player
who is very experienced he's a five-time
runner-up In This Very competition and
well that may sound like well he's never
won and people get on his case about it
Magnus likes to troll him but being
second place in this event five separate
occasions that's the sign of great
success because he's gained rating
points he has performed above 2800 in
many of those tournaments and you see
him he is really just trying to make
sure that the draw is not going to be
Out Of Reach he cannot afford the
blunder he is about to take but he holds
himself back he's showing some restraint
as it is very late in the day in the
Netherlands check it one more time and
what a save this will be for Anish giri
who puts himself uh in contention for
first place going to the last round of
course Notre back he was hoping for
nothing more than and uh for Jordan
benforce to convert that attack but he
will have his work cut out for him
against the very same Jordan van forest
and I'm so excited to see what course
that game is going to take Robert I can
see many different scenarios possible
now motorbeck has the white pieces and
let's be real if he really wants a draw
then he should be able to make it no
matter what Jordan throws at him I mean
I don't think Jordan's gonna do anything
ridiculous I don't think he's going to
go E4 G6 uh and get a bad position just
to say that he fought for a win but if
Notre back draws then nishikiri's path
is in his own hands
that's right because when you're a half
Point behind somebody you really hope
that the person in the lead draws and a
niche will have to win with the white
pieces and he plays Richard's report you
never know what to expect from Richard
he's playing a very good
tournament now that he's won a bunch of
games but the start with shaky and a
niche speaking of shaky all right time
to take the bishop Anish yeah take the
bishop with your rook and he is finally
going to do it nope he's done that like
four or five times now and that's
obviously a sign of nerves it's a sign
that he he just that wants to avoid a
blunder at all costs but there's just
nothing to calculate here Rook takes C2
is an insta draw
it's the heavy down here come on you
like basketball he's just you know
showing off he's just there it is that's
the Euro Step
and there we see a queen it's promoted
and we're gonna see this draw pretty
quickly I believe yes we are check check
the King has to go to the side and I
feel like Jordan and Denise were aged
like a year in this game yeah
how much energy they might have lost
some weight as a result of this game
alone Robert that is not an Outlander
statement that is proven that players
exhaust themselves exert themselves so
much these types of games that they
actually lose a couple pounds
in their case a couple kilos but uh yes
Jordan looking to the side he's making
sure that he is not going to make a
mistake that variation that you
mentioned with the King going to F3 was
quite funny but I think he'll just go
King D3 and Anish he's got a little
smile on his face and he knows the
result is about to be have a draw
between these two yeah oh my gosh what a
fight
incredible it's a 78 move game and how
some 78 Move games aren't all that
eventful you get a certain type of
position and then the players Shuffle
their pieces for 50 moves not here there
was action and fireworks until the very
last move and what uh A fitting end to
this game as you said with a queen on
the board Anish Geary carefully delivers
the check on D2
and we're going to see a handshake
momentarily here we'll get to check
players are gonna carry out the three
move repetition and they are going to
shake hands and look at Anish he's
laughing and I think perhaps he's
laughing because otherwise he'll cry and
that was a game that took everything
from the players every last bit of
energy exhausted and I just have to give
them a round of applause because yeah
they gave it they're all Jordan Forest
he is not in contention for first place
but he wanted to take down his
compatriot gain rating points and it you
know he loves to be in Vikings he came
to determined ever since he was 10 years
old and for Anish giri he is looking to
win his first
championship in tata steel he would love
to win in front of his home crowd and he
had all of you know the the Dutch
faithful watching this game as they
usually do when these two go at it uh
but he had to give it his all because he
was on the verge of losing and he
managed to survive and they're still not
done they're gonna spend some time
discussing the game I think the Arbiter
is ready to go home although we still
actually have a Challengers game that is
ongoing I think that might be uh half
the face of adibon in the foreground but
that completes today's Masters matches
we had a pretty peaceful day on paper
Robert but not on the board every single
game had its own character its own
personality and nobody had an easy day
definitely not the two losers our
generic icy and dingley ren who fall to
Parham and Richard report respectively
and we have been set up for what will
undoubtedly be a magical round tomorrow
it was a magical day today
it wasn't with the leaders at the top
drawing their games the happiest person
in this tournament is not your back
Abdus Atara because he entered the round
the Half Point Clear of Anish giri he
exits the round a half Point Clear of
anishikiri Magnus Carlsen Wesley so they
also Drew as Lavon veronian and Fabio
caruana so we are down to four people
who can possibly mathematically win
first place the inside track is Noir
back Abdus ataros it is his event for
the taking and he can clinch tomorrow's
title if he is abled to win his game
right he has a half one head if he wins
the tournament is his but even the last
player in the standings will play his
part in this tournament Arjun aragaisy
has struggled mightily he lost his
fourth game of the event but Gordon Von
Forest just two above him he takes on
abusotaro so a player in 12th Place will
impact the leaderboard Dania it is going
to be pretty Epic final day tomorrow
taught us teal it's such a prestigious
event it is the event that most of these
players look forward to the most each
year even though it is a marathon and
there we see uh the scenarios in which
notrebec clinches the tournament
obviously a win guarantees clear first
and if he draws and Geary manages to
come up with a clutch last round Victory
notorbeck's work will be cut out for him
and Anish giri will get the chance to
play a third tiebreaker he lost the
first two to Carlson and Ben Forrest
will the third time be the charm well
he's not thinking about that heat will
cross that bridge if we get there even
with a loss notrebed could claim uh a
share of first place but it is very
likely that at the very least Gary will
be able to draw with the white pieces so
Notre back he needs to play solid he
needs to play the kind of Chess that he
has played all tournament long what a
treat it has been to watch him what a
treat it has been to watch all of these
games with you Robert the last two days
Yeah tomorrow's action promises to be
quite a lot of fun we see at the top
abusatar with the white piece against
Jordan Forest Anish Gary with the white
pieces against Richard report and then
Magnus and Wesley they need nerdirect to
lose they are going to be rooting
heavily for Von Forest but as you said
with the white pieces it seems difficult
to imagine a loss happening but Jordan
front force and Richard report they are
the type of players who can take down
anybody it doesn't matter what color
they have it doesn't matter what country
they're playing in when they are feeling
it Tanya and they are showing that
Exquisite opening preparation like fun
Forest did yesterday instinctly ran and
today against Manish giri they can take
down anybody Richard report on a winning
streak as well
they most certainly can and they are
very much aware as I said earlier that
they can leave their fingerprints on
this tournament and on its final outcome
so nobody is relaxing even the players
who are no longer in contentious such as
pragnananda and of course dingley ran a
win in the last round will do a lot to
lift their spirits but ding's work has
definitely cut out him for him Fabiano
caruana has had a very solid event and
parhamaksudu will try to end the
tournament on a plus score Kesh we'll
try to end the tournament on minus one
and gain some rating so all of these
games are going to be fascinating but
our Focus obviously is going to be
squarely on the games that have the most
impact on the final Tournament standings
he leads with one round to go he isn't
clear first ahead of Anish Gary Magnus
Carlson and Wesley so still technically
have chances but the chances are not
very big so it is really kind of a
two-person race of digital tariff and
he's Curry we'll see tomorrow who will
be crowned the champion of the tots of
Steel 2023 but for now we say goodbye
remember that tomorrow's round is two
hours earlier yeah don't show up at the
same time you did today and expect to
see the start of the games Chuck two
hours earlier will be here it's been a
pleasure I'm Brett Master Robert Hess
this is Grandmaster Daniel neraditski
and on behalf of chess.com we say thank
you and see you tomorrow for the final
round
foreign
[Music]